[Music]
well hey everybody y it's Friday night
you know what that means time for
[__] rum and coke yeah well I mean
not usually but today we have rum and
coke usually I have vodka but today we
went to the liquor store and we're just
kind on to's like let's get rum instead
get some bardi yeah bardi Coke's good
yeah that's a plug for bikard right
there sponsored by sponsored by Bard
really not really I don't want to get
sued I haven't had that in a long time I
thought we just got it like a few weeks
ago didn't we I didn't eat I didn't
drink it with Coke oh I had it with
something
else we also got passion fruit yeah I
think I like it with Coke better though
I mean it's good either way so far it's
good either way so
today is Friday and we are ushering you
into the weekend yep sting here staying
in this evening so we can just sit here
and yep get shitfaced yep well I don't
know about shitfaced but maybe quasi
[__] yeah going to interact interacting
with our regular
fans and uh just talking about whatever
you guys want to talk about all kinds of
[__] happened and uh they [__]
spotted 10 foot [__]
extraterrestrials at a damn shopping
mall and all the cops came out you
didn't hear about
that all kinds of weird [__] has
happened well it was EV evidently what
had happened was is there was some
youths were shooting off fireworks
inside the shopping mall and a [__] ton
of cops showed up and helicopters and
everything it looked like [__] 100
cop cars showed up must have been a slow
day yeah I don't know it was a night
must have been a slow night and
um well you know they I guess they
didn't want fires going on or anything
but all these [__] cars cop cars
showed up and some people started saying
yeah there were aliens in there there
were 10ft tall aliens that were actually
behind all this [__] and it scared
everybody and they
were so there's there UFO angle with
that now I don't know if there's any uh
seems very random what would be great
yeah what would be great is if somebody
had some [__] cell phone footage of
some 10 foot tall [__] alien running
down the [__] sh ball it would have
been funnier if the aliens came to Earth
specifically just to [__] with people
and like they brought bottle rockets and
[__] like that and just set them off in
them all randomly and then they were
like he and then they got back in their
spaceship and took off that was a good
story hey man if Bell was still around
he'd be doing a show on that of course
he would hell yeah he'd have F he he'd
be having [__] people call in
Witnesses call in probably fake
Witnesses but or you know yeah he's like
calling up all his buddies he's like hey
can you call and like Make Pretend a
real thing call somebody representative
for the [__] police and start asking
him what happened and then he'd bring up
the aliens and see if what the cops knew
everything and then go it's a cover up
it's a cover up that's that's how it was
art art was explanation for everything
must be a cover up but no art was great
well his old I I think a lot of the
reason that a lot of people like that
show is that even if you didn't believe
in any of that [__] which I don't um it
was kind of cool because he just had a
policy that it was almost kind of like
this is a no judgment Zone we're just
going to pretend that every no matter
how [__] insane some of the [__] that
people said was we're just going to
pretend that it's completely PL well you
see what he what he would do is he would
not really push back yeah he would just
ask questions and they would say some
crazy [__] and you go I see where is
that like no I see well now well you
know isn't that something yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly it was like that um
yeah he didn't throw his own he didn't
throw his two cents into it he let the
guests just yeah and if uh he would he
was non-committal he didn't say oh well
that's is what happened he didn't have a
a narrative per se right he's just he
was just a good presenter and he was
real good at making everything sound
[__] mysterious
even if the [__] even if all the
details of the case [__] contradicted
each other he could still make an an
interesting show out of it yeah and make
it sound like might have been something
you know the star child skull you know
[__] that was wild man I was like
what the [__] is this is an early days
we did a show on that didn't we I think
so I don't know if we did an entire show
but I think we did like a show it was
kind of in the earlier days of the
internet I was just starting to get into
the internet and [__] um I had to go
to my girlfriend my she ended up being
my first wife I when I married had to go
to her office computer to look up to see
what the star child's skull actually
looked like and I saw it and I was like
man that's what they were talking about
man it must be real and they had some
just weird it was made out of the same
uh material that teeth were made out of
they said it's not normal bone uh that
said the proportions were all wrong it
does look like a [__] ET it's not
though
it's not it's a uh it was a deformed
child and they buried it occasionally
happens yeah what do they call it uh in
sephtis or no what do they call it
hydril yeah H hydril like water on the
brain El yeah yeah had a big round
head and uh it may have the skull
material might have been more like tooth
enamel who knows you know yeah all of
weird
[__] all kind of weird [__] Could Happen
genetic problems honestly I I read a
couple books about genetic mutations and
stuff like that and honestly I'm
surprised that anybody comes out looking
normal yeah considering how complicated
all that [__] is and how much [__] can
go wrong yeah the fact that most people
come out looking pretty much okay I'm
like that's amazing yeah I mean somebody
can correct me I think it was about a
year
old the the the baby I don't it wasn't
still born I I don't think I think it
was about a year old it it was enough to
where its head was it was made out of
bone not cartilage so it wasn't just you
know I think newborn babies they do have
real bone in them I think well not on
the top though it's not fused right a
lot of it's more like carage mine is
Fontanel right as they say I'm Raising
Arizona so they're not born as Bonsai K
kittens every watching the Wang about
that b I can't believe people actually I
can't believe people actually like fell
for that yeah people believe the FBI was
trying to [__] I'm like uh no yeah
there was an old internet rumor that
when kittens are born that their bones
are so flexible that you could throw
them on the ground and their bones would
bend and then snap back so you could put
them into like a round jar or multiple
round jars and they would grow like a
bonsai tree in there like that but a
kitten but it was a kitten and they the
site was claiming that they and they had
like weird pictures of the things that
did look like cats that were in the
shape of bonsai tree
but I mean just reading the copy on the
site I mean obviously it was a satire
but I guess some people aren't good at
picking that up yeah I thought it was
true I mean it's you know it's kind of
funny even though I I I have a really
hard time especially since we've got
cats like I have a hard time watching
anything that even if it's just pretend
like that has to do with like hurting
cats I'm just like uh Tammy said she
thinks this is her favorite wig I like
this one a lot too yeah yeah Tom got me
c Christmas I kind of dig
it I have another one that's like this
one that I got a long time ago that's
this short but it's just black but for
some reason I don't like it as much oh
the bangs are different on that one the
bangs are actually kind of short whereas
this one has long but you know what I
mean yeah said he had a whole playlist
of artbell yeah so Tammy ask how your uh
dad was doing uh he's gotten a little
bit
better um I'm going to go down there
Monday I'm going to rent a car I'm not
going to fly I'm going to drive once I
did all the the numbers and everything
what it cost a fly and would it be to
rent a car there and and then man I
don't want to go through all that
[__] and then just have just carry
on luggage and then be stuck in one spot
with my [__] relatives and [__] with
no car and no no ability to escape yeah
no ability to escape and [__] some just
going to drive I'm going to rent a car
and drive it's really you know like it
ends for me it ends up being like 400
bucks a week so I might have to stay two
weeks there so we'll just see I got
enough credit to do it yeah we'll see
how it goes yeah
so I'll I'll be off the show for a
little while probably at least a week
yeah so I'll just do the [__] by myself
CH we did this before anyway I was gone
two weeks last time yeah you were gone
two weeks last time when you went to see
your dad when he had the bypass I'll
hold down the fort yeah CU for a minute
I'll be on the show as a guest
or yeah you got to come in the chat and
comment it's just yeah there you go so
you can come in and like give me moral
support yeah cuz I'm kind of cuz he was
like well why don't you come with me and
I'm like well one the cats and two yeah
I got to work yeah so yeah yeah thing I
would like to go that that badass job
that Jenny got offered they called back
a couple days later oh I'm sorry we we
we can't do it the guys above me [__]
shut the whole thing down yeah so
they're not doing it now so I'm just
like okay well yeah [__] out it was
A50 $50,000 a year job yeah well it's
okay she she still got the other offers
though the remote work from home yeah so
it's a fraction of it but it's more yeah
it's not as much but it's not as many
hours so yeah she comes in she goes
universe hates me I said what
happened she said they told him that he
couldn't do the hiring after he said he
hired her but you see nothing was in
writing so you can't do anything legally
yeah because he had called me and said
um you know I'll email you like the
formal offer letter and all that other
kind of stuff and then I didn't get it
and I was like oh maybe he'll send it
tomorrow yeah and then he called me the
next afternoon yeah the formal offer
letter and he seemed to feel really bad
yeah so I guess like he got scoped by
the people above I don't really know
like why and he didn't know either he's
like I don't really know like why they
shut the whole thing down I would have
been the first designer that they hired
they didn't have and that company's in
some kind of restructuring there's a
bunch of power play going on in it so
I'm not really sure you might have
dodged a bullet yeah Poss company might
might be [__]
up I mean I was kind of bummed out
because I was just like you know I
didn't you know I don't necessarily want
to have to like commute and every day
and stuff like that like I used to but
for that amount of money I would I
happily would have done it CU I was like
oh wow I can pay off all my credit card
debt and I can we can get a new car and
all this other kind of stuff and so when
they called and just said oh never mind
um you know I was really pissed but then
like the more I thought about it I was
like well I'm not really in that
different a situation than I was in
before them calling me yeah so it's you
know it sucks but it's not really that
big well you got that other one though
too that you got a new client that that
that'll add up yeah yeah so that should
be okay it'll be about probably
half it' be about half the money monthly
yeah of what maybe a little less than
half but no gas and no no gas commuting
and and we don't have to get a new car
right away because we were thinking if I
got this job i' to buy a car we had to
buy a we would have to buy a car like
soon yeah cuz I don't really trust that
one long term yeah cuz you know it's
been a good car but it's old we're going
to get another one anyway yeah we are
but it's just you know now there's not
any rush there's not aush rush on it
because you know well cuz when you were
talking about going to see your dad and
at first you said um you know oh I'm
I'll drive out there and he was going to
take my car I'm like dude it it would
probably be out of the car though it
would probably make it I wasn't even
worried about that cuz I said look it's
like yeah it would suck being without a
car for a week or two but it's like I
don't really have anywhere to to go it's
like if I had to go to the store I can
walk there it's just right there it's
just right there so it's like that's
really the only place I would absolutely
need to go I don't want to drive that
[__] Rattle Trap around but that was
what I was worried about I was like
it'll probably make it but I wouldn't
trust it for that distance so and I
would worry about you you know what I
mean I don't want you like breaking down
on the side of the [__] highway
somewhere so so you said get a good so
you're just going to rent a car because
the thing about it was like he was going
to fly but you can get cheap flights
to New Orleans right yeah but not to
buxy but not to buxy right and not this
time of year and the thing about it is
like the super cheap flight to New
Orleans was from the Orlando Airport
yeah he wanted to fly from the Sanford
Airport because that is one much closer
to here and two it's much easier because
it's really small yeah so it's much much
and you could only do that in the
summertime I mean the Orlando Airport is
I mean you know it's obviously not as
big as like Atlanta or Denver
he or something like that but it's still
a [__] nightmare bigger than it was
yeah they built a whole other terminal
there's three terminals Orlando's much
bigger than it was 10 years ago and it's
just the traffic around there and it's
like and everybody's just coming there
to Disney World and nobody knows where
they're going and they're just and
they're just like all over there's five
lanes and they're just like wait how do
I get to Epcot where am I where is my
hotel and it's like so everybody's like
all over the road and it's just like
every time I have to drive to the
airport I have a panic attack plus I I
don't want to be you know uh
restricted to just carry on luggage like
I did last time because to be able to
take everything yeah so I get a car I'll
[__] pack all kinds of [__] up in my
car you know maybe go shooting or
something fcking uh yeah you can take
what don't have to worry about going
through [__] security or anything so
much easier bring all my injectable
[__] hormones and [__] that's another
thing about flying is that even if it's
more it might be slightly more expensive
to drive and yeah it takes longer but
carrying all that stuff but yeah I mean
flying is really not one I hate flying I
would always rather drive well I I love
to fly I hate airports yeah you hate
everything having to do with I think
most people do cuz it's just such an
ordeal yeah it's like I would rather pay
more and just [__] drive myself even
though I hate to drive too but it's like
I would much rather drive I would drive
cross country before I would fly I like
Choppers man they pick you up right
where you are and set you down right
where you want to go but you can't get
that in the civilian World unless you're
a
billionaire you can call somebody up and
like come get me man [__] land a
chopper out the backyard steal some rich
person's credit card and run a chopper
yeah come get me land on the roof like R
land the yard our back you can land in
the yard the backyard's big enough to
yeah you can [__] land you8 60 it's
all open yeah it's almost acre you can
put a ch47 out there
shook running out there with his little
yeah drop me down in front of my dad's
house all right I'm
here yeah yeah I think most of cuz he's
been been talking to a lot of his
relatives on yeah they're and a lot of
them are already there yeah so well not
a lot of them two of them two of them
are already there okay so I thought it
was my cousin and my aunt oh
okay and U he's not awake yeah they got
him sedated cuz he started pulling [__]
out he always gets Hospital
psychosis yeah he's in there's too long
he starts going crazy everybody
everybody here knows about the turkey
neck story thinks people turkey neck en
he thinks people are trying to kill him
that he's been abducted by a cult and
he's for real he he didn't recognize me
a couple times who are you now I I'm
just he go yeah that's right yeah yeah
yeah when he got the bypass well he was
threatening to like he was telling his
friend to go get his guns out of his
truck so they could shoot their way out
of there because he thought he'd been
kidnapped he thought he'd been kidnapped
so not great he when he snapped out of
it you know he told me over the phone he
says I couldn't he he was really
confused about how long he was in there
for the time and uh [__] what he did
and he didn't he didn't have a clear
recollection of everything and [__]
he gave a [__] crazy story you know
about what he thought had happened it
was like something out of
damn [__] Silent Hill he they
abducted me they had me down there and I
was
like I couldn't get out they had me tied
down I saw them they cut they they cut
me up and they put turkey necks in there
and I said Dad they didn't do that he
goes yeah I know but I thought they did
yeah just [__]
funny thought they were putting [__]
turkey necks in his [__] thing and in
his chest yeah his friend goober his
name is they call him goober that's not
his name South y'all yeah
goober goober is a [__] strange
character he's a [__] Champion pistol
shot [__] with 1911s he's a [__]
master of [__]
191145 I don't think he's worked a day
in his life he just lives in his mom's
house after she died he just lived in
her house and the [__] everything all
grown up around it he's like a [__]
hillbilly okay he gets some kind of
check from something he just lives off
of that I'm not even sure he even has
power I don't know probably does he's
probably got water and power that's
crazy yeah but um he's not like one of
his hoarders that like shits in bags is
he no okay he's not a hoarder okay he
just uh no I was just saying like maybe
he didn't have indoor po no he just he
he he's real antisocial he doesn't like
Society he likes his friends that he
grew up with but he doesn't want to have
a job um he just lives at home the house
that he he does I think have a cars but
it's always used cars and stuff so he
can he he makes enough money to save up
and buy things and and and he goes to
the grocery store and comes back and
eats little Debbies and [__] he do smoke
or anything he does he did dip but he
had a whole bunch of 40 1911
45s he had one that he carried a
lot he had a carry
permit and uh it was a Remington Rand
1911 that was from World War II they're
a collector's item if you have one
they're worth more than a cult because
remon Rand I believe was a [__]
sewing machine company or or or
typewriters I think is what they made
and during World War II they converted
it out to make
45s and they didn't make that many of
them but if you have one they're they
also had singer Singer sewing machine
made him anything that was off brand
like that Savage made one made one
but they were a gun company they weren't
worth on on the collector's Market they
weren't worth as
much he would go to [__] police
pistol matches all started in the 70s
80s and 90s with that [__] rington
Rand [__] World War II Army Surplus
45 they had a trigger job on it and it
was match accurized and it didn't have a
bit of bluing on it it was Bare
Metal cuz he carried it all time not in
a holster just in a like an OSS
waistband you just take a loop of string
and put it through your belt and then
muzzle up through the two Loops of the
string and then down into your pants and
it'll hold it so when you pull the gun
there's no holster you can get you can
throw
the throw the string away [__] toss a
pistol there's no evidence that you
actually had it that kind of [__] you
know what I mean but he had a bunch of
those 45s he he could um different
different kinds you know go gold cups
and [__] all real good [__] but he
carried that nasty looking [__]
rington Rand and it was Bare Metal but
it was shiny though CU he he oiled it a
lot it was and it had a [__] sweet
trigger pull and he was a [__] great
shot with
it now I don't think he took it into the
hospital with him I think you have to go
through a [__] metal
detector in a hospital well I guess it
depends on where the hospital is last
time I went to a hospital I didn't it
was just mostly just like state
buildings you got to go the emergency
room and I think you got to go through a
metal detector and fck maybe yeah maybe
so I haven't been to one in a while so
right so my dad's hallucinating and he
calls goober goober come here goober now
I I heard him talking to him but I
didn't hear exactly what he was talking
about I didn't really make afterwards
[__] go was like yeah he said he
wanted me to go down and get his truck
ready and go get his [__] pistol and
bring it up in here and we'd [__]
shoot our way out of here he wanted me
to get him out of here yeah like and he
said he'd been abducted I was like what
yeah he goes yeah he says he was
abducted by a
cat and we were just looking at like
he's what the it must be medication and
we're like yeah wasn't medication though
he just was suffering from hospital
psychosis yeah some people get that yeah
he goes crazy when he goes to the
hospital too long loses his mind is that
why they're keeping him sedated this
time yeah yeah make sure he behaves well
what is he gets frustrated he doesn't
like it well nobody really likes it I
mean but you know and I think he's under
a lot of stress you know fear of death
or something yeah so then he has some
kind of psychotic break yeah and he
can't do anything because he can't he's
too weak to do much yeah so he starts
fighting it starts tearing [__] out of
his arm and I'm going home that kind of
[__] he'll be real confused about where
he is and who's
who but he regains sanity after a while
yeah Tammy said she's got to drive to
Pennsylvania on Sunday nine hours yeah
that's about how long that's how long I
got to drive yeah from here to buxy he's
driv to bxy that's about 9 hours I'm not
going to buy oh that's right yeah going
to Laurel Laurel that's right well well
see the thing about it if you cuz
another thing that where you said you
didn't want to fly was because one you
had to fly of Orlando when we were like
oh God but also you can only fly from
Orlando to New Orleans and then my
cousin would have to come cous would
have to come get him and that's like a
three-hour drive three and a half 4 hour
drive to there and then another three
and a half four hours back right so and
he hasn't had a whole lot of sleep he's
ushering his mom around to [__] cuz
they're basically kind of like whenever
whenever he starts [__] dying she
goes into [__] death death watch mode
and she um goes in there every visitor
there's three visitor times it's like 10
minutes each one because he's in
ICU and she'll stay up all [__] day
wanting to go see
him um even though he's not even awake
you know which I understand it but leave
that [__] alone man he told him
to get out that was his last words just
get out of here yeah he was a little
cranky yeah get out of here say thank
you for coming but get out of here cuz I
understand he wanted privacy to fight it
and and try to sleep it off is what he
do you know he didn't [__] yeah I get
it you can't help me get out of here you
know that's what he's
doing he doesn't like to be seen that
way yeah I kind of feel like a lot of
people don't I mean I I wouldn't like
that either so I get it yeah according
to my cousin Scott he looks rough yeah
yeah he's uh very frail cuz see he he
had lung
cancer and he had him
on
uh
chemotherapy he was he wasn't sure
whether he wanted he's like I don't know
if I want to go through that
chemotherapy I said [__] it maybe I just
get the [__] out of here and he's he's
mad I'll let I'll just die from this
[__] I don't care I'm sick of this [__]
he's like that
but then he elected to have the
chemo and the cancer actually responded
to the chemo it it responded real well
but it weakened his immune
system and he got a cold that became
pneumonia yeah that's what's gotten
right now I think that happens that's
what's gotten L he's got it and um they
put him on a bunch of his blood pressure
started to drop so they put him in blood
pressure medicine to try to elevate his
numbers and it did something to his leg
it started to get get black the
circulation went bad so they may have to
go in there and [__] clear an
artery they almost considered chopping
it off but it got better the second and
third day then he started it got better
as they backed off on the blood pressure
medicine his blood pressure is actually
getting better it's going up it was too
low it's going up and is uh somehow
that's affecting that leg positively
that it's going back to normal how old
is your dad not old 75 oh okay so yeah
that's that's how I became a bodybuilder
with seeing my dad go through this [__]
just like I said yeah that first time I
went down there and watch him pull his
[__] hard out and he's talking about
chicken necks and all this went crazy
and [__] I'm looking at him and I'm
[__] thinking I says all this [__]
was avoidable a lot of it yeah yeah
smoking in [__] cigarettes like a
train and uh eating that white trash ass
[__] Mississippi Delta diet man like
I said on the other show it's not just
it's not just black people it's anybody
from the south from that area eats like
that and they get [__]
diabetes especially that generation
younger generation is not as bad but
baby boomers yeah well [__] trashed
themselves well I feel like there used
to be and I grew up in the South so I
know yeah there was a stigma among that
generation that it's like just eating
salads or eating stuff that was healthy
that was like
effeminate not only that it would say
that wasn't real food yeah it would say
that's not real food it's like it's not
real food unless it's like fried and
bacon grease Prett much deep fried a lot
of [__] bacon bacon grease everything
had to be like meat a lot of meat yeah
meat a lot of soda but the meat was
fried battered and fried a lot of um
they ate vegetables but they were
heavily boiled so like no nutritional
value boiled down all the nutrition was
in the [__] broth that they threw
away um just they would take spinach and
boil it down into [__] slime they
just [__] they're crazy well I told
you it's like growing up it's like I
thought I hated spinach until I actually
got a little bit older and ate like raw
SP spinach like in a salad I'm like hey
this is actually pretty good [__]
deep deep south Southerners are [__]
a trip black people too okay it's about
the same thing they [__] could cook
real well but because of their
Heritage they tended especially the Baby
Boomers they tended to overcook things
cook it to death because they weren't
used to have to to [__] safe food
they cook it a lot to make sure that
they were killing anything that was in
it I think it came from the days of
[__] the the depression and uh
subsistence farming they [__] grew
[__] in their backyards and they
fertilized it with the ouse water yeah
thre [__] water on it which is good
fertilizer it sounds gross but but if
and making compost piles and [__] but
the thing is is that if you don't wash
those vegetables real well
you could get all kinds of disease like
typhus and [__] so when they cooked
things they [__] cooked it to death
to be S to make sure they safe so they
didn't taste like anything really right
now that was a long time ago that was
the 20s and the
30s but
that
habit went from my grandparents
generation to my parents generation yeah
in the South it's not it's nowhere near
as bad as it was they can cook
vegetables now cuz they're buying them
and they know you don't have to cook
them to death there's an internet you
can [__] yeah find out how to cook
them the right way yeah I feel like
Jenny didn't know what [__] Jenny did
not know what spinach was really like
until she got out of South yeah got out
got left home until I left home yeah
tell tell her what spinach was like in
your house well my grandma always made
it and like I said my grandma and my
grandpa grew up in the depression and we
you know I spent a lot of time with my
grandma cuz my parents worked so I was
over there all the time and she made
good [__] but she was you know she was
from Tennessee like like Deep South
Tennessee like small town Tennessee and
everything you say about like all this
stuff she would make she made all that
stuff yeah every single vegetable was
just boiled to nothing like spinach I
always thought spinach was like this big
snotty slime because that's how it
always I didn't even it didn't even
occur to me that you could eat it raw
yeah but then like later on you like
people had salads and stuff like that
with like raw spinach I'm like huh
really I didn't know you could eat it
like that and I was like and I ate it
and I was like oh that's good that's
much better than like the you know if
you were to take something and make a
[__] beautiful wilted spinach salad
salad and give that to my grandmother
she would like oh hell no oh hell she
would think that was risky to eat that
that's not
cooked I [__] I love wilted spinach
salad I do too [__] great yeah I like
raw spinach and salad better than
lettuce yeah I will always pick that
like and we actually we got public subs
today yeah for lunch good and I always
get spinach on there instead of lettuce
it's my much
better but the diet's gotten better as a
gener yeah people actually kind of know
I I think that's something that sort of
like died with the older with the boomer
generation that's kind of it's dying out
with them they just had real bad habits
when it came to eating [__] they'
[__] a [__] ton of [__]
grits and then they'd [__] season
them with a lot of [__] pork
drippings and stuff yeah it's delicious
it's great oh yeah but you I mean I'll
eat it every now and then with like Big
Tub like things of butter in there but
it's like you can't eat like that every
day Southern black families would take
grits and then just [__] add a lot of
sugar to them that was that was each
family kind of had their own yeah some
people prefer sugary grits and some
people like Savory ones they're good
either way I think but I like Savory
ones better I noticed black people liked
them with sugar and then they'd [__]
sometimes put you know cinnamon and or
maple syrup in them you know that it's
good yeah that is good actually with
it's just that you know like a lot of
white Southerners like oh no they got to
be savory
cheese pork you know that kind of stuff
it's good either way I like whole
hardboiled eggs in them yeah whenever
Tom like Tom makes them every now and
then [__] T down there he put he puts
whole like hardboiled eggs in there and
cheese garnish it with hardboiled eggs
American cheese and bacon and [__]
green onions and hell yeah but that'll
generally be the only thing we eat all
day and Tony s Tony sash's [__] Cajun
seasoning in it yeah it is good hell
yeah but we don't eat that every day
though no it's [__] hu it's it's a
carbohydrate [__] flood yeah I mean
that's where diabetes comes from is
eating that [__] all we have eaten today
is a Public Sub yeah that's it meat we
both got we both got roast beef Subs
yeah they were just roast beef and veget
that that sandwich was probably 1500
calories though yeah so that's pretty
good we need to lose a little bit of
weight because the holidays yeah we were
[__] pedal to the metal on the
holidays so I'm kind of bringing it down
to one decent meal maybe like a couple
snacks yeah you know I'll get down there
and make it something tonight I got sh
down there but I mean that's I got
hamburger down in there raw hamburger
and those buns I can make us a small
slider yeah that'd be good
okay um let's see hold on be drunk
making a hamburger yeah well you you've
done it before yeah yeah Zan said lots
of older people drink a ton of soda ton
of soda younger people prefer tea or
other healthier options yeah it's weird
because I um my grandmother loved Coke
yeah um she never drank water she never
drank tea she drank coffee she loved
coffee but coffee and Coke I think that
was all she ever drank she didn't drink
fruit juice or anything but tea is not
safe in the South for diabetes because
they drink sweet tea oh it's sweet tea
and it's [__] sweet in a gallon in a
gallon of tea there's at least two cups
of sugar in it yeah so it's not really
healthy no and I think a lot of might
have three cups if you wanted it really
sweet it's it's syrupy it's good though
she used to get on my case because all I
would drink was water and milk yeah cuz
I didn't really like soda I still don't
I'll drink it every now and then but
it's not really my thing I always drink
something else if if it's available or I
would rather just drink water my dad
would take a [__] big ass glass and
pour an RC Cola into that glass and then
take a package of those salted dried
salted roasted peanuts you get at the
dollar store and the the dime store they
call it Dime Store the dime store and
pour all that inside that [__] soda
and eat the peanuts floating on the top
of the soda and drink it down and I said
what the hell is that you goes you know
colon soda
col peanuts what the [__] is that I
don't know just he was a kid well it's
like sweet and salty I get that like
sweet and salty is good together like um
he couldn't explain it so they just grew
up doing it like I used to like when I
was a kid getting lazed potato chips and
then breaking off little pieces of like
Hershey's chocolate bars and like
eatting that together like with a little
sandwich like that was like really good
okay there's a bunch of questions in
there statements go down the way yeah I
got way behind somebody asked me
something about
rifles where was that where was that
something but I think it see who it
was I saw something about 308s in
there let's see I don't know if that was
like before that or I don't even know
where we're at now
I'm trying to like scroll through and
like look at everybody's yeah there's a
lot of [__] there I know well see that's
what
happens let's see s said I don't know
anyone who's eating
[Laughter]
grits they're good though they're good
though if you prepare them right there
good Art Hill had the best coverage of
the Phoenix Lights yeah that's right you
see that that's up
there Bren said yeah I'll cook a couple
eggs sunny side up and throw them into
some grits and go to town yeah see
that's good too we put
but yeah you can put like sun side up or
Friday okay I think beest asked me if
AR15s and 308 were any good yeah it's
called AR10 that was the original
version actually Eugene Stoner came up
with the AR10 first it was in
308 or
762 but the US Army didn't buy it one of
those African countries bought it they
used it in one of their Civil Wars I
don't remember if it was you can
probably look it up it might have been
Nigeria but they were the first country
to buy an AR they loved it just that It
On full auto it was too much of a
handful it's kind of long too I think it
had a 20in barrel on it maybe more might
have been 21 22 Ines but it just look
like a giant
M16 then later
on the 556 version you know that got
adopted by the Army over time actually
got adopted by the Air Force first and
then the Army
adopted but the thing is
about things like the
AR10 is the
AR10 the whole idea behind Eugene
stoner's concept was something that was
very
lightweight and 762 ammo is is is heavy
it's also expensive and the magazines
are only 20 round magazines so it's it's
more like a standard automatic rifle
it's not really an assault
rifle the AR-15s and 5.56 and all the
different versions of the AR-15 I think
are a lot better for most purposes just
so much
lighter now the older the AR-15 got in
service the heavier it got that M4
carbing once which is what they' been
using recently they've been strapping so
much [__] [__] to that thing it's
[__] heavy now even though it's
shorter and that's not the original
concept the original concept was
something that weighed about five or six
pounds and it's perfect just like that
you don't need all lights and [__]
for grips and [__] Prismatic sights
and [__] that th those will not help you
really
um some you say well the accuracy is
better and this and that you train
training on the troops is is really what
does that all right we had Red Dot ours
was just the front sight post you just
painted you just looked at the Target
and you saw the image of that damn front
sight post that big old [__] raised
front sight sight post just kind of like
a blurry middle finger come up and when
you saw that blurry middle finger you
just put it underneath the Target and
just started firing and you'll hit it
you'll hit it out to [__] 100 me
that's where most of the [__] is
happening anyway so all that Red Dot
site that's all [__] training wheels
man you really don't need it even though
I have stuff like that it's
just I don't know it's got
batteries and you know it's good for
home stuff and security but in Warfare
you don't want anything that has
anything to do with batteries because
you probably not going to get batteries
they're going to shoot down all the
[__] helicopters that bring all that
[__] so you just be stuck out there with
[__] with something that doesn't work
in a real war you're getting your ass
kicked all right um hi desert said uh I
just started reading some horror stories
by Gemma files really good I think you
would like her if you haven't already I
mean I think if she's the one that wrote
the novel experimental film um I did
review that some time ago and I liked it
but I could see how maybe a l maybe a
lot of people might not like it because
there was a lot of stuff in there like
the first I want to say 33% of the book
was like very much about like the
Canadian film industry which I thought
was fascinating but I could see how some
people might not um but yeah it's pretty
it was a
very it was a very ambiguous story it
was like kind of ambiguous and low-key
which I liked about it but I think I
thought that I had read some of her
short stories too because the reason
that I picked up that book cuz I bought
the print book because I recognized her
name because I thought that IID read
some of her short stories but I'd have
to like go back and look through some of
my an ologies to see but I did read
experimental film if that's the same
author which I think it is um and I
reviewed it a long time ago um yeah Zan
said all I drink is water or coffee yeah
me too it's like I get up I have I fill
up a glass of water I make a cup of
coffee and then I just keep filling up
water all day and then at night
sometimes we have booze Camp guy says
yeah you got to go to a metal detector
where you go into a hospital okay so I
haven't been in a while yeah last time I
went in a hospital I didn't have to Zan
said I love chicken and waffles for
sweet and salty chicken waffles fried
chicken with waffles if you're up in
Europe [__] look that recipe up learn
how to deep fry chicken you can do it in
a pan you do it the southern way just
make a good
[__] batter the batter is [__] you
know just it's a it's egg wash and then
you roll it in seasoned flour and deep
fry it in a [__] pan flip it over you
learn how to make a waffle but you got
to have a waffle iron for that yeah you
kind of need a waffle iron to make a
waffle and Frozen Fu just chicken and
pancakes know waffle iron can be
expensive I think they're about 5050 to
$75 you can get a cheaper one but
they're not great yeah yeah you want a
good one that flips over yeah it's it's
a big big
machine then you put that once the
Waffle's done you want let waffle about
the size of a plate almost you put the
chicken on there you can use a thigh or
a leg or a breast I like a thigh th like
two thighs on there I'm a dark meat girl
yeah put some butter put some butter on
the on the waffle first then put the
chicken on top of the butter and then
take some warmed up um maple syrup and
pour it over the chicken and the waffle
all right this is really good for you
man it's hell food all right and you
just cut the pieces of the chicken off
that's got the damn syrup on it and then
a piece of the damn waffle and just eat
them together man it's good yeah and
that chicken juice is seeping into the
waffle yeah yeah we had chicken and
waffles at shantel's a couple of times
and that was good their shrimp and grits
is delicious too yeah Shantel puts uh
coconut milk in it yeah cuz we asked her
why secret secret group yeah I was like
this is like way better than any other
shrimping grits I've ever had
yeah uh yeah scrambled eggs and bacon
are good in grits yeah definitely yeah
we always put bacon and eggs in there
yeah Zach says I think I only ever had
grits once at Golden Corral and I was
like well this exists yeah Golden Corral
um I wouldn't trust grits from there no
well that's the thing it's just kind of
like you know when you know when you
stay in like a mid-tier like chain hotel
and they do the breakfast buffet and
they have like 40 million things and
they always have grits but they're never
seasoned so it's like you got to put
your own [__] seasoning on there
because you don't put like 40,000 tons
of butter and pepper and [__] like that
in there they're not going to taste it's
not going to taste like anything it's
just like anything else it's
just they don't taste like anything
unless you dress them up with stuff
they're kind of like plain white bread
or just plain rice or something like
that you have to do things with them you
know you can't just eat them like that
they're not
good I still laugh when I the first time
I went to the UK in the '90s I think it
was the '90s and my then
mother-in-law um they had only just
started selling lender Bagels over
there and you know it's the UK so they
don't really know that much about bagels
and so she bought some cuz you know she
was trying to you know she was trying to
be nice she's like oh you know they
don't have Bagels in the UK well they no
they do now okay but they didn't back
then it was like a new thing okay and um
so and she was always trying to like buy
say I thought this saw this thing that
had an American flag on the package so I
bought it you know what I mean so she's
trying to like make me happy or whatever
so um so she took one out of the package
and and just ate it and she was like man
that was horrible and I'm like you know
you're supposed to toast it and like put
cream cheese or [__] on it right or
something or butter or peanut butter or
something and it's like oh yeah that
would probably she just took it out of
the package and ate it did you give it
to her when when it cooked I don't know
if she had my cooked later but she was
just like I think she was like
complaining to me cuz he's like these
are awful and I was just kind of like um
yeah she just took him out and ate it
like that and I was like yeah it
probably would be awful if you took it
out and ate it like that store bought B
is not going to be good cold but you can
buy a real bagel like say on your way
into the damn Boston Tea or the subway
all right and and some of the [__] that
they're selling there that's good I it
doesn't have to be if the bagel's good
it doesn't have to be warm yeah no yeah
you can totally eat but the but the ones
you buy at the grocery store like the
lender Bagels you absolutely have to
toast those I mean yeah you can eat them
right out of the package but you're
going to have a bad time yeah you need a
high quality Bagel to eat it just R yeah
yeah yeah like if you go go some like
Einstein Brothers or something like that
like yeah you can eat those I'd be on
the run and I'd [__] have a get a
high quality baget might have poppy
seeds on it or something and then they
give you a damn thing of sour cream or
excuse me a cream cheese Philadelphia
cream cheese in a packet and I would
just squirt all of it on the top of it
and just eat it like a [__] hamburger
your nose to get in the
[__] in a hurry they fill you up man
but they're terrible nutrition there's
no there's no protein in that I mean
it's just all carbs yeah but it's carbs
I used to like the smaller Bagels like
toasted with a layer of cream cheese and
then like some sliced cucumber on there
and some salt and pepper I used to like
that a
lot yeah Camp guy said bagel and cream
cheese or brand muffin is my go-to
breakfast when I'm traveling and or in a
motel toasted Bagel scrambled eggs and
cheese and [__] bacon or whatever
that's good in there ham hell yeah
imagine all the Jews are [__] going
crazy could go you can't put Ham on that
you know but yeah I do you can
it's bread you can put whatever you want
in there I don't think anyone cares
anymore that's that's I think it's yish
yeah well that's how it started out but
like I said now it's I don't even think
I don't even think people like a lot of
people that eat them even care about
that it's great with locks and cream
cheese on it yeah it's when I was in
Israel [__] when I worked in Israel
[__] they they had that at the
[__] the hotel morning
Buffet Bagels locks cream cheese i' be
making a [__] yummy yeah a [__]
sandwich stocked up
anding locks is like smoked fish I think
it's salmon yeah but it's got a real
nice flavor it's it's kind of kind of
has a hamlike quality to it it's good
enough at least it's a protein it'll
[__] give some nutrition to that
thing yeah it was good Danny says
blueberry bagels and salmon cream cheese
are the best no [__] well the smokiness
and the and the sweet I guess that could
work unless you're trolling but I'm
sitting there thinking because initially
I was like gross but then I was like oh
wait maybe not might
work maybe not yeah um Mur Hornet still
upset that a [__] AR-15 and 308 is
American yeah the first AR-15 was in 308
called the
AR10 so yeah that's more American than
the and that was the 50s that that came
out I think it was late 50s late 50s
early 60s around that time that's an old
design
John Smith says crumpets I actually
quite like crumpets as well they don't
have a lot of flavor to them but I mean
they're similarish to an English muffin
cuz you know what I mean well that's
what when they were making English
muffins and they were trying to make an
American version of a crumpet so they're
kind of similar but they're but they're
not quite the same yeah I so like a um
it's a dumbed down version of a crumpet
is denser yeah the um the uh the texture
of it is different everything it's
spongier and denser a bit everything
that is kind of American was redesigned
for this market for mass production
because anything that survived over a
long period of time wasn't some small
local manufacturing facility it was
something that was able to go Nationwide
it's a huge country here this is back in
the late 1800s early
1900s so to to produce this [__] quickly
and then get it get it passed out to you
know to to keep the United States
supplied it had to be made out of
something that was readily available
resources so regular old [__] flow
you know what I mean so everything was
kind of dumbed down so you can make a
lot of it quickly yeah it doesn't mean
it wasn't bad it wasn't bad just what it
was based on is going to be a lot
fancier right it's going to be a lot
better right well once you start pumping
that out it's just going to be adequate
it's adequate but once that [__] that
includes chocolate like Hershey's
Hershey's was adequate it was adequate
I'll eat it it's fine yeah but it's not
great that was the only chocolate that a
poor person could afford and it was
everywhere yeah so it was like a luxury
to them yeah and real chocolate a poor
person couldn't afford that you know it
was a nickel and you got a [__] maybe
a penny you got a [__] a Hershey bar
I think that's some rich people [__]
that was some rich people [__] it was
yeah and and and European style
chocolate which we had at that time just
that that was made locally in your local
candy maker that was many times more
more expensive than that little 5cent
Hershey bar was it delicious much more
delicious yes yeah but over time that
became part of our tastes
yeah up eating that Hershey chocolate
has its own taste it's kind of got a
slight sour Wang to it and it was made
they knew which a lot of Europeans say
why does it taste like vomit yeah I I've
heard more than one of them say it has
to do with the way the way the process
was made they were trying to make a lot
of chocolate bars out of a small amount
there's whole documentaries about it
it's actually fascinating yeah it was a
very efficient way to make a [__] ton of
chocolate out of a small amount of
chocolate cocoa powder you can make a
lot of chocolate bars out of a small
amount of cocoa powder milk
chocolate
and things like temperature and
temperature control and it was hard to
do back in those days so they had the
the the recipes had to be very dumbed
down yeah you know and it had to be
something that was shelf stable because
there was no Refrigeration then well you
had to ship it across country big ass
country obviously so yeah Zan said my
dad used to make h made coffee cake when
I was a kid for breakfast that [__] was
amazing man so yeah oh [__] I used to
every now and then like when I was not
being lazy like sometimes on the
weekends I would bake a coffee cake if I
felt like it and yeah that that really
does make a good breakfast that's it's
really not good for you but okay it's
okay uh Zan also said I tried some
Mediterranean style hummus last week
that was amazing I never knew how good
hummus was yeah yeah real good Tom makes
it from scratch yeah I'll rehydrate
those [__] garbanzo beans also know
as chickpeas it's it's
chickpeas um garlic lemon a little bit
of olive oil uh water and um tahini you
got to make
tahini tahini is ground
up sesame seeds Okay you can get a bunch
of sesame seeds you can blend them and
make it if not you can buy tahina yeah
like be in the import section in a jar
it's like peanut butter made out of uh
sesame seeds yeah some people have used
peanut butter unsalted peanut butter as
a substitute probably pretty good yeah
that would probably work but you
couldn't use you couldn't use sweetened
American well no there's a ton of sugar
right it had to be un you could use GIF
or anything it had to be unsweetened
peanut
butter that could work yeah natural
peanut butter is that what they call it
natural peanut but yeah you can get
natural peanut butter I've gotten it for
it's pretty good it's a pain cuz you
have to you have to mix it every time
cuz it's separate you know what I mean
um Danny says Germany makes the best
chocolate yeah they probably do Z said I
bought a Whitman's sampler over
Christmas I forgot how good Whitman's is
it's as good as any European chocolate
uh then says my go-to is Belgian white
chocolate holy [__] I love white
chocolate look I've had [__] the
fantastic homemade chocolate in Brazil
in a place called Grado and it's Grado
was a [__] German Town all the Nazis
ran there but they were Germans there
before War too but they all went down
there they can sell you a big botch of
chocolate yeah it was great um I never
had when I went to Germany I didn't have
any of the chocolate I had the Nutella
it's just like it is here but I didn't
have any chocolate didn't have
time um there are there are candy shops
that make the candy on site there used
to be one at Harvard Square down in in
Boston and man they could the the the
chocolate was [__] just badass it was
expensive though
you could get they had about seven
different versions of peanut butter cups
and they were the size of an
apple man some of them had
strawberry strawberry and peanut butter
and a big old [__] it was it was
wasn't the size of Apple was the size of
a [__] um
cupcake they were made in a cupcake you
have to like eat it in slices oh man had
get halfway through it and it was so
rich I couldn't unless you were real
couldn't finish it but they was they had
all these little homemade um chocolate
bars you could get a selection of
chocolate bars would be like probably 30
or 40 chocolate bars in there they were
unwrapped but they were all in the same
same box stacked perfectly in there each
one of them different some of them white
chocolate some of them just you know
four or five different kinds of
chocolate they were [__] great that
box of chocolate though might be 50 60
bucks me that's not bad for a bunch of
bars though yeah but they're not very
big they're only like they're they're
only like that big it was expensive and
that was that was the '90s
right oh okay you know so I was
like but you could go in there and get
one of them you get one for like a
couple bucks two or three something like
that well I told you one of these days
if you ever go to St Augustine with me
there is a very famous candy shop there
that's been there for I don't know how
long it was there when I was a kid and
it had been there a long time since then
and they make all the [__] on site and
you can buy I think the last time I was
there a couple years ago um they have
like all like a whole bunch of different
flavors the fudge I think it might be $6
a pound or maybe $8 a pound I can't
remember and then they make like a bunch
of other stuff too cuz I bought I think
I bought like some butter pecan fudge
and then I bought like a jar of um
chocolate covered espresso beans the
Danny says that there's a town in Brazil
that's filled with twins because Joseph
Maga was there doing twin experiments I
don't believe it i' have seen that to
believe I heard that story too yeah I
don't believe it I also because during
the time that I was there as a kid my
mother was working in the state
department Department she worked at the
consulate and uh the American Consulate
in s Paulo and she was there when they
found that body mangala's
body and uh there were people in the
intelligence Community they got the full
report once they found out you know
Israel was involved and everything they
wanted to know everything about Joseph
mela's life in Brazil he didn't do
anything he basically stayed in the
flla um he swam on the beach he laid low
he got snuck out there by the rat line
that's how they used to sneak the Nazis
out and there was some kind of secret
funds coming to him from from from
Germans in other countries we sending
him the stiping to live off of those
Germans took care of each other um they
didn't just leave you out to
dry they had kind of like a a mafia
network of them taking care of each
other and he uh had a black
girlfriend uh that lived with him for
like 20 30 years I don't know if they
got married but they did have
children
okay
so this whole
[__] Germans of the bent cross and
[__] racial Purity and [__] they
didn't really actually seem to [__]
believe in that [__] they just did what
they were told to do they were like okay
theudas had a black
girlfriend you know and kids and [__]
some people might say well that was just
his cover I don't believe so though she
didn't know who he was though she knew
he was something from the war but she
didn't know who he was he died yeah I
imagine that that isn't something that
you like lead with when you're on a date
or whatever yeah she I don't think she
knew who he
was he died swimming at the beach there
was a beach called uat tuba that's where
he died he died when he was [__]
swimming had a heart
attack Zach says uh Tom I still say you
and Jenny should write some kind of
political thriller novel I bet it'd be
great who said that Zach did Zach yeah
gay Zac gay Zac not motorcycle Zack
isn't here motorcycle Zack is not here
Joseph Green said the boys from Brazil
was a great movie oh I agree I haven't
seen that in a long time either yeah I
got [__] we haven't reviewed that have
we I got stories of that [__] okay I was
when I was a kid I was going to I was a
state department
dependent
so I got sent to a high school there
called es Escola gradu de s Paulo it was
the best high school in
Brazil I went to school with all
the the children of all the richest
people that ran
Brazil the malies the Melos those are
people that were presidents and [__] um
Lise I forgot his name Louise something
I got to look at my yearbook one of the
guys he was kind of like a dude who was
next to me in class I was constantly
[__] with he was the king of Brazil I
didn't know king of Brazil but the King
was deposed you know what I mean they
didn't they still had a parliament and
it kind of like England you know what I
mean they kept their Royals around but
they did kind of have a title but it was
unofficial and they weren't paying them
but they were so rich that they didn't
have to pay them they own a bunch of
building a bunch of businesses and
[__] there was an American kid that I
hung out with that I'm not I'm not going
to mention his name
but he was an American
kid he had a German last
name he was we would get high as [__]
smoke weed
drink was hanging out with him one
weekend and another guy named Derek and
he goes got to go to Five Villa get some
weed and he says come on with me and I
was like all right and
uh which was stupid but he I says man
that's a faella man they'll [__] us up
in there that's a [__] Shany town he
goes no no no where I'm going it's all
good I was like all right he because I
know these
guys let's go down to the faas there
little narrow corridors and [__] Shandy
Town went up to this thing it looks like
a pile of [__] this house when Dude door
he knocked on the door door opened up
and the [__] white dude in suit was
in there with glasses and
[__] and uh told us to come in and and
and his name is John I'm not going to
say his last name John started speaking
German to the guy I didn't know John
spoke German he was an
American so he walked in there speaking
German and I [__] end up in the other
side of the threshold in what looked
like a [__] beautiful [__] house
on the outside it looked like just a
shanty house and the inside looked
beautiful had lighting and everything
and it was in the middle of a goddamn
Shrine to
Hitler yikes yeah it was red on the
inside the lights it had a [__]
swastikas it had [__] the mustache
man and these were like original
pictures like back from the fucking' 40s
and then all of his ancestors and I'm
looking I'm looking at all these
uniforms some of them were females and
some of them were were guys and they
were all in uh well German uniforms of
some sort I don't I don't I couldn't
tell you if they were vafan SS or SS
security or police but they were
something like that and dude comes back
and they're making a transaction give a
whole coffee can full of [__] weed
and we're we're in [__] we're in the
we're in the [__] ghetto man and uh
nobody would touch us and we just walked
out of there and I was like man what the
[__] was that he's just laughing he goes
yeah I know those guys [__] how the
[__] you know he goes through my family
I was like what and he goes I said what
he goes my grandfather was in the Third
Reich I like really he goes yeah my my
parents immigrated here immigrated to
the United States my grandfather was in
the third
right so I oh it made sense they were
still speaking German mhm and his sister
could speak German and they lived in
Brazil but they were I think they might
have had dual citizenship Brazil America
I don't I don't know because they were
kind of moving between the two countries
because I linked up with him here in the
United States years
later now he
wasn't a Nazi but his ancestors were
yeah I mean you can't control what your
ancestors right yeah yeah but that kind
of was like man and the dude that sold
him that stuff was young but all those
artifacts in there were from the 40s
yeah which means that he was a
descendant of them right and there was a
network
there that would be weird like I don't
think my ancestors did anything
particularly nefarious but that would be
kind of weird if that was well they got
Blended
in to the intelligence agencies of
Argentina because Juan Peron was in with
them he used them and Rumor Has
It
Uruguay Paraguay Chile they were
involved and what I saw Brazil that they
all took him and um uh magala was
there I don't know if the Brazilians
knew he was there but they may have been
paid to look the other
way Brazil is not highly organized it's
a an anarco tyranny it's always in some
kind of stage of
collapse that's why Americans are
freaking out what's happening and now
here in the United States it's always
like this in South
America I'm mentally prepared for what
could
happen the sh America's been stable for
a pretty much a long for a long time
last time it was like this in
1860s we'll see we'll see what happens
but um the world is a lot more like
what's [__] funny is that just by
chance of birth with
me a lot of the [__] you see in in
[__] like James Bond movies I've
[__] seen
it so something you would read about in
a
movie or a music video from Duran Duran
yeah I grew up like
that back in the 80s Duran back in dur
back in the 80s Brazil was one live
Duran Duran music
video from my point of view it was
rather from my point of view yeah murder
Hornet ask if you ever tried hash
because he wants to try it yeah uh
hashish I tried that in Egypt but it's
just like real strong concentrated weed
I don't really like that kind of yeah
cuz he said even though I hate THC yeah
not my thing I'm not a big weed fan like
I know some people really like it like
the few times I've smoked it it's just
like I said it made me feel paranoid
even more paranoid than usual and I was
just like I don't need that slightly
hallucinogenic but not as good as LSD
LSD is a lot better don't do drugs kids
and uh [__] um masculine was good
kind of like LSD not quite as strong um
I didn't really have like I didn't have
a hallucinatory thing but what I did
have uh when I smoked weed was
everything it seemed like a slideshow
yeah like I seemed like there were like
gaps in time were
missing yeah so it seemed like kind of
cuz I was at iar yeah and I was standing
there and then like a song would come on
and be like oh I like the song oh oh
it's over like you know like I lost that
whole three or four minutes you know
what I mean like it seemed like it was
SK real good weed in real good weed
you'll you'll have little trips where
your imagination takes over and you see
things but it's not that's not very
visual it's mental yeah I just basically
felt like I felt like everyone's looking
at me um uncomfortable I'm doing
something stupid I just I felt like that
and it was just like really and it's
like I feel like that anyway so it's
like I definitely don't need something
that heightens that you know what I mean
make another drink okay Zach says if you
guys ever reviewed blow up the 60s movie
I do not think we have the antonioni one
is the one you're talking about uh we
did blow out the one with John Travolta
but I don't think we've done blowup yet
but that is definitely one that's on my
list though because I I really like that
movie um let's
see
and I've never tried hash but he has
he's done all the drugs I've done some
of the drugs but not not not as many as
he has uh Zan said Infamous war criminal
clous Barbie lived in Bolivia and helped
the cartels before the French captured
him he worked for the CIA before fleeing
to Bolivia yeah it's we should probably
do a show about that I think the only
one we've done about the bent cross
Germans was um we did one about like the
occult like they all the occult [__]
they were into but I don't think we've
ever done I think I put it in the polls
a couple times like all the ones that
like escaped to South America and all
that kind of stuff but I don't think I
ever won so we never did
we never did a show about
it um yeah Camp guy said hash is just
like good weed yeah I don't like I said
we we know a lot of people that are
really that really smoke a lot of weed
and like enjoy it but the few times that
I've smoked it I really don't like it
some people it seems to like chill them
out like I have a friend who um has
similar kind of um like anxiety issues
and stuff like that and she seems to
really like it and she like seems to
respond really well to it like it chills
her out and stuff like that and so I was
thinking oh you know it'll chill me out
too that's not what happened that's not
what happened it just
exacerbated you know which I guess it
does do for some people but it didn't
chill me out at all it just made me even
more like paranoid and like everyone was
looking at me and stuff like that so
like made me more self-conscious which I
I don't need that's why I like booze
honestly other than LSD I don't think
I've ever taken any drug that I liked
more than booze I like LSD more than
booze but other than that everything
I've tried I was just like I'm going to
try this out maybe this and I'm like n
no no I just didn't like it we were at
the club a few weeks back I don't know
if I should say this or not well I'm not
going to mention any names we're at the
club a few weeks back and a friend of
ours was like hey I got some what did he
have what remember when we were at
Barbarella I don't I didn't hear the
beginning of the what um and what what
did he have that he gave me and
Jen Jen what was it was it DMT I don't
know I don't remember I remember I don't
remember I don't remember what it was
but
um it didn't really do much of anything
though but like I said I don't I tend
not to respond to things strongly oh
yeah I know I know what you're talking
about yeah what was that it was ecstasy
oh okay yeah yeah yeah just wasn't
enough I guess not yeah
because he was like Hey you want
something I was like okay bunch of
there's a bunch of comments coming up
what you say I've already read most of
them okay I'm not behind you're not
behind go
no yeah they're just like hash is just
like good weed like I said and I said
I've never been a big fan of weed it
doesn't really like it doesn't chill me
out like it does other
people for whatever reason Z said if you
have any questions about weed ask me I
smoke every day yeah see like I said you
know we know a lot of people that do
that and it's like
I was always kind of looking into it
because like I said it's like oh if I
had something that could like chill me
out and stuff like that that would be
good but because I just I overthink and
I have anxiety and stuff so it's like if
something chilled me out that'd be
awesome but the few times I've done it
it's just had the opposite effect so I
don't know if it's just the wrong [__]
it was never really my thing I didn't
like it I liked alcohol better that's
what I mean I kind of like alcohol
better because well control up to a
point yeah up to a point um I like
alcohol better because it gets rid of
the over thinking yeah so it just kind
of makes me just go ah [__] it yeah and
I think that's good like I need that but
like I said if he goes you know I don't
want it to go too far because then I get
like start crying and [__] but you know
what I mean depending depends on what
kind of night it is and what kind of
drink it is um Zan said you get a slight
hallucinations on
Edibles yeah Z said I Love Weed it's my
one
Vice you get over the anxi feeling but
it's not for everyone yeah maybe it's
just I only cuz I've only done it a few
times you know it's too slow feeling for
me I don't like it like I said I really
liked LSD I I enjoyed that quite a lot
yeah I've always been more interested in
hallucinogens I guess maybe because I'm
a creative person it's just like I want
to
see if I can like see some cool [__]
that'll give me some ideas you know what
I mean at the proper dose it's it's mind
altering but it isn't dehab you can
still do a bunch of stuff that yeah
that's what I liked about it I liked
that you saw weird [__] but you were
still Lucid yeah you knew you knew like
you knew that it was the drug that was
doing that but you're like o neat you
know what I mean so I thought that was
kind of cool that like ju position you
could still think pretty clearly yeah
whereas like on alcohol after a while
it's like you know you wake up the next
day and you're like what the [__] did I
do yesterday like you don't remember
like after a certain point but it's like
I did I remember every single thing yeah
like when when we did LSD I remember
everything that happened talking about
Dam the Odessa files it was a good movie
I've never seen it I think I saw it but
it was a long time ago it's a old movie
it kind of reminded me of desfile I
think was kind of in the same genre as U
what was it three days of the Condor I
think it was something kind of like that
which that was a great movie Robert
Redford that was his [__] spot yeah
we reviewed that a while back huh yeah
yeah zanada man if you haven't seen
three days of the Condor man you to see
that I really like that movie that's a
[__] badass play Robert raford I love
all those 70s like conspiracy the yeah
yeah he's a dude that works for the CIA
that was the whole thing and then all of
a sudden assassins are trying to kill
him and their and their CIA paid
assassins and he can't figure out why
why why is I am I'm in the CIA why is
the CIA trying to kill I'm one of you
guys yeah and they're trying to kill him
and and the way they tried to kill him
was very
realistic dude just shows
up special delivery he's a [__]
mailman and everything and [__] he's
trying to sign for the mail and dude
[__] pulls out a [__] Mac 10 with
a suppressor and starts [__] firing
him then later on you find out he was an
ex Army first sergeant and everything
they B because the the Condor was his
code name [__] Robert Redford's
[__] code name was a condor his job
was just to read spy novels and enter
the [__] plots and tricks out of the
Spy novels into a database that the
[__] CIA would use yeah for some
reason they're trying to kill him and
and he's not a [__] field operative
his job is just data entry
he reads [__] books and enters the
data that's it he can't figure out why
they're trying to kill him but it's a
good flick it's a great premise I love
that Prem yeah so Le I thought of it
because he read all these tricks he's
he's never done them but he uses all
these tricks that he read about to stay
alive yeah CU see reading books is good
kids you canar in in in yeah in that
world knowing is [__] most of the
battle Yeah DVD Dragon says have you
ever heard of Clyde Barker's undying I
have it's a video game written by him
really good characters I've never played
it but yeah I have heard of it cuz I
I've read all of his [__] and I've seen
all of his movies but I've never played
any of the video games Zach says I kind
of want to try LSD but I'm scared I'd
wake up in a ditch missing an eye or
something it's not that bad he's asking
with the name the name is called three
days of the Condor yeah and I think it
was based on a book called five days of
the Condor yeah it was like a different
number six days of the something like
that we riew it a while back all you got
to do is just [__] look up Robert
Redford's [__] filmography and look
for [__] the Condor movie just
probably watch it free on you probably
watch that [__] free on
Amazon or no I think we had it paid but
it's only like $299 that's a badass
flick and it's raw it's it's all
practical effects it's the 70s and it's
all very grounded in real [__] and Max
von side shows up in it as a contract a
plus yeah as a contract Killer and a lot
of the cont track killers and [__]
they're [__] older
guys cuz
look you see funny [__] in the movies a
lot for those of you who don't know me
and everything I'm I'm I'm an ex Soldier
I was in 101st Airborne Division I was
in the [__] first 327 Recon platoon
known as Tiger Force it was [__] one
of the most DEC decorated [__] Recon
platoons of all times they [__] CIA
front [__] in the Vietnam period period
I was in there after have a state
department background for my family I
did [__] later on and [__] weird
stuff contract type
stuff I'm [__] retired now all right
they [__] they pay me just to not do
anything
okay you see weird [__] in the movies
you see dudes in in insurrections like
this new movie a24 movie Civil War I
really want to see it but they're
showing clips of that [__] and it shows
guys dressed as the [__] in in in
camouflage fighting out in the middle of
the streets with rifles and some of them
are dressed like the [__] Baloo boys
with Hawaiian shirts and
[__] that is not
camouflage camouflage doesn't even
really work I remember when I [__]
went the when I first went in the Army
I'd go down to the [__] PX and I'd
buy this new [__] equipment that I'd
need to use in the field [__] like mini
mag lights and it would come in a pouch
this big and that pouch would be
camouflaged and [__] I tie that [__] to
the front of my LC [__] it's camouflag
man it's tactical think about this for a
second if you're close enough to see
that camouflage pattern you can see that
[__]
flashlight it's the same thing with
those clothes if you're close enough to
see that camouflage pattern you're going
to see that man at any distance that
camouflage pattern just becomes green it
might as well just be [__] green or
gray or brown that [__] actually works
then they came out with some ridiculous
[__] called Urban Camouflage which was
white and black and [__] you put him in
an urban environment and you up close
just like a dude in white and black
tiger stripes and [__] and a different
distance you can still see him it just
looks gray that is not
camouflage you take that same man and
you dress him up as a pizza delivery boy
and put him in a crowd of people on the
[__] New York City street you'll
never see him that's
camouflage that's some Ninja [__] right
there well yeah I mean obviously I don't
know that's what camouflage is right
well that's what I was saying some of
these movies are just hoaxes dudes
running around in this [__] green
tactical gear and [__] nobody can see me
but a movie isn't real life it's like
you know what I mean they have to take
into consideration is this going to look
cool in the movie friend of mine I was
in the army with ended up being one of
the badass assassins in the [__]
world his name is Timothy vanus I got
pictures of me and him together we sered
together and 1st you can find him all
throughout the internet he's doing time
right now doing Federal time for trying
to kill DEA agents they're going to make
a movie about this
dude he was the closest thing James Bond
you'd ever [__] know he ran an
international team of mercenaries that
work for governments all throughout
Central and South America as hit squads
they had the ultimate [__] camouflage
their clients would dress them up as
cops with a police car from that country
and they would serve you a warrant at
your front [__] door and you would
get into a police car with them and
they' take you out to a pre-planned
position where a grave was dug and
everything and they shoot you in the
back of the head bury you and they'd get
$20,000 for it and they they killed
hundreds of people hundreds and it was
all state state sanctioned he started
off as a [__] security company owner
he's doing time right now because one of
the clients asked him to kill DEA agent
I don't know why he did it maybe he
didn't know he was a DEA agent or maybe
he was a bad DEA a agent but just look
up the name Timothy vanus that's a
personal friend of mine he knew what
camouflage was he helped train some of
those cartels
too and this is the weird [__] these
governments do
that that's not unusual [__] that's what
they
do because it's not so much the
government it's the politicians that
were elected into there they can't trust
their own government's people so they
use private contractors to do it and
it's in what we call in the Army in
echelon above reality because there's a
lot of [__] governments have to do but
they don't want to follow the rules so
they hire Outsiders to do it foreign
mercenaries and
stuff it's a weird world we live
in Murder Hornet said LSD scares the
[__] out of me and if you have a bad
trip you have to ride that out for 10
hours I don't know I never really had um
I never really worried about it I mean I
I guess I've heard about people having
bad trips and stuff but I think one of
the things that um
that I was told before I did it was you
got to go into it like thinking it's
going to be a positive experience
because if you go into it being afraid
that you're going to have a b bad trip
then you might Oracle also says a friend
of mine is very fond of absent in part
because she writes Victorian era novels
you know what I wish I liked absence
because I like all of the iconography
around it like I love all of the I even
have like a whole my whole bathroom like
over there is designed like you know uh
yeah like absent themed it's like the
walls are absent green and I have like
all this absent like old ads like from
the turn of the century I even have a
shower curtain that's like alant uh is
it Musha or Muka I don't know how you
pronounce his last name um but yeah
because I love his artwork so I have a
whole I have a shower curtain with his
artwork on it because I love all of that
iconography but I do not really like
absent itself yeah I got to correct
Sebastian Sebastian I never said that
tiger stripe wasn't a Vietnam camo it
was my platoon was the only platoon
really in the United States Army
authorized to wear c tiger stripe
camouflage and it was uh you we're
talking about Tiger Force you can look
it up on Wikipedia first 327
Recon um tiger stripe camouflage was not
American camouflage that was not the
American Army that was the South Vietnam
army or Arvin that was the that was one
of the camouflage patterns that they
used that platoon or my platoon adopted
that and then kind of made it famous
Tiger Force the thing was about Vietnam
Tiger Strike
camo is that the patterns changed over
the years they weren't all the same
because they were made in little bitty
tayor shops it wasn't made in big
factories uh they were made in smaller
batches through these little Vietnamese
tailor shops but it was Vietnam Vietnam
ta Viet n pattern stuff um the Army
liked it but they didn't adopt it
widespread only small Special Forces
types units because the material it was
made out of they didn't think it was
tough enough and the dyes that they used
tended to fade and some of it was like
stamped on [__] paint type patterns
that they put on it and it it didn't
last very long it it faded out pretty
quickly but they wore it
anyway they just changed it out although
some guys said in Tiger Force they
actually never wore it in the field they
just wore it back at the camp in the
field they evid evidently a lot of times
just wore the OD army green because it
was a tougher
material murder Hornet said does absence
today still make you hallucinate it
never did I don't think it actually made
you hallucinate back in the day no um
I've read a few books about like the
history of absin and what the general
consens is is that that was the wine
Lobby um trying to scare people away
from drinking campaign because it was
getting so popular it was so popular
that they called I think it was 400 p.m.
like in Paris the green hour because
everybody would go to the cafes and they
get absent yeah and um the wine Lobby
didn't like that because it was cutting
into their sales so they started like a
scare campaign about oh it does this
that and the other thing it makes you
insane and it makes you see things and
all this other kind of stuff it was all
[__] it does have a slight higher
alcohol content I think but it doesn't
really have hallucinogenic prop they
leave out why absence became popular it
became popular because it was issued to
French soldiers in one of those Foreign
Wars that the French were doing they
were issued them absent as a water
purification that way if you you might
have iffy water in your canteen you
could put a shot of that damn absent in
it and it would kill a lot of the
bacteria and you could drink it
it had a herbal flavor to it and there
were herbs in it it had a high alcohol
content it did not take like taste like
black licorice though most of these at
modern absence of today taste like black
licorice or anise which is like oo or
anet that is not
what absence tasted like in fact they
didn't know what absence tasted like the
the the flavor is
forgotten they they eventually found an
original bottle of
absinth and some of these absinth
companies bought it in a big auction one
of them bought it to get a hold of it
and they had their taster taste it they
had a whole [__] documentary on it
and we tasted it he was like oh okay
yeah it's very different than what we
thought it was it's it had a light
buttery flavor with a kind of a an
herbal
undertones it didn't it wasn't strong at
all in terms of like it didn't have any
an or black licorice type flavor in it
it was kind of
mild but evidently returning soldiers
liked it and they brought it French
returning soldiers liked it and they
were ordering it in cafes and bars and
it was selling well it kind of became a
a fad and it started to dig in the into
the French wine is business and you had
a lot of [__] Rich Nobles owned the
wine industry so it was a threat to them
they had to get rid of it but there was
nothing wrong with it
it was just a Lor but I really do I like
the whole um kind of Mythology that
sprung up about it yeah you know what I
mean I do like that they were spiking it
yeah that's true heads of the time know
people like to get high would take
absent and melt sugar cubes and lodum
and stuff which is basically opium and
they drink it you get high [__] off of
it well opium and wine they were doing
that yeah they doing that too they were
also mixing cocaine with it and drinking
it yeah that too but it wasn't the it
wasn't the uh
it wasn't the absent that was just an
heral that was other [__] they were like
like I said I think absent does have a
slightly higher alcohol content but it
doesn't have anything that would make
you lose no they were spiking it with
other things that was maybe making that
happen and you know people that you
associate with the whole absence Madness
thing such as quote like you know
Vincent Van go or something like that
they all the cool people drank that [__]
I mean he might have been had mental
problems anyway yeah the cool people
drank that [__] because it was new and
it was [__] trendy yeah like [__]
all right it's like energy drink Trek
and all that yeah it'd be like [__]
Red Bull of the day everybody drink a
Red Bull now we're going to put vodka in
Red Bull and then over time we got to
stop Red Bull they tried to stop Red
Bull and energy DRS they're too
dangerous it was that yes 25-year-olds
having heart attacks oh yeah yeah but
you find out later that it's like oh
well that's cuz they slammed like 12 Red
Bulls like in a couple of hours or
something while they were playing a
video game and yeah they might have been
high on some other [__] and they maybe
they were super fat also that probably
didn't help yeah Zan said um talking
about uh jgermeister Z said Jagermeister
is great only real men can handle
joerger and then Danny said I hate
joerger because it tastes like black
licorice I don't I don't hate it but it
gives me like instant heartburn I went
to high school with a German guy at that
International School in Brazil I was
telling you about [__] he would laugh
that Americans would [__] pay money
for Jager M said that was the [__]
worst thing you could ever find in
Germany that was like [__] that bums
drank that was that like that was like
Mad Dog right for the Germans they were
like you drinking that
e like I said well I don't really like
any of those cuz you know every now and
then when we were at the bar like some
people would buy us like you know gold
schlocker or something like that yeah
gold schoger is good yeah and um I don't
I don't really like any of those kind of
words that are like real I like cinnamon
but I don't like anything that's like
super like cinnamony flavored or super
cuz or super Ginger flavored or
something but it cuz like I said it just
gives me like instant heartburn they
were back in those days back when the
[__] that particular Club was
slamming it's not there
anymore high rollers would come in and
they would just buy me and Jen shots
[__] all night maybe have our drinks
and then all of a sudden these shots
keep coming and the ones that kept
coming a lot man was [__] uh oatmeal
cookie now those are good yeah oatmeal
cookie we get that one over and over
slam an oatmeal cookie I don't know how
they made it or lemon drops lemon drops
I think that was the second most some
kind of Fireball yeah or a fireball that
was probably the most because I was
always just kind of like okay but you
know you're not going to turn it down
because it's free yeah then I was like
oh man now I'm going to have heartburn
the rest of that was I was deep into
these drinks called Tokyo tea oh yeah
which was kind of like a Long Island
iced tea but it was a different blend
one of the things that was in there was
madori didn't have melon leor in there
melon leor madori and it [__] tasted
like green tea it didn't taste like
alcohol at all but it was all alcohol
yeah it was sneaky yeah and you could
you didn't need top shelf alcohol you
could use well alcohol the well booze
the cheap [__] and just as long as it
had that madori in there and it was to
be a cheap drink that big but it was
like drinking five you know I think I
could only drink three of them a
night was it like three I used to get a
similar thing um you would always get
Tokyo tea I'm not real into melons so I
would always get the Red Death yeah
which is a similar configuration red but
it was more like yeah it was red
obviously it was red and it tasted like
cherry and it kind of tastes yeah it
kind of tastes like cherry or or punch
or something like that yeah and but you
could not taste the alcohol in it at all
no but it was all Al it was all and it
was a mixture of alcohol yeah it was
like it was vodka rum tequila yeah what
else was in there just [__]
everything everything everything was in
there you could yeah it would all
counteract each other and it would just
taste like I think the most of those I
ever drank was four and I don't remember
anything after probably midnight I could
drink like three Tokyo tea was about as
strong as that I could drink three of
them but I was also being given [__]
shots all
night cuz that's the thing you don't
want to say no yeah no you know what I
mean it's like cuz the thing is we' we'd
already be shitfaced yeah on Tokyo te's
or red deaths or whatever we'd have been
out there dancing and stuff so we're
sweating some of it out I mean to be
fair we go back up to the bar to get
another drink or to get water and then
one of our friends be like shots all
around and we'd be like oh oh all right
yeah okay yeah you don't want to look
like an [__] you know what I mean
they're offering so it's like you kind
of got to do it yeah and they're
spending $5 a [__] shot right so it's
just like you know you don't want to
like I said you don't want to look like
a dick and like say no I don't really
want one plus it's a free drink right so
I just be like oh boy I'm really going
to regret this tomorrow I guess but you
know what I mean and you would just go
and do it last time we were at
barberella they don't actually have um
he doesn't have his whole liquor license
thing so they just have those premixed
cocktails in cans which some of them are
okay we got one the other day I can't
remember who makes it but it was like
Tom got it and he's like this looked
interesting so I got a couple of these
it was like a ginger beer but with booze
in it and it was really good but like I
said I could only drink one of those
because it's like if I drank more than
that I'm just going to have heartburn
all night cuz Ginger anything that's
like real spicy like that you know what
I mean is just is going to [__] me up
all
night said Tom looks like he's ready to
blow
jks I don't think
so Zach says oh God oatmeal cookies I
have proper one in Forever the cookie
not the shot well the shot's pretty good
too we make oatmeal cookies every now
and then because for whatever reason we
always have tons and tons of oatmeal
like in storage in case of a zombie
apocalypse or whatever and um so every
now and then like Tom will get a bug up
his butt and be like man we have all
that we have all those oats down there I
I should make some cookies and he'll go
downstairs like at 9:00 and like make
some [__] cookies you know what I
mean but we haven't done that in a while
we haven't done that in a
while Z said weed doesn't make you lazy
I'm stoned at work and listening to you
guys right now that's productive see
there you go where's my drink see Tom's
already lost his
drink he's already lost his
drink yeah man I kind of I miss those
old days at iar it's not there anymore I
mean it's there it's Barbarella is still
there but it's in a different location I
missed their old location though I
didn't
like because where it used to be was
like you know the the main corner of
like the main drag like of downtown
Orlando and so you'd get [__]
wanding but you know what it's like it
had been there for so long and it had
such a reputation that anybody that was
going to cause trouble they wouldn't
usually cause trouble in there I'm not
saying trouble didn't happen CU it did
but it's just like usually most people
were like that's the cool place where
everybody can go and hang out and
everybody's chill you know what I mean
so um but I kind of missed that I just I
don't know I missed that building there
was something about the way it was
configured and it was like and it looked
really cool inside it looked kind of
like it was really big and it had it
kind of had a divey Vibe but but it
wasn't a dive if that makes any sense
cuz it was really big you know what I
mean I don't know I always just really
liked it there and it was fairly clean
for a nightclub it was fun what's there
now I don't know if there's anything I
heard I think Dimitri told me that there
had been a country western bar there for
a little while which is dumb because
there's a country western bar right
literally right there like right across
the street what the [__] is that place
called all I remember is the letters
that are like American flag letters I
don't remember what it's called but
there's but there's one literally right
there like [__] 20t away and but
that's not there anymore so I don't know
if there's anything in that building it
would be awesome if he got went back in
there if he went back in there he might
go back in there because man that
building is like iconic that [__] was
there for like 30 something years that
bar see that was cuz of the co [__]
that up people stopped going downtown
and the [__] business just dropped
out of the bo out of the [__] place
yeah but he just kind of stopped going
out and it's just kind of like and you
all of downtown died and um I do like
the place where he moved it at I didn't
actually know this until fairly recently
but um John the guy that owns yeah
Barbarella iar um he owns that whole um
building where it is now yeah like that
whole Sports Center thing that was
another sideline that he had yeah so he
was telling Tom that he's like yeah I
don't even have to open the cuz he only
has it open
what once one night a week yeah he says
he's making money other two nights a
week he's just doing it for fun yeah he
just does it cuz everybody missed it and
it's a whole so he's just like ah [__]
it I'll just open it up Saturday nights
or whatever and everybody can come and
dance and next time I see him I'm going
ask him what what the possibility is a
reopen I independent was independent
made a [__] ton of money and people are
over all that they'd go back to it yeah
they probably would now yeah oh
yeah I mean if it was the way way it was
before cuz there's just some like I said
there was something about that building
there was something like about the
inside of it there was like it's kind of
like it's kind of like the castle you
can't like really replicate like when
you go in the castle in Tampa there's
nothing else really like that no like
trying to move Disneyland you'll never
be able to move that's what I mean it's
just it's got its own Vibe you come in
it's all dark it's like red there's a
dungeon and it's just kind of like the
stained glass windows and it's you know
what I mean the Castle's one of the best
goth clubs in the United
States probably the only thing that
would match it would be an old Club in
Boston used to go to that's now gone
called man
raid the castle was much bigger and it
is in a castle it's a [__] X I think
Masonic I think he used see a masonic
lodge yeah and it's big though you know
what I mean it's where all the cigar
factories used to be inor City yeah and
has an outside and an inside and it's
made out of stone and it does look like
damn pirate castle like some out of
Disneyland and it's just a beautiful
[__] goth SL fetish club you can see
it on YouTube just look up the castle or
in [__] uh e city ebore city y b o r
y is Tampa it's but it's like the old
part of
Tampa and uh we Jen still works for them
does a lot of their Graphics we used to
know a lot of the dancers cuz they had
girls dancing on boxes the cutest goth
girls ever the outfits and everything
they [__] fantastic I don't know what
it's like now we haven't been in years
we haven't been since vampire ball we
need to go back yeah they had vampire
ball once a year be [__] pack they
have vampire ball they have steampunk
ball they I think they still have
there's one two I think three dance
floors yeah huge there's a downstairs
dungeon for [__] BDSM stuff which got
cells and everything prison cells prison
cells like 1,500 pirate prison cells
with [__] rod iron [__] cages and
[__] there's a bar down there the
upstairs it's got a big Main Event it's
got [__] screens and everything two
bar three bars yeah there's a all kinds
of porn stars that you guys have jerked
into been there uh [__] it's just a
great the whole atmosphere of it is
really cool I used to well like I said I
used to drive there from
Daytona every weekend and that's a 2 and
a half hour drive each way me and Jenna
be in there [__] in that side bar
making little videos that remember our
our Gothic Orlando [__] YouTube we
used to have and [__] right behind us
was L and love Yeah remember L and love
yeah she's a porn star you can look her
up she used to live here then she's gone
now though
um that's it it's everybody's focusing
on New York and La I've been to New York
New York does have some good clubs all
right but I think
[__] I think [__] Castle beats
anything out of LA and it's been there
for there forever
yeah I think they've been there for 40
years yeah something like that it's been
a long time yeah there nothing like the
castle could exist in the LA area and I
was and I actually was really born in
the LA area I was from a southern family
that was living there at the time they
got married my mom my dad my dad got out
of the Navy and my mom was living there
with her parents and [__] uh but they
were my mom was from actually originally
from Virginia my dad was from
Mississippi and I left California in
1981 never went back I got a lot of
relatives there though my mom's side of
the family and um the closest
thing to say the castle that you could
find in La would have been like The
Viper
Room but that was a very metal scene The
Viper Room yeah but I'd easily hang out
the Viper Room hanging out with ly and
[__] back when he was alive I'd love to
have done it but just that even that
kind of looked new
compared to what you look at the castle
the castle looks like something out of
the
1500s yeah cuz it's an old building yeah
1800s and like I said it's got stained
glass windows and it looks like an old
castle it was made to to look like a an
old Spanish Fort from the
1500s like I said I think it was a
masonic lodge it was yeah it was a
masonic that was the traditional
architecture of this area there
uh Florida is the meeting place of two
empires the Spanish EMP Empire and the
British
Empire and Florida got purchased by the
American Empire when it overthrew the
British Florida has always been a
biracial
State it's it's Anglo
Latino and it's always been that way
pretty much and um because back in the
pirate days and everything was like that
it's just an interesting place man I
[__] I love love Florida I think Florida
is
the I I consider Florida to be the
capital state of the of the South some
might say well
Texas no Texas is its own thing I think
Texas is like an independent country
almost similar but very different that's
the desert a lot of that's desert and
grasslands and plains it's Texas has a
very Mexican flavor to it and it was
always biracial too it was mixture of
the Mexicans and the [__] Irish and
Germans they were the ones they it was a
private it was actually Texas when Texas
first started it was a joint business
venture between Mexican families and
American German families for in the in
the cattle industry so it was always two
people but
Florida I'm going to say that's the
Florida is the jungle man this is the
tropical
State very different from Mississippi
very different from
Alabama but I I just I just like it here
Jen's sick of it she's from here yeah I
was born here but I just I enjoy it it's
like something hot man it's like
something out of Disneyland Pirates of
the Caribbean that's here too but that's
it's like a pirate [__] now I like to
New Orleans I love I I don't like the
Heat and I don't like the rednecky [__]
yeah there's certain elements to the
that but there's cool [__] here too you
just got to know where to look that's
all it's not all rednecky [__] I can
navigate through I can even navigate
through the rednecky [__] you know what
I mean [__] my family's a bunch of
rednecks I can well yeah mine is to BU I
can navigate through it it's just the
deit gets old um because it's that's
that that's the basic setting that's
basic
[__] and they get frustrating because
they're locked only on one television
channel they got one way of doing things
they're not real
flexible there's more than one way to
live they they're not really into that
yeah I've noticed yeah that's what I
don't like about it they don't have good
fashion sense that's the main thing I
got against cuz look man I don't have
good fashion sense I don't have a
problem with people that are like
different than me but I I can't hang
with people who think that the way they
live is the way the right way I I just
can't you can live however you want as
long as you're chill with everyone else
living the way they want to within
limits you know what I mean yeah
sometimes they malfunction they're not
quite
sure they have a very small
um Overton window of
acceptability yeah which blows my mind
yeah a little bit even in this day and
age it depends on it depends on the
generation we were at a Dollar General
the other day not the one we not the one
by our house but one we stopped at
another one like on the way back from
Ichibon right yeah because I had to get
some cat food and there was a whole line
of people yeah this is some weird [__]
man you guys are going to like it there
was a whole line of people waiting to
check out waiting to check out but the
self checkout was right there so we're
just like are you guys not know to check
and they're like oh no no no no we're
not using self check check out I'm like
you know this is like 2023
right I had to explain we're like okay
well I'm just going to use it then if
y'all aren't going to I had to explain
that's a huge line I had to explain to
Jenny I understand you know she probably
knows but I have to re-explain yeah I
know man planing is part of a man's job
I said these rednecks is you're a lot of
these rednecks have not conquered the
[__] banking system okay they don't
have atess they don't have ATM cards and
uh if they do have an ATM card they may
not actually know how to use that
[__] machine which to me that's
[__] mindblowing because that means
that they don't know the internet and
they can't make online purchases which
explains why they look the way they do
and why they dress the way they do I
guess so cuz they got to go to the mall
to get their clothes I just didn't
realize that anyone in this day and age
was that far behind well no the day two
days later we're at the other [__]
Dollar General store which Dollar
General store here is like our version
of 7-Eleven they're just [__] well
they put them in food Des food deserts
like in rural areas and there are
wonderful stores they got everything
they got everything and it's cheap and
it's cheap um they're not pretty though
but they got everything in there yeah
they're pretty uh workmanlike I need
needles well we got needles I need a
[__] hot pocket okay we got I need
milk got that got I want some chocolate
we got that they got everything I need
some [__] floor mats yeah we got that
for the car other day I was like I need
I need some like clothes hangers I went
there to for a dollar need some I need
some [__] Harley-Davidson [__] 50
weight oil 20 20 w50 oh we got that they
had oil there all right Harley-Davidson
oil okay cool all right so they got it
they got [__] and it's cheap we were at
the other
one doing self checkout and dude proudly
says I don't do that I'm old school
that's right I forgot about remember
that [__] I don't do that [__] I'm old
school that's what's wrong with the
world today not hiring people and I
almost I didn't want to get into it with
your old dude because I'd had to fight
him I'd have whipped his ass but I
didn't
he just didn't know what he was talking
about I was thinking dude she doesn't
want to check you out she's got other
work to do [__] stocking these
shelves get a at get a bank account get
a ATM card and learn how to check your
own [__]
out but they don't they don't understand
I prefer self checkout honestly I was
really glad when they established that
like yeah some people say um you know in
Tammy was saying maybe it bothers people
because it's like taking people's jobs
away but the thing about it is that when
you're you know if you're working at
Dollar General I mean checking people
out is like a pretty small part of your
job anyway what they're doing like most
of the [__] that they're doing is like
bringing in inventory and like putting
it on the shelves and stuff like that so
they hate checking you out I would I
also hate checking people because I hate
people they're like why don't you learn
how to do this yourself CU they're J
they're very understaffed and their
whole thing is to stock and inventory
yeah they got to keep all that [__]
right and they got to keep the store
clean and they have to keep it organized
and all that other kind of stuff so they
don't really want to check the people
out I feel at at your average Dollar
General Store there's only two or three
people working at one time yeah we go in
there and there's sometimes there's only
one person in there depending on what
and they love us at our next door they
know us that's my favorite couple yeah
we come in there all the time yeah we go
in there all the time my favorite goth
couple the dude knows us at the liquor
store too which I'm not sure if that's
something to be proud of but we were
talking today about my [__] snake P
yeah we were said they were talking
about they were talking about like
Escape From LA and stuff yeah yeah he
[__] lik was about the castle the
other day too cuz I guess he goes there
that's right um so even in like redneck
he may listening cuz we gave him the
show that's right so even in rednecky
areas there are like stealth goth people
now look Jen calls this a rednecky
area it is from her point of view it is
not from the point of view of [__]
heidleberg or Laurel Mississippi where
I'm going say what did no no no no this
isn't the Big City compared to out there
that's the [__] scary place man well
yeah I would not want to go there well
like I said I was going to go with you
yeah I would have just because so I
didn't have to miss you all this time
all those days you'd be gone but like
we're always together anyway every time
we come back we have [__] wild sex
man I mean we do that anyway even though
we see even though we see each other
down today we were throwing down today
should have recorded that [__] right
before the show we should have showed
that sh I give it up I I was in here in
the office working on editing the video
give it up she like I'm going give it up
all right yeah I'm giving it up yeah
[__] I was kind of tired of working
on that video anyway yeah I figured you
were [__] bored of I'm going I'm g go
in there and I'm G [__] [__] out of I'm
go the rest hold on thank you I
appreciate that yeah yeah but yeah I
know I told like I don't I don't know
how long he's going to be gone I don't
know last time it was two weeks I don't
know if it's going to be that long this
time like I said I'm still going to do
the shows and stuff but we'll see so
I'll still do a movie review Monday
night I don't know which one I want to
do though cuz Z was saying yeah I did
malland drive like when he was gone I'll
probably do some [__] like I've been
wanting to rewatch the spiral staircase
from
1946 um I don't know why I just got that
in my head I was like man I really want
to like rewatch that because it's been a
long time so I might do that one but I'm
not really sure we'll see how it goes
but yeah so I'm definitely going to do a
movie review Monday night like normal
I'll do the Regular Show Wednesday night
like normal depending on what the
poll whatever the poll winner is if it's
a okay here what I'm going to say if you
are on our patreon or if you're a
YouTube member and you can vote in the
topic polls if the topic I don't even
remember what topics I put in there
because I think I put that poll up like
two weeks ago because I usually put them
up like you know sometime in advance
because I write down everybody's topic
ideas and then I was like when I have
five you know I put them in a in a poll
and then I just put them up to go up at
the relevant time so if the topic comes
up being something that it's it's like
oh that would be better if Tom was here
then I might save it and you know what I
mean and just do something that that I
could just talk about you know I don't
know well we'll see how it goes the poll
doesn't close till Sunday afternoon so
we'll see how it
goes um yeah High Desert said I've seen
check writing at stores go completely
out thank goduck took forever I saw old
woman write a check and me was looking
at the guy [__] behind the counter
we're looking like what the [__] is this
yeah isn't it funny how like some
younger people is like what is she doing
M writing a
check I
understand the uh the fear of a uh
totally electronic currency kind of like
China has they want it
here but that has not you know having an
ATM card or the credit
cards in a bank account no I just don't
I I don't understand how they survive
without it in this day and age I don't
see how anybody which means can like
live in the world without having an
internet connection and a bank card at
the very [__] least yeah and this is
not in the middle of nowhere no we're
not yeah we're literally only 20
something minutes from downtown from
downtown Orlando like where maybe 28
minutes something like that it's not far
and and during the time I've less than
an hour from Disney World during the
time I've lived here downtown or Orlando
has grown into a worldclass city it's
nice got some beautiful apartments and
[__] Scenic [__] lights and then you
go over towards Disney World beautiful
[__] [__] rides that [__] like
the slingshot and all kinds it's pretty
out there it looks like something I
don't know out of Dubai or something you
know it's this is a nice place it's
fancy it's
fancy and everything kind of looks does
kind of look like a theme park pretty
much well all the the the middle and
upper class the middle class and upper
areas there's a lot of areas that
absolutely don't look yeah there's some
dumpy areas but middle class and up
looks like something out of a damn theme
park manicured Lawns and manicured trees
and it's pretty yeah they freeways are
pretty they got all this [__] [__]
they try to make everything look nice
cuz like I said tourism is our main uh
that's our main economy you know if that
goes we're kind of [__] and the
economy is booming a lot of moved here
they brought a lot of their talent and
money with them it's it's a [__]
great state it reminds me very much of
California in the 70s when it was
booming when I lived there was a kid
kind of reminds me of that better better
because a lot of California
ghetto I was living in
Carson Carson now is the hood [__]
Dominguez
area looking U but you know places get
old you know they get worn out
yeah I mean it just happens it's a
Natural Evolution and a lot of these
dumpy places here in Florida around in
this area that we're in back in the 60s
those was those were the good areas M
and some of those houses like the kind
of dumpy and you look at them their 80s
houses but back in the 80s man that was
the [__] that was those were the rich
neighborhoods you know just that the
those houses are old now people with
money don't want them yeah I mean
everything gets old that's how happen
but you look at the house you're like
man this is like a house from [__]
Poltergeist yeah and that was the [__]
would have been a dream house in
California back in the
80s yeah Tammy said I used to work at
Walmart and they were always paging the
people off the floor to go up and run
the registers yeah yeah I mean the thing
about it and I know some people like
maybe piss and moan about oh they're not
paying me to like ring up the groceries
and blah blah but it's like is it really
that much of a an ordeal no and like I
said I would rather ring up my own [__]
to be honest it's much quicker I can can
do [__] much quicker than other people
can do it you know what I mean so it's
just kind of like I just want to get out
of here without having to interact with
people if I to the less I have to
interact with people the better it is so
I will take self checkout every time all
right I got to pee you talk you talk I'm
going
talk the reason hold let me see what's
going everybody's going on
here from Epstein to Hamas versus Israel
okay n all day Okay the reason why I was
saying that
a digital currency and then having an
ATM card is not quite the same thing so
a lot of people are not really up to
speed of what a digital currency is a
digital currency is a currency that's
owned by some kind of unelected [__]
Board of people of [__] do gooders or
[__] you know control freaks that
decide how much your money is worth like
another words you get paid a certain
amount of money they're talking about
giving everybody Universal basic income
there's a certain amount of [__]
something there is some good that is
kind of a good idea because you're if
you're going to make everybody
unemployed by exporting jobs you better
[__] pay them something you know his
welfare whatever but the problem comes
down to this they decide where you're
going to spend your money you say yeah I
got I got $1,000 I want to buy say an
AR-15 or a [__] pistol or something
which is legal to have in this country
they're gonna say yeah you can have it
it's legal but we're going to charge you
10,000% [__] tax and the price goes
up so it's an interactive money that
decides how much you're going to pay so
then they're going like no yeah yeah you
could have bread but we don't want you
to buy that bread right there so we're
going to add 100% tax on that bread the
price will be higher we want you to buy
this bread because my brother-in-law
owns that bread company so they'll be
able to do all kinds of [__] it'll be a
disaster people revolt against it it
wouldn't work these are all just the
cockamamy Pie in the Sky
dreams the Eggheads come up with all
right same kind of egg heads but the
Germans and the bent cross it's all
these [__] delusional [__] power
dreams all
right ain't gonna happen okay go ahead
um Oracle has to take her Kitty to the
final vet visit tomorrow uhoh and the
kitty is hiding under the bed how old is
that cat I I think she said 17 that's a
pretty old cat what is it incon
incontinent now said and the she said
the kitty looked like Pooky but with a
longer tail yeah is it incontinent or
something I saw that I don't know but
like earlier I saw that has no idea
what's going on and I was just kind of
like I know but you know it's not the
kitty that I worry about it's like I
don't you know man that BM you so much
I've seen whole horses be put down it's
sad yeah okay well but the horse had no
idea what was happening I know they
don't but it's just kind of like they
inject the shot and the horse gets
sleepy and falls down and never wakes
up I'm more worried about like how I
would react you know what I mean the
thing about putting a cat down is you I
don't know how they're doing it are they
putting a cat in a room and putting a
damn [__] carbon monoxide in there
from the back end of a tailpipe of a car
that's the way they would do it in Mass
some of these execution places that they
God don't say [__] like that Fu or are
they doing it with an injection and if
they're doing it with an injection I
wouldn't I would want to be with the cat
well that's how they do it obvious yeah
why I can't believe you [__] said
that because that's not how they put
down that's not how they put down
[__] uh
Garbo drop Garbo off they said okay
we'll take care of
it well they don't generally do that
okay they don't generally do that yeah
all right I wasn't there when Garbo got
put yeah I dropped him off and okay
we'll take care of it thank you does it
go
right yeah Oracle said I'm going to
wander off and spend some time with my
kitty since it's his last night with us
man that's sad
I'm
sorry good night Oracle why why is the
cat sick is cat sick yeah I guess so
yeah okay like I said it was a while
back but I didn't get to it but I think
she said he was 17 yeah that's
old it is but you
know it's I I randomly think about it
like every now and then and I get like
all upset yeah you
know because I know it's going to happen
but it's like I don't I don't know how
I'm going to react to it you know Jan is
talking about he wants us to cover the
1920s Wall Street behind yeah yeah I
think that was in the poll cuz somebody
recommended that like a long time ago
okay but I put in the poll a couple
times but it never won but I was saying
that while you were in the bathroom I
said if whatever wins the poll because
the poll closes on Sunday yeah at noon
if whatever wins the poll is a topic
that I think would be better if you were
here yeah then I might save it and like
go to the second one and then we'll save
that one for when you come back d just
brought up a good [__] point you see
talking about how good those Casino
buffets at the casinos were down [__]
in buuy down Mississippi I've heard that
yeah oh yeah we used to eat me and my
ex-wife used to eat there [__] a
couple times a month man they were
[__] great and thanks for reminding
me because I'm going to stop off there
and [__] eat on my way up that's
where I'm going to go yeah you you going
to film it and send it to me like all
the food the maybe I'm look at all the
food that I'm eating that you I'm going
go to Har I'm going to go to I'm going
to go to haris or [__] treasure
Bay yeah they had [__] steaks there
on the [__] Buffet
[__] cun [__] seasoned crawfish
not that bland crawfish they have
Chinese food they have [__] Xander in
there that [__] was [__] hot yeah
they got [__] great
food at Mississippi Casinos I'm gonna go
ahead and plug the Mississippi Casinos
if you want to go to a [__] good
Casino during the summertime man take
one of these little tiny flights and
[__] [__] go to buuy or [__]
gulport airport and get off there and go
to those
[__] Mississippi Casinos they're
[__] great and it's not super crowded
it's not like a big city but they're
just beautiful casinos and you'll have
fun
there so now I know Tom's going to go
and eat at all the Mississippi Casinos
go to Mississippi get all kind of good
food and then he's going to send me
videos of it I'll be like so you should
have come I'm sitting here eating a
little Debbie
cool it was during those days it was
about 20 bucks for the casino excuse me
20 bucks for the that was a long time
ago yeah 20 bucks for the [__] what
you call the thing is though is that the
food the cost of the food doesn't really
mean anything to those casinos no it's a
it's a loss leader that's nothing yeah
they they're just trying to get you into
the casino they just want you to stay
there longer well there was I was
watching a whole video about that the
other day where it's just like yeah the
whole reason that they put buffets it
was on weird history food actually it
was like the history of Buffets which
like I said started out in Europe but um
they were like well they started them in
Vegas because the casino owners were
like hey if we put a [__] free buffet
in here then these people will stay here
all [__] day cuz they don't have to
go anywhere they don't have to leave to
go to a restaurant or whatever so it's
like we'll keep them in here longer and
take more of their money the buffet
wasn't free well in the in the old days
it in the old days they were yeah the
buffets weren't free you had to pay to
get in there now they might have been
free if you had a room yeah you were
staying in a room there prably free but
uh because they try to get you to stay
in those rooms as long as they can
well yeah and they just want to take as
much they're trying to get as much money
as they can out of you which you know
it's a business that's what they're
doing they're just trying to get all the
money they can go down there and play
the [__] black [__] black uh
[__] roulette table playing those two
bets on the outside then he's going to
call me and be like um I lost all my
money can you come get me I'm homeless
yeah Jen I [__] lost all my money on
hookers that's that sounds like some
[__] you no I would that sounds like
some [__] no she's worried now I lost am
I lost all my money and I have an
STD that's what he's going to say no
those are clean girls down there just
kid how would you know just kid no I'm
gonna uh but no I do want to stop off at
one of the I think I'm GNA [__] stop
off at Harris we'll see how I feel yeah
I mean you know maybe on the way maybe
on the way back I mean try to have a fun
time yeah I know it's not great I'll
[__] record it I'll show you that
it's it's kind imagine imagine like ich
bomb yeah no more like Kian yeah but
it's [__] uh staks and [__] man I
want I C food and [__] was like you made
some steaks like a few months back and
that was like really I got steaks Frozen
oh you do okay yeah those were off that
farm oh that's right we still that's
right yeah I got aot [__] the damn that
was a long time ago we got cows around
here yeah yeah you go to the farm and
you just like buy blueberries or eggs
spent like [__] 150 bucks on [__]
beef but it wasn't a whole lot of it but
we still got got some of it left oh okay
I didn't know that yeah guess I was
going to say cuz we just had some steaks
a little while back so yeah I mean I
know it's like I said it's not a fun
trip really because he's got to go see
his dad but he'll probably have fun I
got to be here by myself with no money
at least he's not taking by car some
he's it's not like I have anywhere to go
though I don't have anywhere to go I'm
not going to go to the club by myself
you know it's not fun and it's like I
don't really want to drive and it's too
far you know what I mean it's like so
I'm too worried about it so I'll
probably just stay home I might go out
to eat a few times but that's probably
all I'll do to be
honest um yeah Danny said the casino
buffets and the catfish Farms are a
bargain in Mississippi yeah I can
imagine I don't know how much they are
now because like I said that was a long
time ago what Tomas talking about his
first wife that was [__] when was that
that was probably back in the early
2000s you know what I mean a long time
ago so I imagine they're probably more
now although I don't know like we the
buffets we go to like kiwan and stuff
like that and Ichiban they're only
about I think the lunch buffet at
Ichiban
is 20
no I think it's $15.99 like plus tax and
drinks and stuff like that I think it's
$15.99 oh banging okay which means
good okay sorry I can't see that good
yeah Danny said that Casino buffets and
the catfish Farms are banging in
Mississippi yeah yeah yeah well you know
like I said send me videos I got to pass
through there on my way up there cuz
like I said I'm probably not going to go
no place I'm just going to be sitting in
the house the whole time I don't want to
make it jealous show all the good food
all the head then I'll be like a usually
it wasn't I mean it's been a long time
since I've been there but I think back
in the day it was about 20
bucks now that doesn't cover what you
ate they're just trying to bait you into
that damn right casino and they want you
to play some on that blackjack table or
on the [__] one arm Bandits you know
slot machine never play slot machines
people never play slot machines the
worst one actually the in terms of odds
the best ones is [__]
Blackjack but you got to be good at
Blackjack and uh still odds are always
in The house's
favor yeah always always I think
Blackjack the odds are least in The
house's favor but they are still
absolutely in The house's
favor business they're just trying to
make money everybody I knew from back in
the time I lived down in
gulport who made money
gambling were people that drove down
there in [__] vws they lived out in
the parking lot and they would go into
the casinos they would live off that
[__]
$20 [__] a day damn
Buffet yeah buffet and they would go
down to the [__] um um poker table
and they would play against other
tourists the house takes a cut but
you're not playing against the house
they don't care who wins and what
they're looking for is they're looking
for we weak
players so they're going around it's
going who's where are the weakest
[__] players I'm going take their
[__]
money that is not the sage playing
against house you're not playing against
the house you're playing against weak
players house taking a cut that's the
way you do it and some of them made good
money that way thing is they were all
old
guys living in [__] V
RVs and uh on
retirement
pay and uh man [__] living in that
casino would get old after a while
they're living in the casino Park lot
they like it but I I yeah Zan said I've
known people out here in Nevada who live
off gambling by playing craps or betting
on sports but they do live in the
parking lot they live in the parking lot
nice guys though yeah I mean hey if
that's the way you want to live and like
I said a lot of them are retired so they
probably get Social Security or whatever
so it's not like they're going to starve
to death or nothing they get like you
know so you can do what you want yeah
and if he's some old dude he's living in
a [__] RV the RV is pretty much paid
is paid for he's getting a [__]
couple thousand dollars a month he's
eating out of there he's having a good
time he has good winnings they never
[__] really come up
they have good winnings they spend them
on
hookers that's what they do and then
they go back in there and Gamble and
[__] it's like an endless cycle but
they're living in the parking lot in the
RV yeah so that's what Tom's planning to
do he's gonna go there I'm do that he's
gonna win a bunch of money spend it all
on hooker isn't that something she and
then he's not going to tell me no no I
didn't win any money no no I SP on
hooker why do I have this STD I don't
know these are dudes in their [__]
60s and 70s I don't
know Victor says my friend and his
girlfriend were playing slots at the
casino and when they left she realized
she left her phone at the slot machine
they drove back he found the phone and
decided to play one more time he won
$20,000 and I think of that every time
someone mentions casinos man that's like
[__] that's outside the [__] well
yeah but that's like that's like Wily
Wonka where he went back in to buy that
one more candy bar and then that was the
one that had the golden ticket in it
it's just kind of like that yeah that's
not what usually happens usually what
happens is the one arm bandit takes all
your [__] money yeah you'll lose more
that's why I don't even start I don't I
don't have that gambling that's the
worst that's the worst one I'm just used
to like hanging on to my money because I
never had any yeah so it's just to me it
seems like really wasteful and I'm just
like I know the odds are against me and
it's like I know I'm just going to lose
all my money so I don't even best one's
Blackjack craps certain bets on the
roulette
table but it's just raw odds and the
odds are is that over time house
wins house oh always wins yeah so you
know that's what I figure yeah if you
want to [__] actually try to live off
of being a gambler it's poker because
you're not playing against yeah like
there are some people that have made a
living uh doing that but you have to be
really good at it you had to be really
good at it and a new guys that did it
they said you had to be not only have to
be really good at poker you have to be
really good at choosing what where
you're going to sit down at what table
Yeah cuz you're choosing you're looking
at the Players you're saying where are
the weakest players you're going to go
take their money you know if you know
all the regulars you go I ain't going
there well yeah know that dude that
[__] good I'm not going to play
against him I'll lose my money [__]
you're going to play against the weak
players and take their money you're
going to play against some people that
look like marks exactly exactly although
if you were smart you would go in there
looking like a mark yeah they know
better though they know better they know
better it's like going in there going
they go that is not I don't know what
I'm doing well you can't overplay it
obviously because you can't you know
what I mean Zan said the most I've seen
someone win is 10K on slots yeah but the
casino took several hours to give over
the money and you have to pay tax after
$1,000 yeah it's still free money well
yeah it's a um that's several thousand
dollars more than I have so they can
take a couple hours to give it to me
that's fine yeah some of that [__] they
take almost half which again that's
several thousand dollars more I got
right now so I'm not complaining about
it I think it depends on what [__]
State you're in or whatever what what I
think it's about almost half I think on
winnings I'm not sure yeah I'm not sure
if that's a state thing or or federal I
don't know because some people well
Florida does not have state income tax
um so when you fire taxes you only do
federal income tax but I know some
states you do federal income and state
income tax but uh Florida does have that
so I don't know I mean obviously you
have to pay if you won like a big
jackpot in like sweep steak or something
um yeah you do have to pay tax on it but
I think they give you the option nowaday
it's like hey do you want us to take it
out before we give it to you yeah you
know what I mean so you can like pay the
tax on it before like so you won't even
notice it's
gone
maybe the uh the casinos are probably
about six hours from
here maybe seven six and a half around
that
time one day I'll take you
yeah I mean six hours is no big deal
it's not that much yeah I mean I'm not
I'm not gonna do any of my money with
that [__] because like I I have little
enough money as it is I'm not going to
lose all of it on that kind of
crap DVD Dragon said STD in Mississippi
is called Mississippi Burning yeah
that's funny Tom comes back with the
Mississippi Burning and I'll be like
what have you been up
to you know how I like to tease well
you're the one that always like jokes
about hookers and stuff like that so
it's like you know you're kind of she
get paranoid you're kind of asking for
Ito you're always bringing [__] up about
it teasing Jan about it yeah what was
that you said the other night that I was
like I didn't really think of anything
of it but I was just kind of like I
thought it was weird that you said it
you said it on was it last week's show
the show yeah last week's show or the
show before I don't remember I think it
was like one of the Sidetrack show that
yeah about cheating yeah and saying this
and you said something like just kind of
randomly like out of like oh well you
know it could happen to a guy just one
time it's just like a mistake you know
what I mean it's just kind of like you
know she probably forgive you and blah
BL blah I'm like yeah and I was kind of
like I gave you that look you know you
know like that Meme face and I was just
kind of like I didn't say anything time
but then later I was like why did you
say that like randomly cuz it it didn't
have anything to do with what we were
talking about no but she but he then he
explained he's like oh there was a whole
context behind it he's like I've been
watching this YouTube video earlier and
it's just like there was this guy that
was talking about this and he was
thinking about that so I was just kind
of like oh okay well I didn't know the
Contex it wasn't a guy that was thinking
about it girl girl okay it was a girl
girl that was talking about it cuz
sometimes you say things and you know
the context but nobody else does like
and I don't so it's just kind of like
why did he just say that randomly that's
odd so I was just like what is what the
context was I was watching one of those
dating programs it was called whatever
and I didn't know that there's a channel
called whatever on on so I was like you
just brought that up out of the whatever
was [__] funny that's on YouTu you
trying to tell
me oh no on whatever they had a girl I
don't remember exactly what it was the
girl was saying that
[__] her boyfriend cheated on her but
it was okay she forgave him for it type
of deal but I don't remember what
happened after that I was I was just
talking okay so you were thinking about
that yeah yeah yeah like I said I didn't
know that and from my point of view it
just sounded like you just said some
[__] randomly and I was just kind of
like no her boyfriend cheated on her and
she kind of forgave him for it but the
[__] came on came she did some other
[__] later on and he didn't forgive her
I don't remember what it was I remember
okay so it was a whole thing yeah yeah
yeah it was a whole thing it yeah I
didn't know you watch those videos all
no I don't watch them and the thing is
that these are people in their 20s yeah
well there so I don't know I don't I
don't know who the audiences all the
time I'm trying to talk to a general
audience I like to [__] go to kind of
like a slightly younger default like I'm
talking to people in their 30s you know
what I mean right cuz [__] like
me got to spread wisdom you know what
I'm talking about I really think about
the ages of the people that we're
talking to I don't really think of
myself as any
particular you know had I [__] known
how things really were back in my
[__] 20s and 30s that have been a lot
better but I was under back in those
days in the pre- internet era it was
easy to live under certain delusions
about the way the world actually was and
the way human nature actually was
[__] which
um
um I don't know can cause [__]
discomfort because you have [__] high
expectations for certain things but
that's not the way things really are
it's better to just kind of like think
well well I okay I don't know if I'd do
it depends on the person yeah some
people the average person I don't expect
much out of them anymore but the thing
is is that you got to realize that I'm
trying to deal with people who are above
average like Jen's very above average
she gets mad when I say certain things
and I'm say here's I'm not talking about
you I'm talking about the
average that's why I married you that's
why all went down you know what I mean
if you were average you'd be long gone
you know hold on let me get let me get
this here all right let me get you
something you want some more of that or
you want juice this time I mean that
coke is good well is there any left yeah
oh okay yeah lots I feel like we'd
probably gone through the whole two
lader by now but I guess
not okay um yeah that's fine well that I
mean you know he says nice things about
that but well I I don't know if I get
mad necessarily it's just kind of like I
don't know I don't like to generalize
about people because I don't know
everybody you know what I
mean everybody's different so so I I
don't really think about things that
way spread
wisdom yeah I never really think about
uh things like that like I said I know
we have people in the chat that are all
ages and we have friends that are all
ages um to be honest we have you know we
have friends that are in their 20s 30s
40s 50s we have friends that are older
than us and stuff like that and it's
just um not really something that I
think about
because when you talk to them it doesn't
really there's not like a big oo
generation gap okay Boomer type
situation you know what I mean like
everybody's just kind of on the same
page go so like I said maybe that's kind
of um just us being in a particular
subculture where everybody likes the
same [__] so it's like everybody's
talking about the same [__] um or you
know things that are adjacent to that so
everybody is just kind of like I said on
the same page about things you don't
really get this whole thing where it's
like oh my God they're 20 and they don't
know anything you know what I mean you
don't really get that too
much Z is talking about Del Taco yeah we
only um honestly we only have two I
think two Del Tacos the one I used to go
to was
in I want to say it was in Winter Park
or a poka which is like near the um
univers no not University of
Florida one of those colle campuses over
there
UCF University of Central Florida and
there was one over there and my friend
used to live over there my friend Jen
used to live over there so we would go
there somay because it was open all
night so you know we'd be out drinking
or whatever and be like let's go to Del
Taco but I think that we only have two
but they are but they are good they are
better than Taco Bell I would submit Del
Taco better than Taco Bell yeah we only
have two around here like I think right
they're just yeah there's not
around yeah the the only one I've ever
been to around around here is over by
UCF like do you remember where my friend
Jen used to live like over in like was
it Winter Park or Ovito or something I
used to live in wter Park when I was a
kid back in the 70s me andell tacos
sucked they were worse than [__] Taco
Bell but now [__] Jen took me to one
we went to go see one of those damn live
in theater [__] uh Rift tracks yeah
and there was a Del Taco Del Taco on the
way and that [__] was [__] fire I
told you it was it had put Taco Bell to
shame a shame
I don't even know if they're open all
night anymore cuz that was a long time
ago that and it was a fast food taco
place it wasn't fancy or anything just
just the [__] that they give you is
[__] great I like it's an American
Taco yeah a Mexican will not be
impressed a North Mexican might or
[__] you know a Mexican American from
Southern California would probably like
it they got it's good for American fast
food it's yeah it's you know and it's
better than Taco Bell yeah yeah it's its
own thing I've never been a huge fan of
Taco Bell I got to say I liked it
because it just so cheap and you could
get well yeah see I mean I think that's
kind of the appeal like the food is
acceptable it's edible it's fine um but
yeah I think the price point was the big
appeal I used to get a whole [__]
pack of like 20 tacos for like five
bucks back in the middle you could get
like a whole bunch of food like so all
your drunk or stone friends or whatever
you'd be like oh bro we could feed
everybody yeah for like $5 you know what
I mean that's amazing I don't know you
can do that anymore yeah's going [__]
Delo Superior bro yes it is yeah and I
like too that they also have French
fries I don't know if they still do but
they used to have french fries you can
get tacos with french fries on the side
maybe you can even get a taco with
french fries on it I'm not really sure
what's s saying about like that last one
he said about uh Del taco is good
because they say hey this is fake
Mexican food here's a side of fries yeah
with your that's what I was just saying
and I like that yeah and their french
fries are kind of floppy but I like that
I like floppy french fries I like crispy
french fries too all french fries are
good really yeah DVD Dragon s come back
[__]
fat Tom is gonna come back from the
Mississippi trip fat from the buffet
broke from gambling and with a child
support bill from Hookers oh he trying
to
get no
look you're not going to be gone that
long are you be he's going to be gone
nine months and he comes back with the
baby and I got to come back you know and
I'm [__] dealing with the deep south
Mississippi [__] Scottish Irish Clan
of the [__] of the of the [__]
Ross Carpenter [__] family all right
um it it's it's it's cool my [__]
cousin is uh he's uh an army he's a Navy
veteran who served with the 101st airor
division in Afghanistan the Navy served
with the 101st he was doing combat
Patrols in Afghanistan as a Navy guy
with my old [__] division this is
Scott infantry Scott you're talking
about Scott Carpenter yeah he looks just
like he looks just like my dad
I he posted a picture of him and my dad
at the same age and he looked more like
my dad than I looked I look a little bit
more like my mom but we you can
definitely I look more like my granddad
too on my dad's day yeah you showed me a
picture of you and your granddad like at
a similar age and you look a lot like
your yeah I got pictures of that [__]
somewhere you look a lot like your
grandfather hold on hold on I remember
you show on the other one it's at my
other tablet but
um the uh it it's going to be [__]
business um now my other cousin
Catherine these are all this is okay the
Carpenters are the which is that's my
dad's
sister married a carpenter so all of
their her children are carpenters
they're um cun they're from they're from
uh they're from
Louisiana uh
but it it's all about the same thing
they have a slight [__] ass
[__] accent and [__] [__] but you
know just they're just crazy my cousin
my female cousin cat she was named after
my grandmother she probably coming too
she was cool she's goth yeah she's a
goth chick she's on my Facebook too yeah
I got a picture of her I'll show her
she's super cool I I've never met her in
real life but yeah she's all
uh she's all po polyamorous and [__] and
[__] her
boyfriend's wife and [__] [__] and
she kicked the [__] wife out and now
she's got the boyfriend to herself and
all kinds of weird [__] that was
happening oh Victor says Tom if you just
stick to pegging you won't have to worry
about any of that coming home with a
baby hold on one second I got a message
from my cousin he's not listening just
got back maybe revisit him earli Tommy
key said the the doc was telling him
this morning he don't think it's too
long so the they were pretty insistent
on
okay so the doctor thinks my dad's dying
oh
[__] so it's all right well hey I got to
go when I
go cuz you're just going to rent a car
and go right so yeah you can go
whenever I thought that we weren't sure
like what was going to happen because
it's like originally Tom's planning well
I'll go on Monday okay but depending on
what happens yeah he he yeah this is all
not a surprise this has been going on
for a long
time okay hold on one
second let me see updates in real time
yeah that's a live stream
baby I you know what I mean I was hoping
for the best but you know I figured that
[__] he's probably going he's sick of
that
[__] you know yeah I mean it gets to a
point where yeah you don't really cuz I
went through the same thing with my
grandmother like obviously I didn't want
her to die because you know I was really
close to her and stuff but after a time
she was like I don't just want to do
this [__] [__] anymore it was too
much that's my cousin cat yeah yeah
she's cool
yeah is she going yeah she probably G to
be there cuz I know you were he was
talking to her last night yeah and
um she became goth cuz I was goth
she still she's a little kid she's seen
me going to the [__] uh French
Quarter and [__] getting ready at her
house she was a te she was [__] still
in high school she's like don't go don't
go to the club [__] and I was like no
I got to go to the club and all her
little friends goes no no don't go don't
go I got to go we're too young we can't
go you can't don't go don't go no I have
to go I have to go yeah it's imp she
look like that
then a yeah she's like don't go don't go
she's going to be like yeah they wanted
me to [__] hang out all [__] night
with them in their little [__]
slumber parties and [__] I was in my 20s
I said no I gotta go what are you
talking about hang out with you [__]
little girls and [__] you little girls
yeah
oh yeah everybody's saying uh Zach's
like oof sorry Tom yeah and then back
says Tom I'm sorry yeah no I figured I
mean yeah that's why we weren't sure
like I said that's why we weren't sure
when he was going to go and stuff like
that because we didn't know what was
going to happen because like when he
went when he did had the
bypass however many years ago three or
four years ago Tom's like well I'm going
to go out there because I don't know
what's going to happen but he ended up
recovering from that right so I was so
he's dying he says waiting to hear back
from the doctor probably tomorrow he had
an emergency surgery today the doctor
did seems stable to us but he's telling
us the cancer and the COPD I don't know
what that is yeah that's like that um
that uh breathing yeah too so it's
likely even if he doesn't if that
doesn't get him probably took most his
remaining time hoping for the best
planning for the
worst well that's all you can do I
mean yeah I mean I heard from my mom
today too that my stepdad's not doing
that great either and like he's got he's
been in the hospital and then he came
home today and he's got home hospice
care so I don't know how that's going to
go yeah but yeah yeah her stepdad's died
too yeah so I mean I kind of figured I
saw him at my grandmother's funeral when
was that like that was probably a month
or two ago and he was like walking
around and stuff but you could tell that
he wasn't doing too good but you know
we'll see how it goes I'm kind of
worried about my mom I don't know
because she kind of lives out in the
middle of nowhere in
Okala and um I mean their neighbors look
out for them and stuff they have other
people that live around there so it's
not like she's by herself but I don't
really like the idea of her living out
there by herself so he's not awake okay
so this just you know what I
mean yeah Tammy him sedated yeah yeah
Tammy said speaking from experience it
might not be a surprise that your parent
is going to die but it still hurts yeah
yeah it does yeah I mean even if you're
prepared for it it's always cuz like I
said when my grandmother died who like I
said I was very close to cuz I grew up
you know living with her a lot of the
time and it's like you knew it was going
to happen she went to hospice she was in
the hospital she knew she had cancer she
was like they did surgery they didn't
get it all and she was like [__] it I'm
not doing chemo I'm not going through
that yeah and so we knew that it was
happening but still when it happened it
was really upsetting yeah it was really
upsetting but you know it took me a
while to like get over it but you know
what are you going to do you can't do
anything no nothing I can do happens to
everybody I can't help him yeah Tammy
said that's what my mom died from COPD
yeah cuz remember Tammy said her mom
died the other day yeah he's saying it's
sucking he's saying the doctor says it's
probably sucking him down yeah we'll
see mean what can I do there's nothing I
can do you know that's what I mean it's
like well and I think that's why people
get upset about it because you feel like
you should be able to do something but
you can't I mean realistically no it's
[__] it's it's the way of the force
you're only given so much time and
things [__] you know what I mean he's
in the best carry possibly have they
can't do anything yeah so I can't do
anything right I mean all you can do is
just kind of like he's a wake is be
there
yeah and a lot of times you know even if
they don't because like when I was with
my grandmother like she was in a coma so
it's like she didn't know we were there
I don't think but like you know
everybody's talking to her and stuff
yeah but I think everybody's just there
for like everybody else you know what I
mean like as a support system that's
just kind of why you do it
yeah Victor said are they talking about
hospice that's usually the next step
make them come no he's in ICU he'll
he'll die there he there yeah my
grandmother was in ICU she had stomach
cancer and um they did move her to
hospice but I think she was only
there two
days I think cuz I was working and they
called me and they said you know oh
they're moving her to hospice and I was
like okay well I'm going to come there
in the morning and then when I got there
she was already in a coma and then like
she died later that night you know what
I mean so she wasn't there that long
same thing happened to your stepdad
yeah he was
um what did he have I can't remember
ALS he had ALS right and um yeah he died
poorly he did yeah he did um they took
him they eventually took him to hospice
but I think I don't even think he was in
there how how long was he in there a
couple a couple of days maybe 12 hours
he died there cuz I remember we went to
see him yeah but I think he died like
the next day yeah he was dying of being
paralyzed basically he couldn't even
take a breath they just had to intubate
him [__] they're blowing [__] yeah
air into his lungs he couldn't breathe
and he
fing faded away yeah I wasn't a fan of
him though that was the thing he he was
a real
dick uh he was I I will say that um I
know it's not cool to speak ill of the
dead but yeah that was a particular that
dude was a [__]
particular situation I was I was also
she knew him in that mother I was also
not a fan right I was not a fan you just
got to call it call it what it is you
know yeah I mean I'm just saying it's
like you know it sucks he died the way
he died but you know he he still wasn't
he wasn't a nice
person um yeah Jeffy art said dealt with
updates on loved ones a few times myself
it's never fun I'm so sorry guys yeah I
mean you know it'll be all right I've
only met your dad in in person one time
he came to visit us do you remember he
came to visit us several years ago for
Thanksgiving he came here for
Thanksgiving like several years ago and
had Thanksgiving with us who your dad
yeah yeah yeah long yeah was that was a
couple years yeah that's the only time
I've ever met him in person like I hear
him on the phone all the time like when
Tom talks to him on the phone like I can
hear him on the phone but that's the
only time I ever met him a
person yeah Victor said we can move
patient from ICU to hospice if that's
what the family wants Zan also says ALS
is a miserable way to go yeah and um
like I said I wasn't a fan of the dude
but um that is a shitty way to die yeah
it's a shitty way to
die when when I look back at his life
story though I kind of think
uh there was a certain amount of [__]
what do you call it karmic
[__] everybody gets that like that's
why I don't really believe in karma
because like some people that did
absolutely nothing wrong like die in
horrible [__] ways and um so I don't
think there's anybody watching out or
any kind of karma or anything which is a
shame there should be but I don't think
there is um but in his case I don't know
if I'd go that far um because like I
said that's a shitty way for anybody to
go I wouldn't really wish that on I'm
not going to say I wouldn't wish that on
anybody because there are couple people
I can think of I could wish it on but I
don't know if he was quite bad enough
but I didn't know him that long you knew
him a lot longer than me yeah so I don't
really know I grew up with that [__]
that's what I mean yeah I knew what he
was really like yeah like I said I
wasn't a fan all my step [__] I
wasn't a fan my step sisters and my
brother my step brother and [__] [__]
we didn't live together but I [__]
knew that whole [__] story yeah oh
that's right I remember you telling some
I remember you telling me some sh all
right Danny says I remember Tom talking
about the time his dad took him to see
the thing which is an awesome memory to
yeah yeah yeah didn't he take you to see
didn't he take you to see alien too
alien also but he me to see alien in
California he took me to see the thing
in Mississippi two or three times yeah
yeah so his dad took him to see the
thing and alien he got to see him in the
theater like with his dad which is
pretty
cool Tammy says uh they sent my mom home
from the nursing home the day after
Christmas said she was okay then her
home health aid found her dead in her
recliner Tuesday morning that's the
thing it's like they never know I guess
they try to do their best and [__] like
that
but that sucks man that
sucks and like I said we've been I've
been thinking about this for a while
because Tom was like especially since
Whenever However many years ago it was
that he went when he had the byass and
he was like I'm not sure if he's going
to pull out of this but he did and that
was I don't know three four years ago I
don't even remember now but um it was
still when we were at the old house so
it must have been more than three years
ago and um but all this time time we've
been kind of thinking you know he calls
him every now and like once a month or
something like that and he's like man
he's not doing too good and [__] so he's
getting to that age like I said he's not
really that I mean comparatively because
my mom
is um actually my mom will be 70 this
year but she's not I mean she seems in
Fairly good health
actually cuz my stepdad is um I believe
significantly older than she
is so we're going to play all this by
here yeah like I said that's all you can
do like I said um you're renting a car
you can just leave whenever you need to
leave you know what I mean it's just
kind of like he's saying toss drink one
for me stuck in Mississippi Man it says
I'm processing all this too look it yeah
it says I saw discrepancy out there
which blew my mind
but probably got to have Mississippi
license and medical recommendation I
don't know what he's talking about
what's this song I can't see that
dispensary dispensary dispensary yeah oh
he's talking about [__] um he's a
veteran so it's probably place where you
can [__] buy booze and [__] it's
probably what he's talking about oh okay
gotcha Dana said hey back in the old
days they did [__] like bloodletting try
and cure people and it made them worse
at least we live in modern times yeah
and that's the thing it's um yeah Z said
modern medicine can make a lot of the
death process more comfortable yeah like
I said at least that's what they did to
my Grandma it's like you know she didn't
seem to be in any particular pain or
anything like that so at least they
[__] do that for people not back in
the old days where it was like hey let's
pull his arms off maybe that will help
you know what I mean we're going to get
the demons out or whatever the [__] they
would do back then in the medieval times
so you know yeah Tammy said she's got to
drive to Pennsylvania on Sunday and
clean out uh her mom's apartment and
have her funeral
finalized yeah I me everybody's people's
dying that's what I mean like the older
you get like I said my grand my
grandmother just died um I went to her
funeral like whenever that was because I
think I talked about it on the show um
my uncle died I don't know if I brought
that up my uncle died of
Alzheimer's my you know my grandmother's
son my mom's brother um he died of Al
ERS um a few weeks back and then you
know I heard today that was I don't know
if my stepfather is doing all that well
but like I said he hasn't been doing
that well for a while he's got all kind
of problems he's also Southern so
yeah could be it's it's all this it's
all this lifestyle
man I don't know I want to live a long
time but I don't want to live a long
time if I'm
suffering I can totally see if you
have some [__] up disease or something
like that where you're just in pain all
the time you're just like [__] this man
you like you don't want to deal with it
you know yeah I can I can totally see
that I can totally see
that I'm showing my cousin streaming
right about now well
hey yeah live streaming we're kind of
drunk doing the show yeah kind of drunk
It's Friday night you know yeah what are
you going to
do but
yeah I do love that your dad took you to
see the thing and alien yeah I wish I
had seen those in the
theater I mean I was old enough to go to
the theater when those came out but I
didn't have anybody that would take me
to see them because obviously I was too
little to go like by myself
but I was excited that we on my birthday
a couple years ago
they did a um they did The Shining again
on the big screen and I was super
excited because I never got to see The
Shining on the big screen and we went
and it was a whole different experience
I was really jazzed about
that Timmy said yeah I lost my uncle in
2020 my grandmother in 2021 and two dogs
last year the hubs lost two uncles last
year and now my mom I can't take much
more yeah it's he wants to know where
we're streaming he's going to jump in
the my cousin's going to jump in the
[__] all right well let me run to the
backroom real
quick all this rum man it's going
through I'm G send him the [__] U
link oh
okay okay talk
yeah send my cousin a link my cousin
Scott he's another [__] exmilitary
badass he [__] had more combat
experience than I did with 101st and he
was in the [__]
Navy blows my [__]
mind he was doing [__] Patrols in
Afghanistan with a navy in an army unit
it's [__]
ridiculous
okay let me go over there
too
okay he's got the
link he'll be coming in in a
bit he said he's already there all right
already here yeah what's up
Scott should we talk about funner things
or uh no we're gonna talk about some
[__] okay because um just asking the
show here knows my dad
you know the whole story about the
chicken necks turkey necks turkey neck
excuse me Thomas you know about Clarice
across the street taking care of him
Clara's sister the black wi of our
family they know about taking care of
him yeah everybody here knows everything
they know every there is Scott car
what's up cuz yeah we're both X I was
just saying we're both [__] X1 but
you were in the Navy in the 101st and
and got some more [__] combat
experience than I got on the damn Patrol
in [__]
Afghanistan I told him everything man
told him about my time in
Brazil [__] they know me time in
Brazil time [__] as a state
department dependent the weird [__] that
happened after I got out [__] service
with [__] um that weird [__] bomb
unit [__] had uh told him about uh
[__]
uh the Nazis in Brazil that I [__]
saw uh what else still need to do show
about that
uh I told him in general pretty much
everything I told him about [__]
frost my two my two uncles on my
mother's side they were in Task Force
160 that are now
[__]
um they're now [__] those dudes are
in their 60s man they're jacked as [__]
and their bodyguards to [__] Saudi
royals bodyguards and helicopter Pilots
for the Saudi
royals told them all the [__] weird
[__] that our family was up to and then
we were just talking a minute ago about
the time my
dad took me to see the thing three
times in Laurel Mississippi that's a
great [__] movie that's why every
time he'd take me see it it must been
about 15 or 16 hour be scared as [__]
[__] driving back in the passenger
side of his [__]
truck scared as [__] of that [__]
thing with the [__] the head with all
the [__]
legs we have you got to be [__]
kidding me yeah you got to be [__]
kidding me yeah f as we've talked about
before I mean the thing is probably it's
easily in my top five favorite maybe my
top three actually definitely my top
three well and we've talked about this
before if the thing was a real monster
you would never be able to defeat that
monster that is easily the scariest
monster and I will fight people about
that yeah now my cousin
Scott maybe I'll show you the [__] uh
thing my cousin Scott's got a [__]
tattoo on his back a 2 M16 stuck in the
ground [__] combat boots I don't know
if that was from from some of his dead
buddies but he's got Army tattoos on his
back and he's the ex Navy guy got Navy
medals and army medals simultaneously
that was a weird time [__] Scott that
was a weird [__]
time weird times yeah what's Scott
saying went to Peru and seen Hitler look
alike bombing around Elvis in Vegas yeah
yeah yeah yeah I I believe it
okay going [__] get some Scott video
get some Scott photos are you allowed to
show that yeah I can show Scott photos
of course I can show well ask him first
no he don't care he's good man you gotta
watch man Scott's a man you got to watch
because he will send pictures of like
pictures of me people and I don't even
know that he sent them he's like yeah I
sent some like topess pictures of you or
like porn or something like that and I
was like uh okay yeah there's Scott's
care that much there's Scott's back with
the [__] soldiers in the M16s and
[__]
let hold
on D said Tom's out here doxing people
yeah pretty much as Scott's middle name
is my name he's got Ross in there Scott
Ross
Carpenter oh so it's not your actual
middle name did you ever tell anybody
where your middle name is no my middle
name is [__] Francis it's [__]
Francis [__] Francis that would be
better if it was actually and me and
Scott's granddad's name was biver so we
had French and Spanish names in our
family how cool would it be if your
middle name was Boliver Boliver yeah
bolivard or boulard boulard yeah it's
Francis though
yeah there's Scott Victor says what's
his social security number I [__] I
don't tell his fck social security
number I don't even know your social
secure anymore but no Scott I was
telling him how much you look like my
dad that you look more like my dad than
me yeah there's Scott well when I met
your dad I mean it's hard to tell
because he's you know a lot older he's
older now yeah so I saw some resemblance
but it wasn't like a huge resemblance
there's Scott as young
man right there beging the
day the cun side of the
family uh yeah Scott also said in Peru
there were not Nazi gift shops yeah Nazi
gift shops which you know yeah Brazil
[__] I didn't take pictures of that [__]
in Brazil they had Nazi [__] weed
dealers isn't there a whole I don't know
if this is still going on but somebody
please remind me because I thought that
I read something about how in Japan they
don't really have like a lot of cultural
context about the whole Hitler thing no
they like the na so so so yeah so
they'll just put like Hitler on stuff
and like Nazi [__] on things and be like
oh it's neat well they were Allied to
the well that's that's true too but it's
just kind of like it's funny how they're
just not like embarrassed about it at
all which I think they don't have the
same cultural context that's what I'm
saying so it's like they just think
that's I think that's kind of I was in
when I was when I was in
Korea I once mentioned the Nazis and to
one of those girls in the [__] tea
houses and [__] up Soul one of those
hookers I don't think no this one wasn't
a hooker I'm just it was a regular girl
I'm just
te and she goes and I was talking about
this concentration camps and she goes oh
yeah yeah yeah I see pictures of that
and he goes but the government did that
right I say yeah he goes well she goes
well because they were
bad and that's a very Eastern mentality
well if the government did it it was
because you're
bad you know it's very very conform
generally how it works yeah well in the
East if the government did it it's
because you're bad yeah so it's like
victim blaming that's nice well no it's
just that it's Father's know Father
Knows Best oh absolutely it's you know
very much father knows best I can't
government knows yeah government of
course knows best Oscar's here hey Oscar
what's go the thing creature Invincible
if it bleeds we can kill it says Dutch
yeah but that was predator and another
thing too is that even if you killed the
person or dog or whatever that the thing
was possessing at that time it could
possess more than one person at once and
then also it also inhabited whatever
came off of that like you know drops of
blood or whatever you would never be
able to contain that I just don't think
you would ever be able to contain that
if it was a real thing so I've always
maintained that the monster in the thing
was the scariest monster if it existed
in real life because you would not be
able to defeat it so I like that they
kind of approached that in the movie too
because they were thinking about hey if
this thing got out of this base like the
human race would be dead in you know X
months or whatever and that's probably
absolutely what would happen danis said
Hitler is kind of funny looking he is
very funny looking he is kind of funny
looking
yeah Scott says the thing would' be
[__] if it was real and the blob too
yeah the blob would also be bad
um I will I've I'm working on I know
Danny's been waiting for this because
I've been said I've been working on it
for but I am working on it it's just
taking a long time I'm doing a history
of horror movies I've been wanting to do
it for like a really long time so I'm
doing a history of horror movies like
video essay and I have it all recorded I
have everything like that I'm at the
when I'm in the video editing process
I'm at the end of the 1960s so that's
where I'm at as of today cuz I worked on
it like several hours today and I'm at
the end of the
1960s but in that when I get to the
1980s one of the things that I point out
is that in the 80s there were kind but
not a lot but there were like several um
50s remakes obviously you know like the
fly um you know David kernberg and Toby
Herbert and uh Invaders from Mars and
stuff like that um but also there was a
1988 remake of The Blob which I would
submit is one of the best remakes ever
that is like way better than the
original because the original was good
but it was kind of goofy it's kind of
funny Steve McQueen's in it he's a
teenager even though he's obviously like
[__] 30 or whatever and so that so it
was a little silly they didn't really
take it seriously the 1988 one they
absolutely took it seriously and they
made it super gory and it was like
really really good like it was still
kind of funny too like it had comedy in
it but I thought it was like a lot
better Scott you up in hi highberg at my
dad's house right
now look
um I got the message that you [__]
sent me I I understand
it he's probably going to
go it [__] busted me up when your dad
went man when uh [__] I loved your
dad man [__] we would [__] do all
[__] kinds of crazy [__] when you
were still a little [__] kid all
right his dad my
uncle
one time took me drinking with him I was
probably about 13 but this is this is
this is hey 13-year-old let's drinking
that's what happened back but this is
this is [__] this was [__]
Louisiana well I remember that not being
like that I grew up in Florida it wasn't
really that very early 80s late 70s he
took me to the bar and everything about
13 he was [__] there my uncle Wilson
Wilson was the [__] but then he gave up
drinking for a long
time and then how how he end what ended
up happen to him later on after he lost
his job he basically
basically basically killed himself I
[__] to this day man [__] we both
know all right we both know I'm sorry
that that [__] happened to you but
[__] I loved your dad man he was
[__] he was [__]
hilarious
um but now's my time he's probably G to
go but you know my dad you know how he
is he's not going to want us to [__]
wallow in that [__] [__] he's just going
to Valla he's a serviceman too and we're
going to see him on the other side of
the Nether world of the [__]
Force so uh if I come up
there um we're going to have a good time
all right just like just like in just
like in New Orleans we're going to have
like a wake we'll
party we'll see what we'll do we we'll
have
fun okay cuz uh my dad was upbeat and
he'd be like ah [__] it he's sick of the
[__] anyway I know how he is he's sick
of this
[__] he had his time he got sick I mean
I always like the idea of kind of just
making the best of it well your grandma
was the same way she was sick of the
[__] yeah well like I said she was in a
lot of pain yeah like I said she went in
there she was she was kind of cranky
about having to go do the surgery she's
like man [__] this [__] but they were
like okay we can do we can get it all
and then they didn't they did all that
and then they didn't get it all they're
like well we can do chemo and she is
like no yeah no I'll be like if it's
going to happen it's going to happen
I'll be up there Monday and if he goes
which it looks like he probably will
we'll settle the estate and close the
place out and [__] we'll handle it
yeah but like I said you just got to
make the best of it just got to play by
ear see what happen it's just I can't
yeah it's even a lot for Scott he's like
I'm not sure how to process what's going
to happen next but it's [__] up it's
like I just I had a hard time like I
went to my grandmother's funeral very
recently and you know she was in her 90s
so she lived like a really long time but
she was like um in really good pretty
like pretty good health until up until
you know right before she died um and
everybody was there it was like there
was family members I hadn't seen for
like forever and it was crazy but she
had a very traditional like Church
funeral yeah so everyone was crying and
it was just kind of like I don't really
like funerals like that like but I mean
they did try to keep stuff upbeat though
Scott's replying to me
where are we looking at oh started up
there yeah if anyone could run run on
stubborn it'd be uncle Tommy yeah that's
my dad um Dave EG yoke Wilson was wild
you probably know who you're talking
about Wilson was his death okay got baby
memories being in the bar yeah yeah with
Wilson yeah that's it wasn't a baby but
yeah well you know yeah that was new or
that was [__] New Orleans area
[__] where was that mety it was where
you live now or where you used to live
with your family [__] the bar up the
street there [__] it was [__]
funny as [__] and we were driving the
brown
bomber that [__] car that I rode to
the de rode to death one time in the 90s
burned that [__] up it died
right in my dad's [__] [__]
driveway as I came back from the French
Quarter drove it all the way back from
the French Quarter the [__] engine
just seizing it seized as I went into
the damn driveway that was it that was
the end of that car well that's at least
home that was your mom's friend's car
she gave to uh my grandma little mom
gave her that car ugly as [__] brown
car of all times it was just a [__]
pile of [__] mildew what it looked
like now what he saying so not as bad as
my car then oh no much worse much worse
so why you always bitching about my car
then oh no that car was matte Brown I
know my car is not pretty either but it
was matte brown mold colored okay with a
[__] ripped up red interior it was
old when they got it
okay cuz Tom's always bitching about my
car what else you say um legit drank
himself to death knowing he was allergic
yeah that's his dad Wilson drank him
okay he's gonna he's going to bring it
out say my my uncle Wilson lost his job
he was through he wanted out of the [__]
the world had changed he didn't like how
it was going drank himself to
death went to the hospital SE several
times and say you don't stop drinking
you're going to [__] kill
yourself it was [__]
suicide yeah killed himself by drinking
I've never seen anybody do it about do
that but that was just something your
dad man he came up with that I guess
other guys have done it well they made a
whole movie about that called Leaving
Las Leaving Las Vegas yeah with Nicholas
G yeah but that was later he did that
cuz he figured y'all were already grown
all the kids were grown and you guys
were doing good so he felt useless I
guess which uh your mom fought as hard
as she could get him snap out out of it
but I feel like and we've talked about
this before I feel like that's almost I
don't want to say endemic even though I
just did yeah um to Men of that
generation when the job's gone you're
gone yeah which is crazy to me he had
that job that Refinery for a long
time yeah and it's like they retire and
then it's like a few years L he got
fired for [__] telling dirty jokes
that I thought were funny as [__] me his
dad was funny as [__] yeah but still
like in work and he would tell all kinds
of [__] naughty ass jokes and he told
some naughty ass joke and put it out
over the [__] little internet thing
that they had at the work and [__]
somebody complained and got his ass
fired or early retirement type of deal
you got to take your retirement and uh
busted him up and he said [__] it I I
don't want to be here
anymore damn I was shook by that when
that happened Scott I loved your dad man
he was [__] hilarious how old was he
not old old 60s probably oh that's not
old yeah I think how old I would have
thought it was old when I was younger
but now that I'm in my 6 it's late 60s
maybe it's not old at all
no yeah Scott said he'd take me to the
bar on the Honda trail bike yeah take
yeah yeah yeah yeah he was uh an
alcoholic but he mostly Managed IT there
were times where he'd relapse but it
didn't matter to me I knew what I was
dealing with he was [__] funny as
[__] and he he was a good dude real good
real good
dude he was not a uh an
evil drunk or anything like that he was
he was funny funny funny guy that's
always the best kind of drunk yeah yeah
he was
fun uh the tray me Twitch says sorry for
your loss good sir I lost my dad 10
years ago this coming September and I
loved him very much I'll be 50 this year
and he only lived to 66 okay yeah I mean
your dad in his 70s you 75 he's 75 75
and I'm 55 54 54 you yeah yeah like I
said my mom is going to be 70 in a
couple weeks actually Scott we got to
hit those [__] casinos man we got to
hit the [__] Casino
um we got to hit that casino buffet on
our way out of that [__] Tom just wants
to eat I want to eat I want to go to
haris man or that a [__] pirate
pirate we eat a buffets down here too I
haven't eaten down there in a long time
man the [__] we eat at the Chinese
buffet Chinese pretty much every
weekend Tom loves his buffets I love
Buffet well you can tear the [__] out
you can eat a lot more than I can so
it's when I concentrate it's more it's
more um yeah it makes more financial
sense for you it's like I feel kind of
bad because it's just I mean they're not
horribly expensive what is what is ichon
is what like 16 bucks a person or
something yeah like plus tax and drinks
and stuff he's talking more about his
dad
his eyes his eyes were wide open oh yeah
like he knew what what was uh yeah that
was sad but he uh was eyes wide open
with the decision yeah like he knew he
he knew he was drinking himself to death
it's like yeah they fired his ass over
dumb [__] yeah it was dumb [__] yeah got
him canned because of an intern got what
canned because of an intern an intern
[__] complainant yeah Zach says my
mom had COPD the last couple years and
it's now terminal for us the worst part
is how bad the drugs hospice has are on
uh and the lack of sleep was screwing
with her head very little she says
lately makes sense and that's on top of
her already having a pretty high
maintenance personality in general yeah
yeah it's I mean everybody deals with it
though it's
like I'm you know I get upset about it
when I think about my parents cuz both
of my parents are still alive um you
know all of my grandparents are dead now
yeah but um all the mine are dead too
but all of my but my parents are still
alive yeah and when I think about them I
don't see see them that often but when I
think about them dying it's just kind of
like I don't know it's it's really
upsetting but I don't see them that
often so it's just kind of like I don't
know it's it's a weird yeah but I but
then on the other hand I'm just like
well everybody goes through this it's
just kind of like the natural order of
things
yeah the older die off and then it's
handed down to the younger
Generations well Scott me and you still
got our moms and then when they go it's
on a
[__] me you Katherine
Casey and then all your
children um and then me and
Jen uh but you know we're the end of the
line over here because we're not going
to have children too late we only have
fur babies yeah just just
cats and uh but [__] Casey had what two
or
three Casey is his sister my other
cousin she's all all I was showed showed
Catherine to everybody yeah you got cute
sisters and we had a goodlook family and
it's just kind of going down on your
side where it's going to end out it's
going to end but that's all good things
come to an end you know but all bad
things come to an end yeah bad things
come to end it's all kind of it's all
good yeah Scott said sorry for hauling
y'all's live down no no no it's like we
talk about this [__] all the time this
is an open this open lines Friday yeah
Friday night Sidetrack show we just talk
about whatever like comes up um there's
no talk I or anything um yeah Scott says
also no children for me not a breeder
yeah me neither yeah um once you bend
through certain things man it doesn't
quite have the same there's a certain
window you got to
hit 20s that's when you're supposed to
have them and honestly like I then you
get too smart you don't want well no
it's like when I was a teenager I
remember telling my mom when I was 14 15
you know I don't really think I'm going
to have kids like I said I grew up
around a lot of kids I have three
younger siblings my parents are in a
daycare I have like a [__] ton of I
don't even remember how many cousins I
have 20 something cousins I have a lot
of cousins because my mom has seven
brothers and sisters and so they all had
kids so I was surrounded by children my
whole entire life and I was like you
know what I I just don't think this is
for me so I told my mom that when I was
young like too young to be even dating
or anything I was like you know what I
don't think I'm ever going to have oh
you'll change your mind you'll change
your mind my mom says I never did though
never did I thought about it um cuz I
was married before when I was really
young I got married when I was
22 and I was married for 14 years we
talked about it initially but neither of
us was really that gung-ho about it and
I figure if you're not real gung-ho
about it then probably you shouldn't cuz
I kind of feel like people that really
want kids yeah let's have some kids it's
like yeah y'all should have kids if
you're just kind of like well I don't
know probably you shouldn't probably you
shouldn't because you can't take it back
you know what I mean and that's what I
was thinking it's like man what if I
don't what if I do it and I don't like
it I can't take it back I got to raise
this [__] now you know what I mean so
it's just kind of like I was I I just
never really liked the idea so I I just
never got around to like I said I was
married for 14 years we never had any
kids and I just really never had any
desire to thankfully um I have a brother
who's four years younger than me and he
has a couple kids well he has his wife
had two girls from a prior relationship
and then they had two boys but my other
two
siblings
I they they seem as uninterested as I do
in having children both of them my
sister is in a long-term relationship my
brother is married my youngest brother
he was born in ' 86 and um he might have
kids with his wife but they really don't
seem all that interested in it it just
wasn't something I was into I was into
doing other [__] you know they take up
too much of your time I get like some
people like that but I I don't really
like
that Victor says Tom and Jenny could
always adopt an older kid like 10 12
years old right I want to do that but
not now yeah it's like I don't know man
because I'm just kind of
like man we have like we have three cats
and plent and that seems like yeah
that's that's about the limit of of the
[__] that I want to put up with you know
what I mean they're fairly easy to deal
with they're kind of a pain in the ass
but you know I love them and stuff like
that but it's like a a human child no
thanks and honestly I think that I would
I don't know do you think I would [__] a
kid up no you don't think I would [__] a
kid up just just that you know I always
felt like I would [__] a kid up well
obvious I can't have kids now obviously
because I'm too old but you know what I
mean that's really something you should
do in your 20s
when you still have energy yeah when you
have
energy when you still have energy but
the way way they have engineered [__]
life in the United States like when your
20s [__] are partying they're
not having kids so that's the problem it
is much more fun to party than have kids
yeah it's
fun well we still have party we still
party we party [__] we're still we're
old we're still [__] party yeah and
it is much more fun than having children
I will
submit you know
yep yes Scott says we got two indoor
cats and one is diabetic that's enough
stress for me yeah
exactly Scott send me a uh picture in
messenger of uh those Black and Whites
of uh my dad and your granddad side by
side in their [__] sailor outfits you
got that you got that
picture I'm looking for it right now I I
thought I had it in a conversation
somewhere I'm looking for it I want to
show the audience the [__]
resemblance in a lot of ways you were
more like my dad and I was more like my
granddad from According to the
stories did you know your granddad never
met him he was dead yeah I thought you
was dead before my dad was an adult
heart problems just like you know but
like I said it was that southern diet
now see my I knew both of my
grandparents both my grandads
now my granddad on my dad's side very
much Southern diet now he died in
1991 MH so I was just out of high school
when he
died I can't remember when my mom's dad
died she found him though he died from a
brain aneurysm did he say he had it wait
a
minute
uh yes I'm going to need to dip don't
know where that's at let me look on
Uncle Tom sh yeah
yeah you posted a couple black and white
of
that trying to find what's everybody
saying DVD Dragon says we already have
plenty of people here most of them we
don't like what like as far as like
reproducing oh like I get why people
want to have kids but I just I don't
know I just never had
that um Instinct I just never had that I
actually look that's why I don't even
want to call it an instinct because not
everybody has it because I certainly
don't the overpopulation thing actually
uh is a myth if you [__] listen in
terms of Elon Musk he's right about that
there's a book that I read and Jenny
read it a long time ago called the
Lucifer principle in order to keep a
civilization going you have to have a
certain breeding
population and [__] once it goes
underneath a certain rate the the
civilization falls apart and the because
there's no
replacement and the uh the replacement
has to be a certain kind you can't just
have a generic person make the
replacement and the example that was
used in that book and that was an what
was it name guy's name was Bloom wasn't
it Harold Bloom Harold Bloom I have that
book somewhere yeah it's a great book
it's over there I think it's over there
on it's called the Lucifer principle
written back in the 90s yeah it was a
long time ago yeah and um the example
that he given was he gave was the Mayans
Mayans and [__] uh the Mayan
civilization in Central and South
America they didn't have the
technology to keep the population very
high because they didn't know about uh
how to fertilize
land and uh the population would get to
a certain level they couldn't feed
everybody and it would
collapse it would collapse into [__]
cannibalism and
starvation but now we're in the we're
now in a [__] sit situation it's even
worse where the population excuse me the
te the techn te olog is making the
population obsolete which would cause a
[__] fertility crash which it would
never which a civilization would never
recover from so then what ends up
happening is there not enough people to
run a high-tech civilization goes back
to Stone Age I totally believe it he
showed the [__] and I was like yeah
that's that's probably
it okay here you go I found a
pictures that's my
granddad that's my grand in a way that
kind of looks like both me and Scott
look at that swab [__] yeah yeah
you showed me that the yeah oh [__] oh
man it went down to the bottom oh Tom
[__] it up yeah I was trying to go to
show pictures of my dad how close they
were he had some pictures up him side by
side are you too in I'm too I'm too
inebriated it don't matter are you too
inebriated he sent the photos to make me
another drink or no yeah I can make
it okay this is the I love me wall of
the [__] entire family service I'm in
it [__] Scott's in it all our
ancestors are in it flags and [__] yeah
where is that
Scott I've never seen that one the huge
I love me
wall
yeah I do not have any pictures of
myself on the wall
yeah I mostly have horror movie posters
all right I'll make another
drink Scott says that's in the living
room it's in the living room of what my
dad's house or his house our military
Heritage shelf I'm assuming he me your
dad's house okay probably yeah all
right Tammy says we can adopt her she's
older yeah I mean you're old you're
you're kind of like old enough to like
you know do your own thing and like
provide money and stuff like that see
that's the kind of that's the kind of
child I would like to adopt the child
that is old enough to have a job they
could like provide some
income that would be awesome I don't
want these
little these little
parasites that just take all your money
and don't really contribute anything you
know what I mean like I
said I'd rather I'd rather the cats
honestly I can't
imagine I don't know like that like I
said the cats are so stressful that
they're not stressful
but there's a lot they need a lot of
attention and
so I can't imagine like having [__]
humans human children I I would just not
be able to deal with
that yeah Scott says damn crumb
snatchers yeah that's what I always
thought I mean you
know it's weird because like I said my
mom kept telling me because I told her
when I was a teenager I'm like I don't
I'm not going to do that she's like oh
you'll change your mind but I never did
my mom loves kids she loves kids she had
four like I I have three siblings she
had me when she was
18 and um so not only did she have four
kids of her own but she also babysat
everyone else's kids and she ran a
daycare for many many years she just
loves children and I was like whatever
that Jean is I did not get that that's
for sure I did not get that Jean and I
told her that I was like I'm pretty sure
I didn't get that you know what I mean
like I said I never changed my mind I
thought about it a couple times but I
was always ambivalent and then I thought
to myself if I'm ambivalent then that
means I shouldn't because I can't take
it back that is a big decision and I
don't want to and I would never want to
like because that's another human I
would never want to bring another person
into the world that I was ambivalent
about you know what I mean that's that
would be bad I don't I don't want to do
that to another person so since I knew
that I was ambivalent about it I was
just like I don't think that's a good
idea
Tammy says well I'm an orphan now she
was trying to get us to adopt her yeah I
said something right but she could like
I said at least she could have like a
job and she could bring in like like I
said that's the best kind of
adopti because they can like actually
provide some Financial yeah you come in
here we'll adopt you and you help pay
some bills
around right that's the best
kind Tammy says LOL older than Tom yeah
she's older than you are yeah she's
older than me [__] adopt her as my
daughter or we're going to adopt you as
girlfriend we haven't really seen you
you haven't passed the girlfriend
[__] test
yet is there a test there might be a
test oh Tom's like it's up to J it's up
to J oh it's ultimately up it's up it's
Tim me after to
gym Tom's kind of hoping that I'm gonna
find some find some [__] this funny like
all right fing foot it so um yeah all
right Scott
yeah how do I Scott says how do I get in
on this adoption racket they pay bills
ad that's what I mean it's like like
let's adopt some people that like
actually have like careers y got to pay
bills yeah right so uh Scott how's Texas
man I know Scott moved to I think Scott
moved to
Texas uh and um cat's in Texas too isn't
she the Republic of Texas the Free
Republic of
Texas
Zach says I'm also worried uh for my dad
they've been together him and uh the dad
and the mom have been together for
almost 30 years and I'm worried about
what he's going to do once mom's gone
because his mom is not doing too good
yeah um oh Scott is in California I
didn't know you were in California what
part of California you in
man that's the thing I've kind of
noticed yeah she went from California
all the way to Mississippi the [__]
is I thought you were in Texas that's
far okay Casey's and C is in Texas okay
okay San Diego he said San Diego yeah
you're over there with my aunt [__]
Lois yeah state after the Navy that's
right after the Navy stayed there yeah
okay I have noticed that same my dad did
for a while yeah yeah I have noticed
that couples that have been married for
a long time they've been together a long
time
um I I hate to say but in general this
is a generalization but I have seen that
if the wife dies before the husband um
the husband usually doesn't do all that
well yeah and usually dies like a few
but if the husband dies first wife
usually does okay yeah um you know for a
while like she'll live alone or you know
find somebody else or whatever but it's
just kind of like the dudes tend not to
do so well but it depends on the person
yeah tell me how San Diego is man
[__] San Diego was great in the 70s I
[__] loved
it me and Lois Wesley [__] R and [__]
later on he wrote a whole book about
that [__] with the
Poltergeist Scott [__] probably has
heard about the Poltergeist but I don't
think he knows all the [__] details
of it up there at Mammoth Mountain oh we
wrote a whole he was a little kid when
that was going on wrote a whole book
about it that was some weird [__] Scott
you would have loved it paranormal [__]
and it still happens from time to still
happens in here every now and then yeah
I do weird [__] Tom does weird
paranormal [__] yeah make the alarms go
off and [__] yeah you've been making
like the [__] firearm alarm go or the
smoke alarm go off yeah the last couple
I think cuz you've been stressed out
yeah stressed out the alarm it doesn't
like go off for hours and hours but
it'll just it'll go off and then the in
the bedroom and then it'll go off in the
hall and then it'll
stop but he said he [__] wish I was
in Texas too many [__] out on
the Left Coast
okay we can just move man look you would
[__] love Florida if you like if you
like the good parts of San Diego oceans
side around that area you would love
[__] Florida cuz man it reminds me so
much of [__] that area back in the
70s and the early 80s when when when
um San Diego and Oceanside were [__]
really cool kind of feels like that over
here it it's it's I love
Florida I would have really only live in
Florida or Texas right
now based on what I'm seeing Mississippi
you know great too it's [__] boring
man there's and there's really no work
there it'd be a good place to retire man
on on [__] [__] but there's just
nothing to do
there yeah I'm not really into that
living in the middle of nowhere yeah
there's nothing to do there I need some
[__] nightclubs and like some [__] to
do you know yeah the only thing in
Mississippi's cool is on the [__]
Coast buuy Gulfport that area Pass
Christian they pretty nice
there Tammy says if we adop ad her she
also has two cats two dogs and a husband
okay that what we do with the
husband what we do with that four
something start swapping I'm I'm just
throwing [__] out there I don't really
know that might be kind of weird yeah
Tammy say she's 55 so she's a little bit
older than anymore yeah but not by
much yeah Zach says my dad is 63 so
isn't that old but I'm still worrying
yeah I mean 63 is yeah like I said it
would have seemed old to me a long time
ago but now it uh you know yeah that's
only uh 12 years away from me so Scott
the Hurricanes ain't [__] man he's like
[__] [__] the
Hurricanes you're rare to actually get
any hurricane damage just kind of we for
it to happen I mean it it is a risk it
does happen but yeah not that much more
than Mississippi or anywhere else the
worst that I've ever and I've lived here
most of my life I was born
here um we went through a few I think
there was kind of a bad one in 79 but we
didn't have any damage the worst [__]
that we went through I think was what
year was that I want to say it was 2004
but maybe it was later than that we did
actually have four
hurricanes hurricanes tropical storms in
a 6 week period but the worst that
happened in my
neighborhood was it blew my all my
fences down it tore some [__] off my
roof and the power was out for about two
weeks yeah and oh and my street flooded
Scott says it's twice the income yeah
twice the income but it's [__] three
times the [__]
bills it all kind of evens out that's
the thing like Florida it's it's cheap
to live here but if you have to work
here they don't pay you anything yeah
you know what I mean so kind if you have
a job that's like remote from like a
place that pays better yeah then you can
probably get more for your money here
but if you have to work here then it's
still kind of a struggle because they
don't pay that much yeah it's like that
with everywhere though yeah that's what
I'm saying you're struggling in wherever
you go if you're working local because
it adjusts to the local economy you
could go to Boston which is a rich city
and still struggle they pay more but
everything costs more so it all just
kind of yeah cancels out what you want
is you want to be in Florida where the
[__] prices are lower but you want to
work remotely for like say like a New
York company that pays you New York
prices that works out
that's kind of what I'm trying to do at
the moment like I'm trying to like find
freelance stuff that like I have a
freelance client that's in Connecticut
um that pays more but you know what I
mean in Florida people they don't they
don't really want to pay anything like I
see jobs here like
locally they want somebody that has like
10 20 years experience and that is like
oh we'll pay you $6 an hour yeah I'm
like
bro no one can live on that sorry
um you know what I mean but they're
still trying to like get away with that
stuff Scott if I was going to live in
California man it' be Northern
California or out there somewhere like
[__] um in the
woods up and around [__] yosity
Sequoia I love that those areas but I'd
be a mountain man up there or a [__]
park ranger he's going to grow he's
going to look like [__] Grizzly Adams
Grizzly Adams be huging bears with a big
ass beard I'd be [__] playing [__]
guitar [__] singing [__] Rocky
Mountain High [__] John Denver John
Denver [__] hanging out with the beer
with the Bears and [__] but just don't
get eaten like
Grizzly you know how that I would
imagine X mil exmilitary guys would have
a easy a much easier shot at becoming
[__] Park
Rangers well yeah yeah I would think so
you probably get preference her
treatment yeah yeah I'm kind of old for
that [__] it I'm going to stay here in
Florida in the [__] swamps
man I got this with me a I got this with
me you know know you love me yeah of
course married you
[__] that's nice you're such a smooth
chocolate that's [__] yeah [__]
sweet as [__] man [__] sweet that's
about as sweet as you
get I don't lie to them like I say all
kinds of sweet I say all kinds of sweet
[__] she goes a yeah yeah he just
doesn't depends on when it when it just
he's got a rep to protect it comes over
me sometimes as they say so you know I
love you yeah he does I had to wait a
long time before you marri me though see
you looking so beautiful yeah roll
over yeah that's about how that goes
that's why he says that no it's not
true it's just that it comes over me I'm
like you did make me wait a long time
I'm going to say that though what's that
me you didn't make me wait a long time
to get married Yeah well yeah well we
were we were friends you know the [__]
went on for [__] 12 years
yeah we were married during that time I
just I mean basically we just acted like
we were it just wasn't legal we've been
we've been together it just kind of
surprised me because when you first
brought it
up uh last that was three years ago
September no two or three years
ago you've only mentioned it a couple of
times yeah and you poo pooed that [__]
you guess you were in a bad mood or
something okay hang going marry you then
I don't see I don't remember that yeah
you must have come at it so she must be
getting ready to split so I was thinking
nah we weren't going anywhere though CU
I just said [__] it we're going have to
get married because [__] come on
we're we're not going to break up let
stop [__] playing games we're old we
yeah we're old now we're W we've been
looking after each other for [__] 13
years we're not going anywhere pretty
much yeah so you know it did surprise me
though when you brought it up we were
sitting in books a million yeah at the
coffee shop
yeah and he just brought it up out of
nowhere so we're going to get married
and I thought you were kidding no
that's I thought you were kidding that's
just [__] [__] on paper that they
know what I mean that's just paperwork
we already were
married it happened naturally I mean
yeah it happened naturally we [__]
years kept flying
by yeah you know what I mean and I'm
like we're [__] married we've been
married we've been married for at least
8 years years I mean yeah probably yeah
eight nine years yeah it was just
hilarious to me that when I posted the
picture like we just went to the you
know uh what county do we live in Lake
County yeah like the courthouse yeah and
like they take little pictures of you in
front of their little or whatever and so
we went down there and they took
pictures on my phone and stuff and I
posted them on Facebook I'm like hey we
finally did the thing and like a a whole
bunch of our friends were like finally
yeah what the [__]
what the hell why did it take you guys
so long terara was like come on
really did she really I don't think she
commented on that post but you said that
she sent you a message come on really
yeah Tera was holding out for me a she
thought you were kidding I guess she
thought I was kidding said yeah we've
been together for 13 years I mean that's
I heard of her broke her heart a she's
got a boyfriend she's got a boyfriend
yeah I know but that but I've known
terara for long long time too look for
y'all out there in the audience no no
terara isn't listening Tara didn't have
a chance and I'd tell terara that ter
face say no crazy Tara hopefully she's I
like terara but you know no no I like
her too yeah she's nice but [__] if
there was if there was an opportunity
there that [__] would happen a long time
ago you crazy
Tera well I remember back in the day
yeah um when we were either like before
we were going out or like you know right
around the time we were first going out
yeah um I remember her telling she was
trying to [__] sew some bad [__]
seeds everywhere try cuz she was trying
to [__] get with me she was trying it
was a long time ago a long time ago yeah
she wanted all women to stay away from
me cuz she had me [__] marked yeah
terara loved me didn't she tell Paul
vain some [__] oh she just do anything
to [__] get me isolated me she was
fighting and fighting to get me yeah
yeah that was a long time terara didn't
have a chance no
but you
know yeah a lot of a lot she subtly
subtly fought [__] Sonia oh yeah too
over all that [__] that was before also
before I knew you what's what's going on
with her nowadays Sonia messaged me
when probably about four or five weeks
ago really yeah out of the blue let me
see did you tell me
that uh I thought I did maybe you did
and I don't remember I me something I me
something said she she posted a new a
photo of herself she had blond hair I
remember you saying blond hair said you
look I said I said said you look good
Sonia and she goes only good I said you
look great she goes thank you [__]
you know fing I'm not fishing for
compliments or for oh my God I would
never yeah and I said so you're talking
to me so now you're talking to me
[__] she said it something sideways
kind of well you know oh see I didn't
know about any of this I knew about that
first part like cuz I saw the picture
you show yeah she goes so now you want
to talk and she said like one I was like
wow I didn't like recognize her cuz she
she [__] then she vanished again oh
okay yeah if you got it's a long story
if you haven't been a long follower of
the show well maybe some people have not
been here for a long time well tell you
can tell well where do you want me to
start that's a whole that's a whole pan
of worms I'mma show you I'm G show her
DVD Dragon says 12 years in the friend
zone of police action where you never
declared war just kidding
I
mean here's the thing
when before me and Tom were going out
when we were just like hanging out yeah
and when we were first going out um I'm
not trying to like inflate his ego or
anything like that I'm just telling you
how it was there was a lot of chicks
gunning for his ass yeah but like
obviously yeah you know what I mean and
nobody got shy with me yeah um cuz
here's the thing I'm a nice person and I
think that that probably helped me
because like nobody cuz if I was a [__]
I think everybody would have been all up
in the [__] you know what I mean oh my
God that [__] blah blah blah but I'm a
nice person and I think a lot of people
felt bad this is who she's talking about
yeah yeah yeah that's Sona so nobody
came at me some people came at me
sideways like they would tell him [__]
about me like without me knowing about
it like they would do that kind of crap
like they would be underhanded but a lot
of people were gunning for him at the
time yeah so there was
that I son I like Sonia Sonia was a
friend of ours I like Sonia and
uh we hung out together we have a
complicated relationship yeah it was I
hav't talked I haven't talked her in a
long time though yeah we have a
complicated
relationship we kind of had a in a weird
triangle kind of going on for a while it
yeah it was it was and Sonia liked Jen
and Jen likes Sonia and I like Sonia she
was a friend of our but Sonia [__]
was the kind of chick that constantly
had to be on top of everything and she
wanted to be number one and she [__]
was very kind of like she's very catty
very catty and she would constantly do
things like try to be Jen's
friend and and then say sideway slightly
sideways [__] about me behind the back
yeah yeah or some in front of her face
yeah she would do that too yeah but then
she'd back off of it so I could never
entirely yeah she's not like she wasn't
like the kind of friend that like some
other female friends that I have where
you know where I could say anything and
I know they wouldn't [__] me over I
would never entirely trust her 100% And
I knew Sonia before I new Jen yeah you
did you've known her for a long time and
um me and Sonia were buddies we were not
[__] buddies but we were buddies um
Sonia didn't want me going out with her
for because that would take away from
her [__] FaceTime I guess even though
she wasn't even [__] you she wasn't
she wanted weren dating no we were
buddies she was trying to get it yeah
but she was trying to play very hard to
get but I didn't I didn't play those
kind of games you know how I was I know
I I you're just like yeah I see what
you're doing she yeah yeah you know so
she was trying to get me the pr
but I don't play
that and Tom does not need to pursue no
I would came from a background of
Plenty you know like the Cornucopia
imagine the Cornucopia but it's filled
with hot girls you're right that's what
Tom had yeah so he's not impressed and I
liked I liked women had to have physical
Beauty but that really wasn't enough you
had to be really cool Jen and [__]
Sonia were cool but out of the two
[__]
Jen 100% Sonia had [__] issues I
liked her she was funny but she is very
funny super funny she's fun to hang out
with yeah yeah she's she's a riot
hilarious she's a
riot y'all dudes know what I'm talking
about okay f y
know Sonia wasn't wifey
material no Jen
was Jen is with you through thick or
thin at least with me you know what I
mean and and uh there was no real games
with Jen no I don't do that it was just
me and Jen just talking like we're
[__] dudes almost Jen is very kind of
like dude like Sonia was like chick like
but like in a caty kind of negative bad
way yeah in a way that I don't really
like I don't like chicks like that
either right but in a weird way that was
her act yeah that was her act she was
trying to be like
that I like some though son son Sonia
did like you just the Sonia wanted to
[__] be above you yeah I know and I
really she didn't really deserve
it just like so [__] I've dealt with
people like that yeah yeah yeah I don't
I have a hard time I have a hard time
dealing with anybody that has any kind
of um anybody that's not like genuine
yeah you know what I mean anybody that
has any kind of like facade or anybody
that like I have a hard time I don't
really like dealing with anybody that's
trying to pull something off or be
something that they're not or just be
real just be normal it's just kind of
like I don't understand why you can't
just be that um you know even if you're
dorky or just be that it's like I like
that a lot better than trying to be
something that you're not and look me
and Jen are not talking [__] about Sonia
Sonia's a [__] great she's funny yeah
we like her we still like I haven't
talked to her in a long time but I you
know it's just uh she was a [__] half
full and she knows she was a [__]
handful well that was kind of her whole
thing that was her [__] thing that
was her whole thing she was very much
kind of like the local version of
[__] Sher
Bono and she knew that she did a kill
her [__] sh she could impersonate
Shar it was so good it's so good like
you were watching we used to get her to
do it at I bar something share do share
do share and she would do share it was
so good it was so entertaining it was so
good I wish we had video of it yeah I
don't think we do though but it was
really good yeah she was exactly like
her exactly yeah
[__] Scott's going ha
Bazinga oh my God legit I'm too lazy to
I don't know what he's talking about I'm
too lazy to be anything but genuine yeah
don't have the memory to keep up his
yeah exactly it's too much work why
would you do that you say he's been with
his old L 12 years now yeah yeah yeah we
met in well we met I think in
2009 or 2010 I was still married when we
met yeah to my first husband I didn't
though yeah I well that's how that's how
my ex-husband uh spun it but that's not
really what happened no that's not what
happened we just met we were friends but
we weren't hanging out all the time and
then they Ian I admit that I I mean me
and my husband were kind of on the outs
at the time and when I met you cuz I had
noticed you before cuz I'm like that D
seems pretty cool and stuff like that
and then like I met you and then I
really really liked you and then I think
that
accelerated the break up the breakup but
but we were breaking up anyway yeah but
then me and Jen were like friends for
like a couple years we were da for like
a year and a half yeah we were like
dating other people yeah like I went out
with a couple other dudes you went out
with a couple chicks yeah and it was
Sonia was saying do not go out with her
that was Sonia yeah do not go out with
her she's just gone through a
breakup let her go [__] let her
experience of the guys she's my
ex-husband as well yeah she's like she's
just infatuated with you as she said let
you know
[__] she's not at your level that was
such a weird [__] that she would say too
she would play all kinds of [__]
crazy [__] and then um and here's the
thing [__] in a way me and me and Jen
and Son were dating each other for a
little while we did have a little weird
we had some things going three them
going on for a while yeah
but but she ended up going back to her
husband yeah well they have a kid yeah
and that [__] was going to be a disaster
because the way [__] Sonia was is
that she would eventually [__] xgen
out she would try to xgen out that's
kind of what I and out of the two
[__] of course [__] Jen three
times over but you know only three times
three times four times three times over
yeah you were trustworthy she wasn't she
was flaky cuz like I said I liked her
but she was flaky yeah that's what I
mean it's just kind of like she's kind
of one of those people that it's like
you're friends with them and stuff like
that but it's like you're not going to
like lend them your wallet yeah or
anything well you know what I mean it's
just kind of thing she was
uh like you I I would trust you with
pretty much anything yeah I can't I mean
I could not I could be wrong and I don't
think I am but I do not think that you
would ever [__] me over and I would and
I would never [__] you over I
just it would have already happened do
that it would have already happened the
thing the thing with Sonia is that she
was uh she was cool very she was very
cool very lot a lot of fun and she was a
good
person uh
but she had a huge ego okay and
um she'd hurt a [__] to get in charge
just some [__] and part of the reason
why [__] Sonia
[__] wanted me was because of you
yeah if you weren't there she wouldn't
have been fighting for me yeah yeah so
that's part of it it's competition
competition some competition came up for
your attention kind of like Sarah oh God
Sarah did the same thing that was
another crazy [__] she was Furious
Scott know that no Scott doesn't know
her oh that's a great Sarah was chick
that moved off to Germany she's back
now I keep expect her and Sarah be
fighting on the [__] stage and [__]
hey I didn't start that okay I didn't
start that yeah Sarah so Sarah called me
on the phone when I was with her [__]
she was Furious that I was with her and
I wasn't dating Sarah Sarah wasn't my
girlfriend she she was just pissed that
I had chosen Jen over over her she
couldn't fathom she couldn't fathom
that's how arrogant she was she was cute
but she wasn't that cute the [__] are
you talking about like I said I will
never [__] on her to the extent that I'm
never going to I would never do that to
a woman where it's just kind of like oh
cuz she pissed me off like oh that ugly
[__] or what she's not ugly she's
beautiful she was cute she's beautiful
she was cute in those days yeah but yeah
tall thin woo nuts nuts here's another
thing got people saying that those you
know women will never date a guy shorter
[__] Sarah was probably about 5' n
I'm [__] 5'
6 and [__] yeah honestly you have you
have never had a problem no with anyone
no matter of fact the taller they are
the easier they are for me to get if
they're about six or over six foot Tom
has dated some very very tall women yeah
it's because a six foot woman doesn't
have a man to match her [__] most
dudes run from her well yeah I'll dive
right into it back in the day I don't
give a [__] like a big game hunter I'm
like no you're tall I love you though
babe you you're cute you know I was
doing that back in high school [__]
yeah they got big old feet like mansiz
feet you know like that's a big
foot
but it looks it it's not big when you
look at the [__] full it's all it's
the the whole gal yeah right yeah yeah I
had friends in high school that were
yeah um you know girls that were 6 foot
6 they had a [__] hell of a time and
actually I would argue that they have a
worse time than short than a short guy
like tall girls have a worse time than
short I learned that early on in [__]
high school back when I was back in
Brazil nobody wants to date the 61 girl
if you're if you're a female and you
ever six foot you're you have a harder
time dating than a guy who's [__] 5
foot4 because here's the thing I never
it never occurred to me until I was
older that people had that women
were that some women were like bothered
about like dudes being shorter than them
or I was it literally never occurred
well I'll tell you what in my experience
literally never OCC based on dating
women and having a but I'm short so
maybe that's why that's only women that
have never dated shorter guys yeah or
good ones I mean I'm only 53 so maybe
that's what it is but if you look good
and you're shorter than her she doesn't
give a [__] if you look good you you
have Charisma and you um you dress nice
and other women are interested in you
okay you can't be average you got to be
above then they don't give a [__] no
they don't give a [__] cuz all that [__]
gets suspended or like put off to the
side well like I said and we've talked
about this before yeah like a lot of
chicks will say like on their dating
profiles or something like that when
they're just kind of like shotgunning
out there into the universe it's like
yeah we want a dude that's six foot tall
or whatever but it's just kind of like
in the wild if they met a dude that was
shorter that was super awesome that was
super funny that was like super hot or
super or something or or was super
charismatic they would actually not care
about that there they're pretty um and
like I said I literally never I've dated
people
from uh my height up until up to 6' five
yeah um and it really did not it I don't
know it just was never something that
occurred to me to be concerned about
yeah some women are very concerned about
height they are but I I can kind of
break if you get him at the right time
it's the right guy you can break him
over
that okay [__] there there have been
in the history of [__] Hollywood a
lot of shorter guys who are like 5'4 53
that were just Lady Killers what was
that one back in the
[__] 30s and
40s he he could dance and [__] he was
kind of like the Michael J fox of his
time I forgot sh what movies was he
[__] oh he was in a lot of those old
[__] Silver Screen movies yeah yeah
but like [__] I forgot what his name is
all I got to PE maybe you'll think of it
long yeah but that dude did [__]
super well and what was funny is that he
did really well with very tall women and
it's because uh very tall women are on
the outside edge of desirability anyway
as far a lot of guys are even if a
dude's 6 foot he's like I don't want to
go over her she's 6'1 or she's six foot
so very tall women actually have it
harder than shorter guys and I think a
lot of tall women kind of know that
so I remember back when I was in high
school back in uh [__]
Brazil
uh at one of the clubs I hooked up with
one of the Swedish girls from the school
and she was [__] uh at the club
because we've been to Club in high
school in Brazil you could go to the
club at 16 and
drink she was probably about 61
she was cute too we were dancing [__]
hanging off of each other and [__]
[__] I was she picking me up like a
baby or whatever you know what I
mean kind of funny but she didn't have a
man nobody was sucking gunning after her
because of the intimidation and I I
didn't really ever feel that
intimidation because a lot of the girls
were taller than me it didn't matter if
she was [__] 510 or [__] 6'1
they're they're both taller than me so I
didn't care I just cared about how cute
they were
maybe that's kind like I said maybe
that's kind of why I didn't care because
I'm short I'm 5 foot 2 5 fo three
something like that so most people are
taller than me so it wasn't really
something that I thought about cuz I was
like I was just used to everybody being
taller than me yeah at 56 you don't care
she's 510 or 6'1 it's so it's like if a
dude was 5'4 or 5'5 it's like he's still
taller than I am so it wasn't really on
her dating profile she's going to say
you got to be six foot something but
that was not in my experience well like
I said I think that people get a um a a
misperception from people's dating
profiles like I said your dating profile
is just your shotgunning it out there
into the universe you don't you're not
looking for anyone specific you're just
like well these are some parameters that
I'm going to lay down so I don't get
this and that but it's just like when
you meet a person yeah all that's off a
lot of that doesn't really apply because
she's looking at you not statistics
right exactly so I think that you know
dating profiles are not a good
um indication of what people are looking
for because it's like man if I had to
[__] God forbid if I had to make a
[__] dating
profile like I said God forbid if
something happened to Tom
which I think I would just give up on it
but um if I did that I have no idea what
I would [__] put on there I honestly
don't I don't
have I don't have a type I don't have a
thing I don't like I said I don't know
you so how would I how can I narrow it
down I don't I I don't know you in real
life so it's just kind of like I height
[__] like that it doesn't matter I have
to meet you I have to meet you in real
life to know if I like you or not you
know what I mean so I I don't know I
don't want to like [__] limit things
by putting like oh I have a height limit
or I have this and that that's dumb it's
you know what I mean it's
dumb I mean I understand why people do
it but it's still
dumb oh Tammy said Mickey R oh maybe it
was Mickey Rooney yeah yeah yeah that's
yeah yeah cuz he was famously R short
and he dated
um what's her
name okay I just based out and I totally
forgot totally
forgot I gotta tell a story Scott still
on there who played who played Dorothy
and Wizard Oz um [__] was her name
[__] uh cuz Tammy says was it Mickey
Rooney M Mickey Rooney that's exactly
who I'm thinking he was a little I think
I think he was 54 5'4 or something I
think which is only about an inch taller
than Mick roone Mickey Rooney was kind
of like the Michael J fox of his day but
he was funny he could dance he was funny
and he was a good-looking guy and Mickey
roone it goes a long way evidently he
just cleaned up cleaned up and he was uh
I could see that mostly with real tall
[__] like model yeah type chicks
Mickey Rudy you got it yeah that's who
he was talking about yeah yeah DV Dragon
said tall tall girls are hard to date
oral sex is tough you have to go up on
them Rim shot dude man my first tall
girl experience man was [__] I felt
like I I don't know was having sex with
a pony or something man you got to get
in the back [__] get your [__]
something to stand on and
[__] girls are cute though wait hold on
I'm going to get the step stool hold on
get the step stool get on your knees
baby just come on bring this [__] down
no I can't get it up that high come on
it's just you know not quite so
complicated with with us cuz we're I
mean I'm probably three in shorter than
the only yeah no we're we're the right
size yeah the uh the only thing the only
thing that was odd being 56 with a
[__] over six foot tall girl was um
from my point of view the size of the
feet I'm looking at the girl's feet I'm
God damn cuz for a long time you kind of
like gross out by feet yeah well it's
just like it would be like a size 12
foot fr the man look at the size of
chick's feet man but you get a over it
you know what I mean you're [__]
young and you got a heart on so you used
to tell me that you were grossed out by
feet yeah you seem to have lost that
though no you got cute feet you got cute
feet I have adorable feet yeah well my
feet are tiny though yeah I have like I
have baby feet I have size six feet DVD
Dragon says 5 foot6 short Kings rise up
exactly it's the short man Mafia Scott's
in the short man Mafia too I think he's
only a little bit taller than me how
tall are you SC I forgot maybe 5 seven I
have really no idea why anyone would be
bothered by that kind of yeah like I
said that's why I think that dating
profiles he's 56 too he's 56 at a so
that's why I think dating profiles are
not a good judge of like what people are
actually looking for because if if I had
to make it I told like when you were in
the bathroom I said if I had to make a
dating profile for for [__] sake which
I would never do yeah like if God forbid
if something happened to you I would
just be like well I'm alone I'm just
going to be a cat lady but um get you a
robot or I'll just get a robot gu you're
a robot or one of those weird
disembodied torsos with the dick on it
be riding on it yeah on the girls making
the content I love here's here's the
thing we we've looked into um sex dolls
yeah for videos some of the videos we
make yet and the weird thing is they
don't really seem to have a lot of
fullbody male sex dolls no they're not
very a lot of the sex dolls are because
women don't buy them and I guess gay men
don't buy them either otherwise they
would have them cuz it's easy to get
laid with you're gay I think sure so so
the only there's a demand for it Mish
sex dolls are just torsos yeah with
dicks on them well they're cheap and and
they're smaller than actual size which
is a little disturbing it's just
something you grind on so it's just kind
of like we talked about it's like well
should we get one of like some of those
for like making videos and stuff but I'm
like they're a little bit smaller than
normal that's kind of weird they want a
lot for them it's $200 just for the head
they're kits yeah one it's a little bit
weird like well and honestly I think
that we were thinking about putting
together like a non-human elf chick was
for the money
super super human proportions just
[__] I think it would be better to
get like a female one yeah because we
could both do [__] with that yeah he
makees some videos on it and we could
have different heads but you know that's
something in the future because they are
kind of cool costumes yeah you're G to
spend at least because the male ones are
a little disturbing yeah that's weird
they do have like some they're all body
male ones but they're near laugh it's
just it's very weird it's I don't I
don't understand why it's just it's just
chest with no arms no legs and just a
dick and it's smaller than actual size
yeah I don't I don't they got girls on
[__] Medi vids making [__] whole
yeah we watched like videos cuz I wanted
to see cuz I was like well is this
something we want to invest in it's like
are there people making videos with this
there a lot of girls making videos with
it and they are but it's just kind of
like oh they're so weird though yeah I
think they're weird yeah I I don't love
that they're not human size and I also
don't love that they don't have a head
okay now some people might be going what
the [__] you talking about okay on some
of these uh video sales
platforms
um sometimes only the woman that is
registered can be on it to register a
male guest is [__] complicated so
she's more going to do toys yeah you got
to do solo [__] because if there's
somebody else like like are many vids
account
both of us are on we can both be on it
so I can upload stuff with both of us on
there but on stream made I can't yeah
and they can only be solo video there's
some customers that don't want a guy in
the shot at all they just want a [__]
female solo video there are male there
are gay male customers that like that
too they don't want another dude they
just want to see the dude doing solo
[__] too they have that it's just it's
just the uh just the tastes of the
customer
now um one thing that is
happening uh is uh the competition
there's a lot of [__] people out
there making these things now yeah so
there is a lot of competition and um I
know people in the industry [__] the
proam industry some you know like the
uh [__] [__] what's his name Bill
[__] um I don't remember if you can
talk talk about his real name and his
wife yeah don't say they're making stuff
and they they their thing is is uh don't
worry about Trends just try to go after
your own customers well see that's kind
of what I've always thought too because
it's just kind of like the way [__] is
now um there's so much [__] out there
yeah we were talking about this before
the show started right cuz Tom was
showing me this like look at this chick
on uh Twitter or whatever it was who
wears these gigantic fake tits just fake
tits but like she doesn't like she tells
everybody they're fake tits I mean
because they're obviously breast
expansion fetish right right right so I
was like okay well I like that but see
the thing is is that there's so much
porn there's so much adult content out
there that and there's so many hot girls
out there that you have to um
distinguish yourself you have to find an
angle yeah if you don't you're just
going to get lost in the morass I mean
there's literally [__] where there's
billions of there are billions of
[__] people Somewhere Out There bil
some girl making money jerking off a
rubber dick with a bunch of chocolate
pudding on it I mean that's how
ridiculous you have to find a niche What
the fu that's the only way you're going
to make any money if you try to like
appeal to the mainstream you're never
going to especially if you're just
coming in now you're never going to
compete because there's so much of it
out there and there's just so much
there's so many hot girls there's so and
they're just doing regular vanilla [__]
or whatever so you have to like find an
angle yeah they got a British
chick out there who's just in her house
by
herself with two or sometimes three big
rubber [__] horse
fallaces on her knees talking to the
camera about what mama's been doing in
the stable in the stable yeah that's her
whole yeah and she's not even really
nude she's
just these rubber [__] yeah and
talking to the camera and she's got a
[__] [__] ton of customers
like that like I said that's all you can
do in this day and age you have to
specialize right if you try to appeal to
a general audience you never yeah you're
never going to like rise because
everyone's doing that right and
especially in porn like I said there's
countless yeah hot chicks yeah on
Instagram on Twitter on whatever there's
countless hot chicks you can't compete
with that you just can't if you're
coming into it now you really have to
have some other kind of angle yeah or
you're never going to stand out just
ever a lot of the ones that are making
big money they look great and they
[__] are are filtering customers from
uh some kind of social media site like
they have a good YouTube channel on a
talk show about this [__] like [__]
old Adam what's his name and his [__]
wife and then his wife starts doing the
black dudes they made a [__] ton of
money on that yeah well that's a big
well that's a pretty common fetish like
the whole cuck fetish
cuz we got asked to do that like many
times yeah a lot of times on stream mate
yeah yeah Scott says a female one and a
strapon don't assume her gender well
that's kind of why like I said that's
why we were thinking about getting um a
female one because I'm you know I I know
you're you haven't been in the chat but
I'm by so um so I would like that I
would I would like for there to be like
a female thing I would I would get into
that but it's just kind of like yeah
it's like I could
do the female thing and I could also
like have a strap on and do that so you
could do all kind of stuff with it
[__] are trying to pay her to
[__] Peg me and [__] and I said man
well there ain't no peg in involved bro
not until we're talking about Harley
money [__] there's a price for
everything you start talking about
millions of dollars all of our
especially like Tammy and Zach and all
those people that have been here for a
long time we keep making jokes about
pegging because I keep teasing Tom about
his life one of these days and Tom's
like oh absolutely not but some people
like hey you guys do how much money
would it be how much would it take for
and Tom's like well it'd be like
motorcycle money so one of these days
somebody is going to come up with enough
money and then you're going to have to
do it I just have to [__] get Special
Operations mode you know what I mean
like I'm like I'm playing a role like
it's not me it's somebody else I be
leather daddy I put my leather daddy
outfit on
power bottoming that [__] pretending
like it's somebody else like it's
happened to somebody else even Ian
Fleming books [__] James Bond was doing
byy [__] in the in the [__] Ian
Fleming's book to try to complete the
Mion because in a most hey you got to do
what you got to do sp most spy is a
[__] sex operative most of them
doesn't matter what gender they
are well yeah just like in [__] okay
just like in the the movie The Jackal
had [__] uh Bruce Willis is in it
he's playing this [__] International
assassin paid assassin he's going to
[__] assassinate this he makes out
with a [__] gay dude to get his ID
then he kills the dude wait which book
is that the
Jackal movie I'm gonna have to you never
saw that one the Bruce Willis oh [__]
classic oh I know what you're talking
about he goes to some kind of I don't
remember if it was a hospital or
whatever but a [__] dude looked at
him [__] crazy like oh wow and it's
[__] Bruce Willis playing the Jacko
goes g he's gay and [__] goes and
[__] makes a move on him gets him up
into his [__] apartment makes out
with him and then just kills him I need
to see that movie yeah it good kills him
and then takes his ID takes his takes
his identity so he needed I can't
remember what he was trying to do I
think that was how he
gained might have been how he gained the
[__] firing position to set up the
[__] 20 mm Cannon to [__] kill
that female politician remember what it
was y'all some of y'all know the movie
you can you can you can drop it in there
but uh no um if you've been listeners to
the show for a long period of time
anytime we got into [__] uh special
operations with the Intel operatives
especially in the Cold War era they tend
to be women they tended to be sex
operatives it's the most powerful spy
that's the best way to get that's the
best to get information is to [__] some
dude and he [__] slowly drips out
yeah just ask some of these [__] was
swall well [__] with [__] Fang
Fang he he was up there in the Senate
[__] a Chinese spy
confirmed Fang
Fang Tammy says sometimes it's not a
joke she wants to see you get pegged
like really badly she just can't she
just can't afford it right now
you you're gonna have to raise some
Harley-Davidson level money we're
talking about 20 grand all right one day
I got relatives in the Stream it'll be
win I got relatives in the Stream it'll
dude I'll get what I want you'll get
$20,000 women always trying to Peg
[__] in the booty I can't
understand it it's this it's this
[__] fantasy of female domination
okay like not to be TMI yeah you've been
in the
booty yeah I go in a booty all the time
so so you try to say turn arounds
[__] fair play sure that's what I'm
saying all right see that's how these
women think well it's fair
right Scott says he motorcycle money
just saying that's a lower entry point
than I I had we had a whole discussion
he's trying to [__] be more of a man
than me we've had a whole discussion I
gotta be realistic about it [__] I'm
talking about [__] not motorcycle I'm
talking about Harley-Davidson level
[__] motorcycle M and I start
considering it because I know me you
start coming at me I know you I know you
too some well it's 20,000 that's a lot
of money
20,000 hm that's a lot of money I mean
yeah like I said it's not dude it's not
like you have to go get like randomly
like Ram roded by like some random dude
in an alley or nothing yeah just you
it's just me just like it's like a
medical procedure it's just
me it's like a medical we've been
[__] for 13
years you know yeah at least yeah
nothing bad's going to happen nothing
bad's going to happen Scott says you
learn something about family every day
it's oh come here every Friday night
you'll learn all kind of stuff there all
kind of [__] funny [__] like I said
we everybody knows everything about us
I'm thinking about that
$20,000 think 20,000 now he's
considering well yeah like I said we've
talked about I think we talked about
this last week or the week before where
he had seen some video about like some
girl that had um no it was a dude
talking about it okay so talking about
girls he knew girls he knew yeah I have
a friend the sex industry but right but
um that had been paid yeah a quarter of
a million dollars yeah to go to where
was it Dubai Dubai and some other places
they were going to fly in a pattern
essentially be in like um group sex
situations it was one dude and it was a
bunch oil tycoon son birthday party
right to be in that like you know you
have sex with the other ladies and you
have to have sex with this dude whoever
was and whatever for like one week and
you get to be like on a yacht and all
this other yacht it wasn't okay
look it was about a girl who lived out
in the middle of [__] nowhere but she
was like a nine she looked [__] great
and she was on Instagram and a verified
account that was a private company
approached her with a [__]
deal we
represent something they gave the guy's
name a certain company and he's the son
of a [__]
oil Baron in Saudi Arabia and he's
having a birthday party and he's
inviting you we'll give you like a
$440,000 down payment all right for a
week of your time you're going to go and
they showed her they gave her an
itinerary or where she was going to go
and
everything didn't say anything about
sex okay but I mean that's what happened
when it got there you could imagine that
that was I mean I would assume that that
was I'm old but I would assume that that
was in play so she didn't believe it but
she said yes and they [__] put like
[__] $30,000 in her account and she
go okay well I'll be there because it
was to buy clothing and stuff and they
were send her plane tickets and
everything so she goes and meets up with
them and it ends up being a situation
kind of like one of those dating
programs where the bachelor you know
what I mean where there there's all
these girls [__] vying for this guy
who's got a [__] ton of money and he was
in his 30s and according
to this guy telling this girl's story he
was a good-looking guy and he was fun
and
everything and they were [__] which
is good there's about 20 girls [__]
vying for this dude this Arabic
dude but uh and they'd party with him
and travel with him in private jets and
they'd go to all these different
locations and like the best hotels and
they party and they were going to get
paid $250,000 ahe at the end of like a
week week and a half like I said and
they all had sex with them but they also
all had sex with each other cuz they
were having like these orgy things going
on and some of them had been on multiple
trips with the
dude the Only Rule was is they weren't
allowed to like post any Instagram
photos of him okay and they couldn't
mention him I wouldn't be doing that
anymore right to be honest now that's
what she's talking about yeah uh and
because we talked about this he told me
about this situation yeah so
so how this [__] went down is I said Jen
said what happens if they came at me
like that I said Jen not that they would
cuz I'm old but you know they were
looking for 19 20 sure I'm I'm way past
that age [__] they were like fing and
Jim was like what happened if they came
at me with that I said Jam I tell you
what I'd be packing your bag
sure and I'd be like yeah I probably I'd
probably go I mean that's a lot of money
,000 a lot of money I Sun baby
discomfort but you know what I mean
[__] you know you're not going to
hook up with this dude because he's
already married that's really what the
[__] deal was they're V and then the
girl he wouldn't be calling me or
stalking me or anything afterwards that
would be good no that [__] don't give a
[__] that would be good [__] what was
what was the what the actual deal was
that the dude was having a we a birthday
weekend but he was already married
that's why he didn't want so he just
wanted to bang all the all and what they
were doing is they had just [__]
agreed to be in a basically Harum sure
is what what they agreed to and uh some
of them had been in there several times
and that particular girl went like
twice and she had feelings for the guy
she [__] thought he was
great but she stopped going she got
pissed because he didn't remember her
birthday so that's how emotional she was
[__] man you don't even remember she's
only [__] yeah I don't remember I I
don't remember my own birthday you don't
remember your own birthday that's July 1
that's what it is I don't remember
anybody El birthday I don't forget I
forget how old I am he does yeah I head
injuries though I got to remind him yeah
yeah but um so that's what that was
about and then
like J's like what and then I was
starting to think about it yeah we were
both like thinking about I was thinking
about this it was kind of like you
remember that movie that came out in the
90s Indecent Proposal proposal where
everybody was talking about like Robert
Redford going to Woody harelson and
saying hey I'll give you a million
dollars to [__] your wife who is to me
more right and they're all like having
this big discussion about it and
everybody was like having discussions
about it I'm like a million dollars yeah
just for [__] a dude one time yeah
and he's not going to keep you is he
never going to call me again do I never
have to see him again yeah can I just
like lay there right and not get
involved
right maybe I I'm not going to enjoy it
or nothing but it's just kind of like a
million dollars joking around and I said
well Jen I think I'd have to be start
packing your bags she's but then I
started flip around on myself I was like
what if that was a gay dude and he gave
the offer to I said I was like what if
he what if he wanted and I was like well
I would be packing your bags because
$250,000 [__] you go earn that I was
thinking I was thinking to myself I was
like
$250,000 we could live on that for a
long time a lot m a long time we could
pay off like half of this house
morgage all you got to do you just got
to let somebody in your booty just a
couple of times a couple of times was
he's probably got a bunch of dudes he
wouldn't like yeah he'd be tired by the
time he got right right right that's
what I I'm thinking so I'm thinking so
I'm thinking how the [__] would I play
that [__] off so I was going well what I
would do is I just kind of buck up like
I was Jay's Bond and [__] and I go get
my best leather daddy [__] outfit out
the [__] closet and just [__] man
up like a [__] and try to flip
that [__] around like like I'm going to
[__] him yeah so no no no no I'm the B
fck I'm I'm the top F yeah that'd be my
only way
out look at Scott Scott says
um he says Scott says 250k I'm gonna be
down for basically whatever yeah 250,000
I'd be like that's a lot of money that's
a lot of [__] money that's a
mercenary job right there I mean now I
will admit we talked about this before
there is some [__] that I would not do
for any amount of money yeah but [__]
a random dude for a week that will never
call me again or anything like that and
if you said it was okay yeah I'd be like
baby I'm take to the airport I'm not
going to have fun or anything like that
because like I don't know this dude I'm
not like that I'd be like no have fun
have fun make as [__] enjoyable as
you can i' have more fun [__] the
chicks to be honest yeah make it as fun
as you can have fun baby have fun bring
that money back and then I like yeah now
we have a quarter of a million dollars
and we can do whatever r a pimps love is
very different from that of a
square you're not my pimp I know I'm
just talking if you ever see that movie
[__] uh idiocracy it was [__]
hilarious you see a pimps love is very
different from that of a square that the
military officer he's putting in his
[__] fake Golds and [__] going trying
to be a pimp that [__] great man
Scott also says 250k buys a decent bit
of
therapy uh and also says I'm mad
thankful my wild Navy days happened
before for smartphones took hold yeah
yeah we're all happy about that um all
of Generation X I'm just like all the
stupid [__] that I did when I was a
child uh and a kid um was not recorded
so not saying I didn't do some [__]
later that was stupid because I did but
daddy's talking about something
there
uh I'm not really sure what that damn I
don't know I know but I I'm not sure
what cont that is I I can read it I just
don't know what the context Kingpin when
Chris Elliot
went and ishma Borg and proposed that
they that Roy Peg ishma for a million
dollars okay yeah I don't remember that
I don't remember that so that's the
whole thing I mean for a million dollars
you better let somebody Peg you for a
million dollars that's a million [__]
dollars I'll be mad d That's a million
dollars like I said that's some life
changing money right it's not like they
love you or they're like hang around or
nothing you just got to [__] put up
with it like it's torture just put up
yeah just put up with it for how many
minutes it takes for them to like you
know yeah for them to Cal or whatever
and then they piss off and they never
think about you again and then you have
a million dollars yeah I know it's not
pleasant I know like I
said you know the whole situation like I
said
I the whole thing about like having to
go and like you know just [__] some
random dude and uh and everything like
that it's like you know I don't love
that but for $250,000 I would put up
with it for a week you know what I mean
I would put up with it for a week and
then' be like hey I never see the studio
come back and we'll buy all kinds of
[__] and then we can have all kind yeah
yeah and then that that old [__]
Saudi oil shake like those [__] but I
don't give a [__] I got the money I
don't care be like we got the money well
and the thing about it is that I well
even if he thought I was a [__] it's
like well I'm not a horor so I don't who
gives a [__] with that random ass dude
thinks I don't give a [__] what other
let me show you me show y'all
something this is my old friend Melissa
Melissa
nin
from Boston okay get another picture of
her here this is all relevant okay it
this is very relevant hold on one second
let me give you another picture of
Melissa that was Melissa me and Melissa
used to hang out over at and Ray back in
the 90s she's still around okay and
these are recent photos of you just
called her today no no no that was
Melissa Gates oh this is Melissa nin all
right and I hung out with her in Boston
okay she was kind of a girlfriend I did
kind of date her but she was mostly like
a
buddy she came to see me in Mississippi
and we went to New Orleans together when
Scott was about how old were you Scott
when you met her I'm G to go eat another
drink yeah Scott was probably about 16
at that time and [__] he was Smit
with her and she liked it oh yeah yeah
[__] [__] Melissa liked Scott that
was [__] funny then we went down the
French Quarter together [__] Scott
wasn't old enough to go to the club at
that time if he was old enough I would
have taken him but [__] uh yeah that
was [__] funny man [__] uh Melissa
was
cute she was leading the young Scott
around by the [__] nose and I thought
that [__] was so funny man that was cute
Scott Scott was like oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was [__] stepping and
fetching for her and everything she
liked you uh she was uh she also liked
having having all that [__] feminine
power over you it's funny but at that
particular time that that
happened me and Melissa were uh we were
just friends we weren't really a thing
and I remember one time [__] she
hooked up with that dude we went to the
club and she hooked up with that other
dude and [__] came back late remember
that yeah but uh I haven't talked to
Melissa in a while probably about a year
or so I'll see what she's
doing the other Melissa I just talked to
today told her that I may be down there
but yeah I was telling about [__]
that was that was Scott's first Gothic
crush with that Melissa right there a
yeah you know too many people Nam
Melissa yeah it was a [__] ton of
melissas yeah we also have a friend yeah
there's a lot of Melissa Melissa there
Melissa N Melissa was
uh she was a uh an
orphan raised by a family I forgot what
state she was from but um she was
uh part Russian and part
Mongolian that's why she looked like
that what's go say Victor says when I
was in high school this guy offered me
$500 to have sex with him when I woke up
there was a ball of plastic hair on the
nightstand turns out he said 500 doll
hairs doll
ha that's a good story that a good story
who made you gay today oh he said
somebody made him gay but I forgot what
it was yeah Scott Victor every every
time we do a chat Victor says something
something made him gay it's different
every [__] time it's different every
time I love the creativity yeah he comes
up with some new way last time it was
90s Kean Reeves I think yeah 90s ke
Reeves made him gay but this time I
don't remember what it was he think can
make him gay I I mean you never know you
never know that shit's GNA come at you
man yeah gonna make you
gay yeah Scott said she was cool as [__]
yeah yeah Melissa was cool okay so
that's a different Melissa than the one
to on the phone today I was talking to
Melissa uh Gates today okay
cuz I know you use my phone today and
you said hey I'm calling
Melissa oh the Melissa that you talked
to last time she's getting worried about
trying to keep no no no it's just like I
don't I don't know who's who yeah no cuz
like I said we also know several people
see if I'm not sure like who's who see
if I got a picture I don't know who
you're talking
to I have a picture but was gay
somewhere picture said I said dating a
tall girl in junior high made me gay
okay so that's what it was yeah yeah I
thought you said something before that
though yeah made you feel like a woman
next thing you know you're flipped over
now you're
gay I feel bad for like super tall girls
in high school though I knew a few of
them they all right I know but it's just
like man like I said they had a [__] of
a time cuz dudes were
intimidated well they didn't want to be
look short next to the [__] that they
were and the girls were like freaking
out it's like oh man I can't wear high
heels I can't like you know what I they
can't do girly [__] because the dude's
going to think I'm trying to be taller
than them and you know it was this whole
thing
so like I said I would submit that super
tall girls have a harder time than
shorter dudes yeah because shorter dudes
can have other [__] to offer like I said
they can be funny or charismatic or
whatever but tall girl no one's going to
even look twice at
that that is the Melissa I called
today okay that's right that's your
first wife right that's my first wife
Tiffany yeah that one and that was the
Melissa I called
today yeah but that Scott doesn't know
her cuz she still lives in the same same
house and everything yeah well she still
lives in the sort of same area as your
dad uh that's a couple hours away a
couple hours hours away
yeah Victor says sometimes short dudes
have big weenies it's it's a lot of
times bro
well Tom is a is a super example of that
yeah I got a video of it you can rent it
you can buy the video you do you have
like quite a large yeah you do have
quite a large
penis Scott says 250k and a trip to
Dubai made me gay Scott said that [__]
yeah yeah see that's what yeah I mean
like I said I would not begrudge anybody
if somebody offered you a quarter of a
million
dollars to go to Dubai and have sex with
some Chic son for a week I would not
begrudge anybody that goth Melissa I
just showed you hey man I talked to her
today I haven't talked to her in [__]
three or four
years she's
maybe late 40s now she just had triple
bypass surgery a couple months back they
took her heart out [__] fixed it cut
[__] out of her
veins diabetes I said deep deep south ch
yeah gained 40 lbs she was embarrassed I
said maybe I'll stop by she no they
don't see me she say I'm so fat right
now I'm so embarrassed and I said it's
okay Melissa come on I just want to see
you again you know she's [__] damn
near married she's been with that same
guy [__] probably longer than me and
you have been
together probably about the same amount
yeah but years you went to see her last
time you went to see your dad yeah yeah
and I met him he was [__] cool he was
real cool he wanted me to stay yeah he
stay hang out I said dude I got to go
back go oh man I just met you cuz he had
heard he had heard about me right you
know so um I might I'll probably stop by
stop by and spend a few hours yeah you
should yeah but
um Melissa was like my [__] sister
Mississippi sister yeah she was a cool
weird cool Mississippi old school goth
chick living in a basically an old
dollhous that her dad built in a giant
dollhouse that her dad built in the
[__] Woods right there near [__]
Gulfport out there past Christian
gulport on vialia road yeah she that
[__] little [__] crazy ass little
house that she lived like some a witch
would live in it went through [__]
Hurricane Katrina and everything she
made it through all that
[__] [__] floorboards fell through
and the Rats came up her [__] dad
came in and fixed the [__] full
boards it was supposed to be a temporary
house that her dad built her dad built a
temporary house there so he would have a
place he and his family would have a
place to live while he built the main
house and the main house that they have
is [__] nice but she still lives in
that little bit temporary house a yeah
but she would go out a little she was
the uh the executive from Hot Topic that
I guys told you guys about a long time
ago who [__] she was like the
regional manager [__] Hot
Topic she came up with the [__] whole
concept of those big ass [__] pants
the jenkos yeah they took jenkos and
tried to make them
die all of us old people they grew up in
the go scene yeah were like what are you
doing that's not yeah what are you doing
with that her friends kind of came up
with that and they were [__] making
fun of it we're going to take Rave
clothing so they're basically trolling
they were trolling that was the early
version of the 90s version of troll well
there was a whole sub genre gravers yeah
gravers they trolled gravers into
existence sure yeah and the [__] Hot
Topic in that time that was around
[__] 98 or 99 had a competition
between all the [__] stores in the
South to see who could make the most
[__] up kid they said look sell some
kid some [__] up [__] take a picture
of it and [__] send it to us who can
make the stupidest looking kid send it
to us on yeah Whoever has stupidest look
kid get a$1 th000 bonus so they're [__]
that's the way Hot Topic used to
op so [__] that's what I always
expected to be hon when you told me that
I was like yeah that to tracks so that
tracks so [__] [__] Melissa took
some kid this is at the [__] what at
the mall down in [__] uh Bay St Louis
or buuy I don't remember it might be
buy took some kid put him in big ass
[__] black jenkos from Lord all right
a [__] striped shirt and they put
[__] high heels on stripper high
heels and then they [__] [__] put
makeup on him and sold him a bunch of
accessories and had him walk down the
mall took pictures of he walked halfway
down the mall and he came right about
people laughing at me it's not it's okay
you're cool they don't understand they
don't understand it they don't
understand it you're way ahead he goes
out to the [__] car like that last
time [__] look man it's not what you
all think think it was man [__] it
was a troll none of that [__] was a
troll see that's what I always
suspected what I always suspected
hilarious [__] as I have said before
look I grew up I you know we're old yeah
I grew up in the 70s and ' 80s when the
90s came along and all of this Hot
Topic
um goth mainstream stuff came along I
was sus about the whole thing thing and
we didn't even have I grew up in Daytona
Beach so we didn't have a Hot Topic
until like later now they did have some
cool [__] I will admit um you could get
some cool like corset is kind of things
there you get some cool tights and stuff
like that but as it went on you know it
wasn't really goth anymore it was just
kind of like some other [__] yeah but
the whole thing with cuz I remember
going to the castle in the late '90s and
early 2000s you'd be standing in a line
waiting to get in and here would be
these
children from my
perspective wearing these gigantic pants
yeah and these the shirts and all the
chains and stuff like that I'm like are
we trying too hard are we trying too
hard I kind of feel like that was so
'90s to me was like a so it was like
such a tryhard decade I like the 90s so
try hard I like the '90s I thought they
were funny so try hard I love the
internet of the '90s especially the late
'90s I'm not a fan I'm not a fan and
like I said um going back over cuz oh
you got that yeah let me see what that
tastes like it's
good well all we have left is root beer
and I didn't know if that would mix oh
that's good that's really good so I put
passion fruit in yeah so I'm doing my
history of horror
video and going going back through the
'90s which is my least favorite decade
for horror although when I was going
back through the history I was like oh
maybe the 2000s were my least favorite
decade but I don't know but like the
'90s were bad too but so I'm like going
back through it and I was just kind of
like the whole thing about it was that
everyone was just trying too hard
yeah I think that's what I didn't like
about it I think that's what I well
that's what I don't like about people in
general stop trying too hard just be
just be genuine just be normal just be
what you're like don't try to be
something you're not don't so I kind of
feel like the whole thing about the 90s
and the two system except the early
2000s everyone's trying to be like
extreme and they're trying to be
like I don't know they're trying to be
too edgy some [__] worked out though and
that's just that's just tell you what
worked I tell you I tell you what worked
out from the '90s when it came to the
ground there's some good [__] from there
was some really good [__] there was I'm
not saying that I'm just saying one of
the things that came out of the 9s in
the '90s mainstream that I really liked
was [__] Evan Essence Amy Lee and
Evan Essence if you looked at those
[__] lyrics that was a Christian band
and written and the lyrics were written
by basically a [__] 17-year-old girl
and those lyrics were over the top they
were over the top emotionalism but
there's just something very sweet about
them and and she could [__] sing me
and Jenny saw Al she's [__] great I
bought him tickets for his birthday or
Christmas yeah to go see went saw them
at House of BL House of bles right in
the front yeah and she and she's good to
this day uh she's had kids now she's
sucking put on few pounds and she's
she's still [__] a cool chick and she
[__] puts on great shows goes to
[__] Japan and [__] sings with
Japanese bands and stuff and just
another southern girl that [__] made
ha it and you look at Amy Lee at her age
and you put her next to [__] Jenny at
that age they look a lot alike I do kind
of look a little you look a lot like Amy
Lee from yeah maybe that's what it is
maybe that's why you like me I showed
pictures of you and pictures of Amy Lee
at a similar ages to my friend sad in
Saudi Arabia he's like yeah you
definitely have a type and I said I know
and I said I got one right here at home
man just like that [__] you know
you're a lot like her
yeah I know yeah same about same size
same breed same kind of yeah same
Southern kind of breed you know what I
mean it's just and uh both dedicated to
your art you're a writer and she's a
[__] singer you know but but real
similar just as you're just as pretty as
Amy
Lee well thank you yeah yeah like I said
I'm not a musician but I write nether
she she just sings I mean I write horror
I my videos my movie reviews my book
reviews stuff like that people seem to
like those so you
know it's all a thing um let me see
Scott says wow I don't know what he was
I know what you're talking about Scott
yeah wow or what I'm not sure what he
was wowing about because that was a
while
back that's what I mean might had
something to do with
uh
um
victure says 90s internet made me gay
this this one is real
yeah look at how look at how cute Jen
looked in what year was this
2010 no 2015 no 2013 I want to say 2012
or 201 maybe Tony took that b yeah how
and I was there remember that sh yeah I
know how could you say that [__] um
Amy Lee was cuter than Jen no Jen was
[__]
cute cute cute I'm cute as [__] yeah
she's still cute you're messing up my
but it was just a just a different
different era I'm just like old cute
you're old cute no no oh Tom yeah no
look no you're going to mess up the
lighting
again that's Jen look how cute lot of
people like that picture like oh look at
that smile yeah a lot of people like my
smile this how and she was not young
there you were uh no I was still old as
[__] then you were 30 something or then
no I was probably 40 then about 40 then
yeah yeah yeah that wasn't that long ago
wasn't that long ago no well that was
after I divorced and I divorced when I
was 38 yeah so that was a couple a year
or two after that yeah so I must have
been 40 yeah at least 40 at least maybe
older yeah our friend Tony took those
pictures yeah look how cute yeah he's a
decent
photographer I always like that picture
yeah it's a great picture yeah he had a
whole
um setup in his apartment yeah he was
trying to [__] you that night though
well I know but that's that's why I went
with you well that's why well I asked
you yeah because he's like he [__] um
you know he had my ex-girlfriend I
introduced
him here's the whole situation about
this I'm going to show youall who we're
talking about we love them we love them
we do they're friends of ours but a
while back Tony is a photographer yeah
and he's like I want to take some
pictures of you and I was like cool I
wanted some pictures for you know [__]
that I could put out there like on my uh
author page and stuff like that so he's
like okay well I'll take some pictures
but I knew what he was like yeah so I
say to Tom you're coming with me because
I know how this is going to go yeah I
know what's going to happen if you don't
come with with me he's going to try some
[__] yeah so Tom came with me so it was
that we actually had a fun time yeah and
he took some good pictures yeah I think
he was he bummed out that you came yeah
I think he was that's them I think he
was bummed out that um I don't see
anything that's
that yeah that's AA my
ex-girlfriend and that's her husband
Tony and Tony I married a wife yeah and
I introduced them yeah me me and AA
didn't really quite work out but we were
still friends and I
introduced Tony to her because I was
accidentally stole a girl off of him I
didn't know he was going out with her oh
my god there whole thing remember that
[__] and I was like I didn't dude I
didn't mean it man I didn't know I
[__] stole a girl off of you
um so I introduced that was me and ala
when we were a
couple [__] can we get that face going
on yeah that was a what year was that
God that must be that's a long time ago
yeah
20 13 maybe no no no that's got to be
before I met you in 2009 or 2010 so it's
got to be before that yeah that was her
she's awesome I love her yeah she's
awesome J Jen's Jen's a good friend of
hers and they actually wanted to do some
[__] video together yeah she's rad I
love her she does she's a content
creator does erotic video and stuff her
and Tony do porn with like other [__] so
well they're like swingers they're
swingers yeah yeah she was not a swinger
at the time I was with her but she was
cools you
know that was her that's her when she
went to Japan she went to Japan for a
while for some kind of [__] thing
you're messing my lighting up yeah
[__] you're lighting up you're
messing my lighting up
yeah oh what I Scott like this that's
aita in [__] New Orleans she's in the
[__] Cemetery down there at [__]
new in in uh New Orleans with bat wings
on this was a long time
ago but yeah I really like her I like I
like her a lot Tony's cool too I mean
yeah yeah Tony's good too just that Tony
Tony will try to [__] your girlfriend
but don't take it personally I mean you
got to watch you don't take it
personally he tries to [__] everybody so
yeah that's just his way yeah so that's
kind of he wants to [__] he wants to
[__] your girlfriend but he doesn't want
you [__] his girlfriend unless you're
a girl see that's that's the kind of
[__] that's the kind of [__] with it
they're constantly inviting us okay so
there's this place in Orlando I got
pictures of them [__] yeah we've seen
pictures videos everything [__] these
girls and all kinds of weird they go to
a place there's a place in Orlando
called
secret yeah the swinger club and it's a
hotel but it's like a swinger hotel yeah
with a pool and all kinds right right
right so you go there you can get a room
or you can just like pay to be there for
a night there's a nightclub there
there's some other [__] yeah we get
invited there all the time and we get
invite they invite us there like all the
time yeah um and from what I understand
we've never been but you can either you
can get a room you can [__] in the room
you can leave your door open other
people wander in yeah that's the whole
thing yeah I don't think there's doors
on the rooms actually well no there are
but like you can you can close them or
open them like they leave it but if
you're in the night club yeah if you're
in the nightclub um or the playroom then
it's wide open like nobody does anything
without anybody's consent it's not like
that but it's just kind of like hey if
you're leaving yourself open yeah we're
going to do that so we get invited to
that all the time and I'm just kind of
like yeah I don't know I don't know how
I feel about
that
so I I'm just kind of um I don't know
ambient about we don't really have a
place in that kind of [__] I don't know
I wouldn't mind going just to drink and
watch other people but they'd [__]
probably that's what me it's just we
know them [__] and they were like
[__] cuz a lot of them we know it
might be fun to like go and just like
have some drinks and see and just like
watch people [__] yeah but then you
might get like roped into [__] and it's
like oh and and then like you might get
roped into oh man here's some old fat
guy that like suddenly is just you know
what I mean and it's just I I don't want
to get in that kind of situation well
the funny thing about it is is that a
lot of those people that are there we
know them well yeah I know and they're
kind of like secretly there okay that
this is a Secrets
photo it's PG so you that's that's Tony
and some other ones but that's and some
other some other ones yeah that that's
that's that's so they just go there
every weekend most weekends
yeah and they kind of do the the [__]
which is fine like I said everyone's
contenting it's fine um but they keep
inviting us and it's just kind of like I
don't
know here's another Secrets photo oh
[__] have I seen this one it's it
doesn't have any nudity in it so we can
show I have not seen that one it's a
it's a reflection of a mirror on the
ceiling the one in the black booty
shorts is
ala yeah that's the that's the ceiling
image of what's going on there so yeah
um there's other ones in Orlando but
that's the one that I know about because
they keep inviting us to
it yeah so like I said it's a hotel
is but you go there and and it's like
you can pay for the night or you can pay
for a
room now they say I read some I was
writing a short story based on this yeah
so it's just kind of like so I looked at
some reviews of the [__] for like from
um you know Yelp and stuff yeah and some
people really dug it and then a lot of
people were just kind of like bro like
they don't even like police because
places like this they really have to um
let's see how am I going to put this
they really have to like kind of police
how like they can't have single dudes
hanging around no you can't have them
around because there's a lot of creepers
right so people are going to like just
show up and like look in your windows
and jerk off and [__] like that so you
can't have that all the time this was
the Tom
Jen Sonia era oh yeah I remember that
yeah remember that picture yeah that's
Sonia with a blue hair yeah yeah so some
people said
that oh J Sonia is that yeah J I
remember that picture remember that [__]
yeah remember that name remember that
[__] look how cute look how cute they
were look how cute there's Jenna onia
look how cute they were J back when she
had her red hair back when I was cute no
back when you had red hair oh
okay okay yeah okay yeah but yeah so a
lot of people complained that they
weren't really
policing the dudes because here's the
thing apparently at this place I've
never been there but what I've heard is
that you rent you get a hotel room and
if you want to you can leave your door
open or you can leave your blinds open
so people can watch you or you can leave
your door open so people can wander in
and do
whatever so some people like iess [__]
right so I guess like some people um and
there's more than one place like this
this is just the one that I'm the main
one most familiar with because people
have asked me to go there yeah but um so
apparently people were want because
they're very very strict about single
dudes hanging around because they know
that like single dudes are going to like
show up and be like hey I'm going to
jerk after like all these like lad porn
you know what I mean so they try to like
not have that but apparently from what
I've heard from the reviews they're not
super stringent about it it's all kinds
of [__] comments here you can listen
to about you bathing in the blood of
virgins and all kinds of [__] wait where
is
that put your glasses on I do have my
glasses on I just can't really see yeah
evanesence was early 2000s after I
graduated high school yeah early 2000s
yeah
yeah Scott says that was no no no no
what Evan Essence was actually late '90s
it's just you didn't know how bright
this [__] [__] is their first big
album came out out in the early 2000s
but no they were doing little stuff in
the in the late
90s you can look on online they were
actually doing little shows and clubs
and [__] and it was kind of Christian
oriented that was the really when you
when Christian
stuff sucked like striper it always
sucked it sucked the only one I don't
know what the deal is the only one that
was good was Evan Essence and it was not
if you were just listening to it you
wouldn't know it was Christian cuz it
was very kind of subtle well see that's
why it's good because you don't because
it's subtle real subtle it's ambiguous
yeah and they just used Christian
imagery sure yeah which like I said a
lot of mainstream artists have used that
you can use that like I said I listen to
[__] Nick Cave all day long and he
uses like Old Testament New Testament
[__] all day long I love that [__]
but the problem arises when you try to
push an
agenda yeah it starts to dominate the
art
and then it's like not so good anymore
that's why a lot of Christian
entertainment yeah that gets ghettoized
into that is not good any kind of
[__] uh political or religiously
[__]
driven [__] media isn't any good
[__] you know none of them it's got
to be it's it's got to be more loose
shit's better when it's open to
interpretation right but because it's
you can listen to it and relate it to
your own situation yeah like it's not
super spe specific you know what I mean
yeah Scott says I don't consider myself
goth because I don't I don't didn't go
nearly as hard as Tom just goth is yeah
yeah you were into the [__] uh into
that damn uh medieval stuff
man I remember that when you were a kid
you were into what Lorena McKenna or
something like that you were into all
that kind of stuff little bit of
death I think I showed you [__] uh
some of that
U oh [__] man I'm getting kind of drunk
I can't remember the [__] names of
bands anymore dead can Dan yeah yeah
just that you were a little bit after a
lot of that stuff happened you weren't
old enough to go to the club with me
man and we were living different places
too I mean the weird thing about it is
that I kind of feel like I was into that
[__] from
birth yeah but it took a long time for
[__] to catch up with me I guess because
in the early 80s when all that [__]
start first started coming out like it's
like oh I saw like [__] early Cur and
all that kind of stuff I was just G oh
there we go thank you you know what I
mean yeah it that kind answer questions
Jan there a [__] ton people are saying
all kinds of stuff Jen are you bathing
in the blood of
virgins to stay so youthful you can tell
us we're in the circle of trust
um no well I would tell you guys if I
was bathing the blood of virgins I would
never kill virgins just to bathe in
that's [__] up I don't know what it is
what is
it uh us staying active and us you
working out and [__] us working out
and [__] doing stuff it might be
genetics too like I said my mom is Mom
stayed young look 70 and she's pretty
young looking still so her mom doesn't
look 70 no way no so I kind of got lucky
in that regard it's
genetics her training schedule her diet
her
lifestyle I think part of it is that
Jenny never had kids because I think
that has a hormonal impact on women I
know it has hormonal impact on men
people don't realize that having kids
impacts men it does uh your testosterone
lowers early you become more DB bod uh
because you have kids it was Nature's
way of getting you to settle the [__]
down and raise childid right right cuz
no one cares about you it's like the
Next Generation sure I wasn't like that
I didn't have kids and I'm [__]
bumping test tasting steroids so [__]
same which is you know and so does she
so uh there's ways to cheat we cheating
everybody looks awesome in those movies
you're seeing they're [__] cheating
too doing the same thing we're doing I
don't even consider it cheating yeah
it's just
like when your teeth fall out you put
false teeth in you just got to fix it
you got to fix it you got to fix it
that's all when your hormones start stop
flow and you replace them it's called
hormone replacement and really if you go
through the black market you know what
you're doing it's not that
expensive just have to know what you're
doing don't do that [__] without [__]
proper education I studied for
years yeah I mean know what you're doing
but yeah I know what you're doing yeah
Tom knows what he's doing yeah and [__]
I let him inject me with things yeah and
my best friend's [__] a biochemist
[__] you know [__] Steve Rouse
he's [__] a doctor [__] so and we
grew up together so I [__] he knows
exactly what I'm doing he wants to do it
but [__] coward is said dude
just [__] inject it you know how it
works but there's something about some
good dudes they [__] have a
damn fear
of doing the leap taking a leap you know
it's a leap of faith but no science is
real if you're inject hormones I mean
[__] that's like science that doesn't
scare me yeah it works like I said
you've been ejecting me for a long time
it's fine couple years now it's fine
very small amounts and it's certain
things only it's fine yeah and honestly
I don't know like I said I don't know
what it is a lot of people have said
that our sex life is awesome and a lot
of it has to do with that yeah CU we're
we feel young and we look young yeah I
don't feel like an old person but it's
like I kind of feel like I don't know it
it might be kind of attitude too because
if from when I was a young age I was
like man I'm never going to be an old
person and I've said on this show before
it's like when I say like an old person
I don't mean like a liter old person
yeah I mean like a person that has like
an old person attitude it doesn't matter
how old you could be 20 years old and
have an old person attitude you know
what I mean so it's like I don't really
mean that well another thing is just you
know I got Scott on my
cousin um in case you're new to the show
the
uh oh [__] where I going with that man
fing the alcohol got to me oh [__] yeah
um
age age
had me and Jan are of a certain [__]
generation where we kind of had the The
Best of Both Worlds we saw the old pre-
internet world and then we watched the
the internet world yeah we watched in
with it going so we understand the
importance of uh Tech you know what I
mean and social media and what its
effects are and how it affects [__]
what the difference it was be before
[__] pre social media so we know we
we know what's happening the Boomers in
general not all Boomers but the Boomer
because actually it was the Boomers that
invented the computers just that a lot
of them are dead now they weren't around
for the social media
era the boomers are not quite makinging
the transition very well [__] we we can
go up to the [__] stores here at
[__] Dollar General store and see
[__] who probably aren't even
Boomers they're probably JX they're
probably our age they're probably our
age and they don't even have [__]
bank accounts or ATM cards and they
don't know how to use they don't how to
use self checkout okay that blows my
blows yeah yeah J what the [__] and I
said yeah yeah that's what I said but un
left I was like what the [__] is said
yeah there a huge line they're waiting
for them for them they are still in
1998 I can't I don't even remember 1998
come on yeah ask [__] Scott Scott's
over at my dad's house it's still
[__] prob 1991 crazy it's 1991 my dad
crazy to me yeah
[__] it's
2024 yeah so with the program so and one
of the weird things about [__] social
media in the internet is that in a way
it's mind expanding if you've done LSD
you know what the Mind expansion is the
internet is actually also mind expanding
because you're aware of things that are
far outside your personal sphere you
know what's going on in other countries
and it's unfiltered you don't have these
[__] corporate [__] news agencies
dictating to you what reality is no you
could meet a user in Saudi
Arabia and see videos that they are
making in their own houses with their
own opinions what's going
on that's actual information okay
because all that [__] adds up all the
little [__] adds up uh [__] cor the
corporate Narrative of reality has
always been a lie because it's just a
way of controlling masses well it's just
a consolidation consolidation and then
there's the big money powers are
involved in what narrative they're going
to sell to the people that they need to
have on their side for them to be in
power well I kind of feel like it's more
like they want the advertisers that too
whoever the advertisers but a lot of the
advertising is going away in
television when you talk about
television the advertisers aren't there
so they're straight up government
mercenaries now they're just
contractors all that [__] went into that
goddamn [__] uh bill that Bush signed
Patriot Act it's now legal to
propagandize the American public and
it's also legal to pay news agencies to
give the narrative that the government
wants to give well that's State Control
propaganda exactly that's the same [__]
the Soviet Union had so why the [__] do
you want to listen to them I would never
listen to them any of those threel
[__] ABC NBC CNN they're all
government
propaganda and the difference between
right and left and Republican and
Democrat is an artificial
difference they did that [__] because
they wanted to give you the illusion of
choice it don't matter who you vote for
it's gonna be John McCain that's what it
is no matter who you vote for John
McCain some milk toast middle of the
road [__] that feeds the the
[__] military industrial complex
that's what it is because that's really
where the heart of the American economy
is giving contracts to Lockheed and to
[__] rathon
and the rich families that are involved
in those so uh just wise up people I I
know a lot of you are listeners know
what's going on I don't believe them me
and Scott we serve the insane
master I'm now fully aware how insane
that Master is it has nothing to do with
the American people or enriching the
American economy or bettering the lives
of American citizens this has it has
nothing to do with that it only has to
do with shareholders and very rich
families go to the restroom J go ahead
yeah all right let's see we got
good all
right yeah Scott says I'm on the cuss
before [__] went to hell yeah it's
honestly
um I don't know I kind of think about
this um a lot and I'm just kind of like
would I want to be a
different age or a different generation
I don't think I would because it sucks
being old it sucks being your 50s
but I don't think I would exchange the
experience of
being just right in between because you
know me and Tom he's a couple years
older than me
but we both spent the entirety of our
childhood and most of our teenage years
without the internet or without social
media and I kind of liked that I
wouldn't go
back um you know I there's a lot of
things I didn't like about back then
everything was much more uh difficult
you know it was much harder to find
information so I wouldn't go back to
that time but I do like the experience
of having been right at the middle of
having spent like essentially like half
your life without the internet and then
like half of your life because the first
time that I got internet
was I want to say
1995 so when I was in my
20s right yeah I was 23 I think I was 23
when we first got like full bore like
internet and I kind of get into that so
I was still young enough to get into the
like uh you know meat of it but I had
still lived most of my life without it
and I kind of think that's a good life
experience because you lived most of
your life without it but now you have it
would I go back and live without it no
no I
wouldn't so
I can't imagine what it must be like to
have grown
up just having that from
birth that must be really well I mean
it's not weird to them but it's weird to
me yeah Zach says I can't these dudes
are still awake yeah been on for four
hours but we still got a [__] pretty
decent crowd in there I'm still having a
good time I we're not going any place
like I said I am getting sleepy though I
am kind of sleepy it's after midnight I
am kind of sleepy yeah but you know
everybody was in
here picture say 1998 was a great
year I don't really remember 1998 what
happened in
1998 I don't
remember I don't remember
yeah all right I tell you what Jim's
glad and shut it down you sure yeah I'll
make it something to eat oh all right
sound good to you oh Tom's going to make
something deep yeah making something all
right all right sh and uh Scott I'll be
up there in a couple days all right so
here's what's going to happen as far as
we know right now um we're going to shut
this down this evening go get something
to
E I will probably do a movie review on
Monday
evening I will probably have to do it by
myself right because you'll probably be
gone I'll be gone yeah probably yeah
I'll be gone so I might also have to do
the Regular Show on Wednesday night by
myself if you're not back yeah but we'll
see how it goes like I said I I said
before we'll we'll talk about whatever
the um topic is going to be yeah so
we'll just work with whatever happens
we'll work with whatever happens I'm
gonna miss you I haven't left
yet yeah I'll miss you too go ahead and
shut it down J so I will do a movie
review Monday night like normal y but
probably Tom here so thank you everybody
for dropping by this evening we are very
drunk right now we're going to go get
something to eat yeah and we will see
you guys or I will at least see you on
Monday and I will try to update you with
what's going on with him all right so
thank you everybody for dropping by we
will see you again on Monday good night